morning routines are one of the most
important things that you can create in
your life and the reason is when you
start the day if you get early momentum
going the rest of the day is often going
to follow in that it's an idea called
entropy everything moves towards chaos
and the only way to combat that is to
put energy into the system you are not
going to wake up and randomly have a
good day you're going to have to
structure your day in a way that sets
you up to overcome all of the entropy
all of that chaos all of the thousand
things going to come at you on a daily
basis that are going to knock you off
course and the easiest way to do that is
to have a routine that you follow every
morning so you don't have to think about
it you don't have to reinvent the wheel
you don't have to wonder or think about
what you should be doing it's just right
there it is baked into the routine by
doing that now you can actually
accomplish the most important things
first the thing to doing your morning
routine well is to optimize for what Tim
Ferriss refers to as the lead Domino
what's the thing that if I did this it's
going to make everything else easier
down the road so number one a morning
routine actually starts the night before
you want to get get plenty of sleep why
because that's going to optimize your
cognition the next thing you want to do
is either meditate or work out typically
I will work out first the reason that I
work out is because it optimizes your
cognition so that everything else is
going to get easier it also dramatically
impacts your energy levels talk about
two things that are incredible lead
dominoes if I'm getting sleep and
optimizing my cognition if I'm working
out and optimizing my cognition and I am
making sure that I have the energy
levels that I need to get things done
now I'm really making sure that
everything that I do after that is
easier Hey Stephen Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to stay afloat I
quit on my business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the thinking that maybe I
can do it too that extra bit of belief
and I still need their stories today and
I'm honored to share them with you here
as well so today let's set some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Tom Billy thank you
enjoy
the next thing that I do is meditate why
because it optimizes your cognition you
want to make sure that you're getting
all of your background radiation the
stress the anxiety you want to get that
as close to zero as you can that way you
can think clearly you get into what I
call a calm and creative state so the
areas of your brain that don't often
communicate are able to communicate get
better ideas that way again lead Domino
improving your cognition lowering your
stress levels making sure that you're
centered and that you've got that energy
to move forward then I'm going to go
down my list of important things I make
that list the day before so I know
exactly what I should be doing at any
one time and again it's a lead Domino
strategy what the first thing that I'm
going to do is going to be the thing
that makes everything else on my list
easier I'm going to do everything that I
can do on the most important thing and
by the way they should always be rank
ordered there is no such thing as a tie
there is a number one a number two and
number three and number four so on and
so forth there's not two number ones
there's not two number twos there was a
one two three four five so on and so
forth I do everything that I can do on
number one once that's now where I'm
waiting for something else or you know I
just have to let it bake whatever then
I'm going to move on to number two I'm
gonna do everything I can on number two
then I'm going to move on to number
three do you set your day up like that
and you're not checking your phone and
you're not responding to other people
because that's letting them control your
schedule and what are the odds that
somebody other than you knows better
what you should be doing to make your
goals come true than you the answer
should be zero because if somebody else
knows better than you we already have a
problem it means that somebody else is
paying more attention to your own life
than you are that would be problematic
get that morning routine down get that
momentum going do the lead Domino
strategy make sure you're optimizing for
energy and cognition absolutely critical
once you know what your goal is that
goal then makes demands and you either
live up to those demands or you don't
and the reality is that most people
don't so even when they have the clarity
and they get into it and their kids wake
them up in the middle of the night and
then they're really tired the next day
they wake up late they're rushing out of
the door to get to work they go their
bosses addict to them they come home
they're super stressed out through all
of that their goal suddenly becomes
unimportant and unfortunately because
life is hard and life is going to punch
Us in the face constantly over and over
the only way that you're going to
achieve your goals is if in that moment
you get more aggressive that you have
those rules in your life that are like I
am doing this every day I know that I'm
trying to read X number of books lose X
number of pounds by this date and that
means by the end of this week I need to
have lost a pound or two pounds or by
the end of the month I need to have lost
five pounds whatever your goal demands
your goal ultimately will be translated
into math so it is very simple what do
you need to do on this day to achieve
your goal do you do it or not it really
is that cut and dry and if you're
looking over your shoulder for somebody
to save you I can tell you right now
they are not coming no one is coming to
help you this is something that you have
to do for yourself and I hope in hearing
all of this you realize why 92 percent
of people fall into the category of I
gave up I quit I knew what my goal was
or I didn't have enough Clarity but I
didn't do the things that I needed to do
in order to cross the finish line it
really is that simple now the great news
is it really is that simple if you just
draw those bright lines in your life if
you make those demands of yourself if
you say I simply must do this to be the
person that I want to be and therefore
I'm going to do it even when it's hard
even when it sucks even when it's boring
I'm going to keep doing this and let me
tell you right now even though what I'm
talking about is achieving goals I
promise you one thing if you set a goal
and you achieve it you will gain respect
for yourself and there is nothing that
matters more and I mean nothing there is
nothing that matters more than how you
feel about yourself when you're by
yourself so if you structure your life
in a way where you set a goal that is
two things exciting and honorable
exciting to you you just want to to do
it other people don't have to tell you
to do it you just want to do it right it
goes back to the whole thing you've got
to want it badly enough and if you want
it badly enough then you're going to
stick with it and if you don't then you
won't most people think that life is
about avoiding the pain I'm here to tell
you right now in a very controlled
fashion it is about really experiencing
the pain learning from it so Ray dalio
the most successful hedge fund manager
of all time has a perfect math equation
pain plus reflection equals progress if
you don't feel the pain you never
reflect on it so my thing is I spend 80
percent of my time focused on the
beautiful things in my life the things
I'm grateful for the beautiful things
that I want to bring into existence all
of it
20 of the time though I'm in the
darkness man I'm in that Tim Grover
Relentless I'm going to make this happen
if I have to break myself and I'm not
afraid to lean into that because I know
how powerful it is now if you really
want to put numbers how powerful this is
they did a study and they wanted to find
out what happens how can we get people
to endure more pain and the punch line
is hilarious so they would take people
and they would submerge their arm in a
bucket of ice and they would just hold
it there as long as you can now at first
it's just cold but after a while it
really starts to hurt and so people
would end up yanking their arms out
they found that people could hold their
arm in the bucket 35 percent longer if
you let them display anger
so put it in they get to that point
where they're about to pull it out and
you tell them yell cuss do whatever you
need and they'd be able to do it they're
the expression of intensity even what
I'm doing right now I can feel myself
ready right I'm ready to strike my
muscles are tense I've got a different
posture I bring my chin down there's
intensity in my eyes like dude I'm now
feeling that because I'm embodying it
right so it makes me really feel that
and so I actually started to tell the
story earlier I hate the gym but what I
would do to make myself work out is I
would my wife would be on the opposite
side of the gym and I would stare at her
and I would imagine her being attacked
by people bigger than me and that the
only way that I could fight them off is
to get stronger there was nothing
beautiful in it I was not worried about
Aesthetics I was worried about saving my
wife and by stepping into that dark
place and because people are like what
are you doing yeah but dude that was I
needed that motivation to push past what
I want to push past pain boredom all of
it and just to really get into it and
get a result but I find that people shy
away from that look to me it's an 80 20
split if you're spending more than 20 of
your time there it will be corrosive yes
it will start to erode your sense of
self because you're going to feel badly
right because I would be saying to
myself you're weak come on like you've
got to get stronger if you spend 80 of
your time doing that yeah that sucks yes
I don't want to live like that right but
not being able to dip into both you'll
just never hit the level of
extraordinary you may be fine you may
even be good yep but you're never going
to be great what is the first step to
getting started in business once you
have an idea what next and how do you
avoid being stuck in analysis paralysis
okay so first the first step in starting
a business is always and forever what is
the problem that you're trying to solve
product Market fit is everything you
don't want to sell something that people
don't think they want you want to be in
a position out of changing Behavior but
of leveraging it what are people already
doing what is a need that they already
know that they have then the game just
becomes awareness you're just needing to
make them aware that your product exists
and you're in the business of getting
people to try it and if there is a known
problem and your solution is actually
awesome
and the Holy Grail of holy Grails that
there is some part of that value chain
that you can give away for free so that
people can try it and see for themselves
that oh my God this is actually better
than everything else and that's the hard
part people want to think that there's a
business trick that they can learn and
that they're going to be able to build
this massive success the reality is
every successful business was better at
something that mattered
than everybody else
you need to get very comfortable with
that that's why I am so glad that there
was no social media when I began there
was no way for me to get in front of a
camera and try to build hype or Persona
I had to build a product and nobody
cared who I was nobody even knew who I
was in the beginning
so I had to focus on what is the problem
I'm here to solve how do I solve it
better than anybody else let me get this
product in people's hands get them to
try it and then knowing that trying my
product was the best marketing ever
because we made sure that the product
itself was awesome
now when you do that now you've really
got something and if you don't have that
then don't start a business because it
is going to be way too difficult you
don't want to end up chasing your tail
you don't want to end up trying to
create a market or get people to behave
in a new way which will finally make
your product make sense
you want to hone in on an area that is
underserved a need is not being met with
a customer that you completely
understand with a product that is better
than everybody else that's the goal now
once you have that idea and you're like
this is it I know this is the one
boom now we're going to go to social
media social media is going to give you
the ability to get people to know about
your product to add value to people's
lives before you try to extract that
value and that's how we're going to
start getting that word of mouth so that
we can give that product away because
remember that's our goal we want to
create something we can give some part
away it could be a freemium model where
we're giving some small part away then
we want you to upgrade or if you're
lucky like I was at Quest and it's a
product people actually eat and so even
if you give them one you know that if
they like it they're going to need
another one the next day and the next
day and so on and so forth and so people
are coming back and now like with impact
Theory where 85 90 of the content that I
create I give away for free and by doing
that and changing somebody's life with
the free content then I'm like now
imagine that you get into one of the
paid pieces of content people make the
leap that whoa if the free stuff is this
valuable then the paid stuff ought to be
even more valuable and since we give a
money back guarantee you have nothing to
lose and so that's been a tremendous and
this win for us is by putting out all of
that free content over years building
that reputation impacting people's lives
becomes very easy then to get them into
the paid offerings also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there you gotta you you must say that
noise you cannot allow yourself to say
that I'm too old ever again I don't care
if you're 98 and you know that you have
15 seconds is Left To Live don't buy
into the myth that you're too old
because that is going to slow you down
there is a quote that haunts me to my
core which is genius is a young man's
game now why is genius a young man's
game part of it is definitely energy
part of it is the naivete of the
beginner but part of it is just that as
you get older you become dogmatic you
start saying like I'm too old you start
buying into the myth that you can't
teach an old dog new tricks the reality
is your brain remains plastic until the
day you die meaning you can learn new
things the human animal is designed to
learn that's what we are designed to do
now yes
when you're younger it's easier you
learn at a more accelerated rate I'm not
denying that but if you lose sight of
the fact you really can learn it at any
age and by the way as you get older you
have wisdom you have better tools for
learning so there's an efficiency to
learning that is not present when you're
young in terms of tools and tactics that
you definitely have when you're older
and so you also have more will more
drive more reason and so if you can
manage your energy on both a
psychological level because your
psychology is going to have a huge
influence over the neurochemistry that
you pump so if you've ever put on a good
song and that energy fills you up you
realize just how much that's pure
psychology baby that song Got You hyped
you secreted dopamine and now you felt
more alive the problem is as you get
older you try things you find the things
that work and the world of things that
the young people are trying which is why
they don't know what the is going
to work so they're trying everything
begins to narrow narrow narrow narrow
narrow narrow narrow until you're like
ah here is that narrow bandwidth that
actually works when you get there and
you think you're at the PIN vehicle you
are my friend that is how people get
trapped by being old
you've got to discard all that
and say I'm going to try things maybe it
didn't work in the past but maybe it'll
work now read voraciously find new ideas
put them to use if you learn something
use it that day push yourself push
yourself to get better to get faster to
learn new things reading podcasts
YouTube videos I am insatiable in my
appetite for knowledge because I am
always shocked one the world is learning
new things and two I'm discovering new
things that interact with my wiring
right we're all we all have about 50
hard wiring so we are not blank slates
so it's interacting with the unique way
that I think about things but it's also
interacting with the things that I've
learned the current climate of what's
happening and all that but if you're not
taking in new ideas then you can't get
new ideas out
so I used to have this formula that hung
over my desk and it said ideas in equal
ideas out you've got to voraciously get
those ideas in so that noise about being
too old that is a self-defeating way to
think about it never ever repeat
disempowering
like I'm too old ever again and then go
out there learn to code become the
greatest coder that ever lived you're 98
you got a long ass beard and you go
better than anybody else and God only
knows what the language will be then but
you're gonna beat these young
whippersnappers and if you maintain that
idea my friend you will stay mentally
Supple and you will dominate dominate I
say so get after it you can learn
anybody can I think that people should
absolutely look at what is it that gives
you more energy because you know it's a
game of attrition you're playing a very
long time Horizon you're going to fail a
lot there's going to be a lot of like
having to figure things out and making
mistakes and a lot of that aversion
energy is going to come in as you
struggle with this or whatever and so if
the thing itself isn't replenishing a
large amount of that energy then you're
really going to be in trouble yeah um so
the doing should be joyful and so I
think the right question for people to
ask isn't what would I do if I knew I
couldn't fail it's what would I do and
love every day even if I were failing
and so when you think about what you
could enjoy failing at now you're on a
much more interesting path right because
okay I can be in here I can fight this
fight I can struggle with this thing and
over time obviously I'm hoping that I
figure it out and I win big and all of
that but if I don't it isn't like
because this is what was going on in the
first company awareness Technologies it
was I knew that I was sort of burning my
fuse and that I was just banking that I
could get rich faster than that fuse
would run out right and I lost and the
fuse ran out before I got rich and so
thank God because in that the rest of my
life hinged and everything turned on
that and you said you know each company
has become more and more meaningful
because of that moment because I knew
that you know one tomorrow's not
guaranteed to any of us quite frankly
tonight's not guaranteed to any of us
and once you know okay I'm on borrowed
time and I don't know that I'll ever be
successful so that you know if you have
a fuse the odds of it running out are
much higher than you finding success so
you have to figure out what is that
thing that I can do and keep doing and
struggle and fight because life has a
certain amount of that no matter what
you do
um
and going back to that you have
evolutionary pressure to work hard so if
you know you're going to have to
struggle at something then you should
very much struggle at something that
gives you energy now what is it that I
focus on and think about that gives me
the energy to keep doing all of this
it's I have a very simple Mission it's
it's simple to articulate how about that
to pull off is going to be
um you know very very difficult but the
the simple idea is that right now in
much of the developed World your ZIP
code is the number one predictor of your
future success and so while I'm not a
huge fan of thinking that IQ is a big
factor in people's success of course it
is
um so if the answer were that your IQ
were the number one predictor of your
future success okay I could begrudgingly
accept that and it never would have
become the mission in my life but seeing
amazing people who I love and care about
get chewed up by the inner cities was
something that I wasn't prepared to just
accept and live with so at first I
thought that I could just gather people
around and say hey I took myself from
you know really struggling emotionally
not knowing how to succeed in business
to being very successful it's ideas it
isn't me there was nothing like
different about me I met minimum
requirement right so there is a level of
intellect that you will need I meet
minimum requirements the vast anybody
listening to this meets minimum
requirements so now I thought okay I
could just gather people around and
explain the ideas they would be able to
go off and Implement them and it would
change their life forever fulfillment is
very simple for me so and it has to do
with the directives that are embedded in
your brain from an evolutionary
standpoint so you must work hard it's
embedded in your brain to acquire skills
that matter to you that allow you to
elevate yourself and others in service
of a goal that's both exciting and
honorable
so exciting and honorable means that
you're just amped about it you dig it so
I dig storytelling just I do and I want
to help people through storytelling I do
my life circumstances have led me to
that the way that I'm hardwired I just
have an over
um an outsized response to stories and
so I'm drawn to that and because of life
experience I want to use stories to help
people so that's very exciting for me
now it's also honorable because I'm not
just looking to make myself rich or be
admired for telling a cool story I
actually want to help people with that
story and I hold myself accountable to
that so when you have that cocktail
you're working hard to Garner a set of
skills that allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people it that's
fulfillment so people can say whatever
they want and I know like if I'm
actually out there every day doing my
best to help people I'm going to feel
good about that now I'm not going to
feel good about people misunderstanding
that that's still going to suck but I
know it's in my heart and so if I'm like
no for real I'm showing up no matter
what people say I really am showing up
to help people then that will give you
the emotional resilience that you need
to see yourself through so fulfillment
is
it's able to withstand even moments of
unhappiness and when you have
fulfillment the thing that you believe
in that you're fighting for then it gets
easier to push through you know whatever
frustrations difficulties the mob coming
after you whatever if you don't have
that and it was you were just trying to
be famous or get approval and it feels
like the entire world is piling on you
you just are like yeah I'm done with
this so there really has to be something
you're fighting for one of the coolest
quotes I've ever heard in my life is
don't sell out what you want most for
what you want right now and I think that
is a quote to live by right there so
that's the big one is really making sure
that you are focused and excited about
what it is that you want long term and
even just having a phrase that you can
say to yourself about what it is that
you want most I think would be hugely
beneficial so often people don't have
that level of clarity so when we're
talking about procrastination just the
raw desire to actually see something
through to the end is going to be
critically important now the rest of
what we're talking about is very
mechanistic but I want to go through it
so first of all anything that's
disrupting the rhythm of your day is
going to be wildly problematic I will
answer the question assuming that
there's just absolutely nothing you can
do about that but I want to sneak in a
quick little answer for anybody else
that finds themselves in a similar
situation if there's anyway for you to
get out of the situation where you are
constantly having the rhythm of your day
disrupted I highly encourage it so we're
about to go through how you can regiment
the chaos but first and foremost would
be to not find yourself in the chaos to
begin with and that really does matter
in terms of when I think about my own
life and trying to be as deadly
efficient with every single moment that
I have
eliminating disruptions is a big one
okay now assuming that you can't
eliminate the disruptions then you're
going to need to start building some
rules into your life so that any moment
where you have let's say that rule might
be if I have any consecutive three
minutes where I know three minutes are
available then I'm going to immediately
do X now that X might be journaling so
you keep um something like Evernote on
your phone and you have a topic
pre-ordained something you already know
that you're going to do and whenever you
have a gap because look some gaps just
aren't going to be worth it so if I had
a 90 second Gap I may not fuss with it
it's going to take 20 seconds just to
get your phone out and get the app open
and have it refresh and all of that but
if you're really hardcore and you say
anytime where I have a three minute
stretch then I'm going to make sure that
I immediately begin doing something
that's productive a big part of making
limited Windows like that productive is
the following so first and foremost is
having an important things list and by
having that important things let's
you're going to be able to immediately
slide into knowing exactly what you
should be doing so that you don't spend
the three minutes just trying to figure
out what it is that you're going to do
so you're going to have that important
things list you're going to know exactly
what you should be doing you're going to
build in some minimum amount of time
where you say anytime I have this amount
of time or more I'm immediately going to
dive into one of the things of my
important things list now important
things this shouldn't all be just these
gargantuan things that require hours and
hours of time you want to make sure that
you have things that you can do that are
long you want to make sure that you have
some things that are medium and you want
to make sure that you have some things
that are short and when you have that
now you can begin sliding into those
some of what you may be doing in the
short maybe researching something
learning more about so you're talking a
lot about film and TV so I can just tell
you right now that I have a YouTube
playlist which I also curate ahead of
time so anytime I've got a brief window
it's what I call transitional moments
where I immediately pick up my phone
take it out go into let's say
screenwriting boom I've already got 20
any videos that are just going to auto
play so I have to select the next one
curate it on that playlist boom I
started going and now I'm researching
another thing that I can do in very
limited Windows of time
is I have specific stories that I'm
going to be journaling on and I might
journal for a minute I might journal for
an hour depending on how much time I
have but every second that I spend
working on that I'm able to eke a little
bit more productivity out of it so
that's huge you're going to need to make
sure that you get sleep that's going to
be really critical and then you need to
prioritize things in your life you
mentioned your wife so for me my wife is
number one now not in terms of time
allocation but in terms of importance so
when I know that there's any friction
there I'm going to deal with that first
when there's um you know I need to
capture Joy or something to really
reaffirm the relationship and make sure
that it is this Beacon of joy and hope
in my life I'm going to do that so
putting your your
um values in life in ranked order is
going to be critically important to you
one reframe your thinking around AI do
not see it as the enemy see it as a tool
you're not going to be replaced by AI at
least not yet you're going to be
replaced by a human using AI so be the
human that places others get control of
the AI learn to use it two figure out
how AI is going to disrupt you face it
head on don't shy away from this don't
run don't hide identify your
vulnerabilities and aggressively Shore
them up with additional skill set three
identify all the AI tools that are
relevant to you and master them learn
absolutely everything you can remember
this is the very beginning of a very
aggressive Revolution that's going to
change everything moving quickly gives
you advantages everything in your life
once you wake up should be dictated by
a routine that you follow religiously
that is optimized to help you achieve
your goals now remember you should set
goals that are honorable and exciting so
it's something you're legitimately
interested in doing again don't let
other people set goals for you based on
what you should want don't chase money
don't uh uh Chase
um goals that are good for the planet
unless you're excited about it now if
you are that's amazing but if you're not
don't get tricked into doing things just
because other people think you ought to
this is where you really want to jump
out of bed you want a spring in your
step you want to be moving towards
something and not just away from
something what is it that you're trying
to make come true in your life that
you're really amped up about go do that
thing so we're not going to lay in bed
we're not going to play on our phones
we're not going to take something in
before we start creating outward we're
going to figure out what the important
things are in our life so don't check
email don't go on social media go
straight to the gym you want to be doing
things that are going to optimize your
body and mind no one is more bored by me
than having to deal with the body I wish
that I could just exist in the realm of
the mind but the reality is that your
mind and your body are completely
interconnected they are organs in the
same ecosystem and if you don't take
care of your body you will tear apart
your mind so be very very thoughtful if
you're suffering from depression or
anxiety and you're not working out like
a fiend that is Step number one there
are certain habits basically all wealthy
people have in common that you guys can
put to use in your life
and the first one is going to be the
most controversial but I could not feel
more strongly about this they make no
excuses they take total responsibility
for their lives in fact many people
that fall into that category will take
responsibility for things that clearly
don't even have anything to do with
themselves
I have said many times as arguably the
most controversial thing I've ever said
but I'm telling you if you adopt this in
your soul and act accordingly it will
change your life forever you will become
an Unstoppable machine
if I Tom bill you were hit by a drunk
driver I would blame myself
not because I don't think that the drunk
driver caused the accident because
blaming the drunk driver gives all my
power away and I can't do anything about
them I can't stop people from drinking I
can't control the way other people drive
but I can control whether or not I'm on
the road I can control how good I get at
defensive driving how much I pay
attention and looking out all of that
all of those things I control so if you
take control of your life and make no
excuses
now you're in a solution-oriented
mindset and people that get wealthy let
me tell you right now all they think
about are solutions how do I solve this
problem because you are if you're
wealthy you must remember your parent
you're paid in direct proportion to the
difficulty of the problems you solve and
if that's true you better get very good
at solving very difficult problems and
if you have something that's holding you
back like I'm not as smart as a lot of
people and that really pisses me off but
the reality is pissing and moaning about
it is not going to make me any smarter
all I can do is go make the most of what
I have I can go learn now I can get
pissed off at my mom I can be angry at
my dad but the reality is that I am
where I'm at from either uh how I was
impacted as a kid in the developmental
years how it's impacted in the womb my
genetics all of that stuff but it's all
done the Dias cast there's nothing I can
do about it but there's 50 of my life
that's completely malleable and so I'm
going to focus on that and I'm going to
like other wealthy people be obsessed
with learning you've got to be obsessed
with learning so you're not making any
excuses you take total responsibility
for your life and one of the ways you
take responsibility for your life is
even if circumstances are against you
even if you really have been dealt a bad
hand you know that you can get better at
things you have the only belief that
matters the only belief that matters is
if I put energy and effort into getting
better I will actually get better now
why does that matter
because skills have utility now why does
that matter because skills that you do
something other people can't do and that
thing that it lets you do is solve
problems that people want solved what if
I said like eight times in this episode
that people will pay you in direct
proportion to the difficulty of the
problems you solve so going out learning
getting skills that have utility allows
you to do things other people can't do
you're going to be able to get money
other people can't get that is something
that wealthy people understand maybe
it's not fair but who gives a nobody's
coming to save you nobody's going to
solve these problems for you and if
you're turning to people for a handout
all you will ever get is what they're
willing to put in your hand
but if on the other hand
you're willing to go hey what's the
hardest problem you have to solve I'm
going to make that problem go away for
you and all I ask in return
is money
and I'm going to ask the amount of money
that's either equal to the exchange for
you or less so that you're tripping over
yourself to buy this thing and that is
precisely how you end up breaking the
time for money equation because wealthy
people understand
you just can't charge enough for your
time in order to make it worth it so as
you can imagine there are people that
offer to pay me a lot of money for
one-on-one coaching but I don't do it
and why don't I do it because unless
you're willing to give me equity in your
company to do it I just can't charge
enough to make it worth the time
so you have to break that time for money
equation you have to be getting
ownership in something if you want to
achieve anything amazing in your life I
can tell you right now you've got to
break your bad habits if you want to
achieve something incredible step number
one is to understand that the way that
you break your bad habits is by letting
them atrophy so you don't spend a lot of
time thinking about the bad habit and
how we're going to break it you have to
find something new that you're going to
put your time and attention into now
there is a bit of both though so it's
going to go like this step number one
you're going to pattern interrupt you go
to do that negative thing you call it
out immediately you stop yourself in the
middle of it if you let's say that you
want to get in shape and your bad habit
is midnight snacking and you're so used
to doing it that you sleep walk out of
bed you open that fridge and you start
cramming things into your face and you
get four bites into stuffing your mouth
most people go up it it's already shot
it's already wasted it's done I might as
well finish the thing not anymore that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever at the
moment that you realize you're doing the
thing that you said that you weren't
going to do you're going to pattern
interrupt say I don't do this anymore I
don't snack at midnight you can say it
with crumbs hanging on your face the
taste of cookie in your mouth
you're going to remind yourself I don't
do midnight snacking
spit out what you have left throw away
what's in your hand close the
refrigerator door swish your mouth out
spit back in the sink brush your teeth
do whatever you have to do to remind
yourself that in fact you don't do that
thing anymore all right that's the easy
part pattern interrupting the new thing
is you've got to have a new habit
develop to develop a habit you've got to
identify something that you want
the whole point to building a habit is
that it's going to get you somewhere
that you want to go if you don't want to
go somewhere badly enough you will not
have the energy that you need to see it
through when you go to the fridge and it
tastes so good when you're eating
the thought of having six-pack abs or
the thought of holding your kid as they
grow up the thought of being able to
walk your daughter down the aisle
whatever it is that's motivating you to
want to get in shape in that moment it's
got to show up and it's got to show big
so the way that we break the bad habits
the way that we let them atrophy is we
get so excited about this new thing that
we're putting all of our time and
attention into that suddenly that other
thing begins to fall away because it is
the enemy of what we want and we
actually want this thing that's why you
can't pick you've got to pick
something that you actually care about
this has got to be something that you
really want now
if your secret question is
Tom how do I build a habit
when I don't know what I want
then the answer is very different then
the answer is you have to find something
that you want and build desire around it
inside of you right now based on the
things that you've encountered in your
life there are areas of Interest that's
it there you're not going to go inside
and discover that you have this hidden
passion or purpose lying within you what
you're going to realize is that you have
areas of Interest you're going to engage
with those areas of Interest those areas
of Interest then why they're turned into
something that you're legitimately
fascinated by it is completely captured
your attention or it won't if it doesn't
you set it aside you move on to the next
thing engage with it until you find the
one that you're really fascinated by
then you're going to go into the process
of gaining Mastery and in the process of
actually getting so good that they can't
ignore you in that process it's either
going to develop into a passion
something where you're actually good at
you've got the whole Greek notion of
Techni where something that you've
worked your ass off to acquire the
skills has used to other people that my
friends is when you fall in love with
something when it really becomes this
Burning passion it is something you've
been Fanning the Flames the whole way it
is not something you're born with it is
not something that happens by accident
and in that passion you're going to
decide at some point
is this sort of a private quiet passion
that I have like I have a passion for
video games I love them you don't have
to remind me to play them but they are
not my purpose
so engaging with that it's very clear to
me I love it I enjoy it it's very fun
but my real purpose in life and I'll
even stick with video games for a second
is to teach other people how to leverage
video games to build a mindset okay and
that focus on helping other people build
a mindset to escape the matrix to see
what happens to the world when
hopefully Millions hundreds of millions
more people now have an empowering
mindset than would have had they not
encountered me and my content that is my
purpose but that was a decision amongst
many things that I really enjoy have a
deep passion for want to engage with am
horrified that I don't get to spend more
time doing those things there are a bevy
of them for me I have a deep passion for
reading I could just sit and read about
Neuroscience all day and I would be a
very happy camper but at the end of the
day everything comes back to the thing I
have decided is my purpose and that's to
pull people out of the Matrix and for a
while I had decided that my purpose was
to end metabolic disease and so it
really is like you make that decision
and you can change from one to the other
if you want I now spend I'm super glad
that Quest is still going uh I will
continue to contribute to that cause to
the content but the thing that I will
say is my blinding driving purpose that
I've decided to put at the center of my
life is pulling people out of the Matrix
so recognizing that it's a decision is
very very key motivation comes in waves
that's the most important thing to
understand is and that's just
neurobiology so that's true for
everybody motivation is it is a very
complicated cocktail of beliefs of
excitement thinking about you know what
you're going to achieve it is how your
calorie count is how much sleep you've
gotten all of these things bundled up
and so it is inevitable that sometimes
you're really going to feel it and
sometimes you're not so a big part of
motivation is always about actually
wanting that thing at the end of the
rainbow so what is your pot of gold what
is the thing that made you want to do
this in the first place and so when it
comes to working out personally I
absolutely hate working out so I
understand anybody that has motivation
for a minute and then ends up burning
out I get that so much I can't even
begin to tell you so here are the things
that I do to make sure that even as
these sort of Ebbs and flows go of my
motivation that I stay on track number
one is making sure that you want that
thing at the end that you're actually
excited about that so you've got to be
honest with yourself about what it is
that you want so often people are
judging themselves for what it is that
they want that they don't double down on
focusing on that thing so let's say that
you just want to look good when you're
naked and that that is the the God's
honest truth about what is getting you
excited about this and what you're going
to want to say is you know this is about
longevity I just want to be healthy I
want to be you know my best self but in
reality you're just thinking about
six-pack abs washboard stomach or the
way you look when you catch yourself in
the mirror what whatever is real or if
you're like me and you're a psychopath
about wanting to live forever and that
really is the thing that motivates you
then lean into that but don't let other
people's judgments about what you should
want color what you actually want
focus on what what is it you really want
what is it you really care about grab
onto that focus on that start
fantasizing about that again spending
time thinking about what it would be
like to actually have that because you
set a word in your question that I want
to take exception to which is that you
want to find your motivation again you
don't find motivation you build
motivation so we're going to build that
motivation back up by admitting what we
really want by focusing on it and
getting hype about it and then we also
want to find a way to really fall in
love with the process so what is it in
the moment in the act of actually
working out that you can get into is it
the um getting stronger for me that was
huge like knowing that I was getting
stronger and I needed to associate
something with that you want to have a
self-narrative around showing up and
doing this thing when you know other
people can't they won't during covet
during lockdown they're getting worse
they're getting weaker you're getting
stronger you're getting better and
people are so weird
about competition
but my friend let me tell you what one
of the most controversial posts that I
posted recently which I did not expect
to be controversial was that I was
talking about business
but I said this is a competition which
is patently self-evident in my opinion
but being willing to compete with others
and to have a self-narrative around
striving and pushing and doing more than
other people are willing to do that will
feed your soul in a way that I can't
convey and people that are afraid to
compete people that are afraid to lean
in people are that are afraid to make
huge demands of themselves they will
fall by the wayside to the people that
can have that discipline that get
excited about pushing themselves being
accountable being consistent because
ultimately those things lead to an
actual outcome meaning you actually do
get stronger you do get better you look
better you have better longevity better
stamina whatever it is whatever that
thing is that you're motivated by you
really can achieve that but you have to
be consistent now I got motivated just
answering your question so I'm very
hopeful that that motivated you as well
motivation comes in waves that's the
most important thing to understand is
and that's just neurobiology so that's
true for everybody motivation is it is a
very complicated cocktail of beliefs of
excitement thinking about you know what
you're going to achieve it is how your
calorie count is how much sleep you've
gotten all of these things bundled up
and so it is inevitable that sometimes
you're really going to feel it and
sometimes you're not I am blown away
that you were able to get a seven day
streak most people go their entire lives
and not be able to string something like
that together so some of what we're
going to be doing to get you back in
that space is to remember what it was
that had you stoked in the beginning so
a big part of motivation is is always
about actually wanting that thing at the
end of the rainbow so what is your pot
of gold what is the thing that made you
want to do this in the first place and
so when it comes to working out
personally I absolutely hate working out
so I understand anybody that has
motivation for a minute and then ends up
burning out I get that so much I can't
even begin to tell you so here are the
things that I do to make sure that even
as these sort of Ebbs and flows go of my
motivation that I stay on track number
one is making sure that you want that
thing at the end that you're actually
excited about that so you've got to be
honest with yourself about what it is
that you want so often people are
judging themselves for what it is that
they want that they don't double down on
focusing on that thing so let's say that
you just want to look good when you're
naked and that that is the the God's
honest truth about what is getting you
excited about this and what you're going
to want to say is you know this is about
longevity I just want to be healthy I
want to be you know my best self but in
reality you're just thinking about
six-pack abs washboard stomach or the
way you look when you catch yourself in
the mirror what whatever is real or if
you're like me and you're a psychopath
about wanting to live forever and that
really is the thing that motivates you
then lean into that but don't let other
people's judgments about what you should
want color what you actually want
so that's the the beginning focus on
what what is it you really want what is
it you really care about grab onto that
focus on that start fantasizing about
that again spending time thinking about
what it would be like to actually have
that because you set a word in your
question that I want to take exception
to which is that you want to find your
motivation again you don't find
motivation you build motivation so we're
going to build that motivation back up
by admitting what we really want by
focusing on it and getting hype about it
and then we also want to find a way to
really fall in love with the process so
what is it in the moment in the act of
actually working out that you can get
into is it the um getting stronger for
me that was huge like knowing that I was
getting stronger and I needed to
associate something with that you want
to have a self-narrative around showing
up and doing this thing when you know
other people can't they won't during
covet during lockdown they're getting
worse they're getting weaker you're
getting stronger you're getting better
and people are so weird
about competition
but my friend let me tell you what one
of the most controversial posts that I
post recently which I did not expect to
be controversial was that I was talking
about business
but I said this is a competition
which is patently self-evident in my
opinion
but being willing to compete with others
and to have a self-narrative around
striving and pushing and doing more than
other people are willing to do that will
feed your soul in a way that I can't
convey and people that are afraid to
compete people that are afraid to lean
in people are that are afraid to make
huge demands of themselves they will
fall by the wayside to the people that
can have that discipline that get
excited about pushing themselves being
accountable being consistent because
ultimately those things lead to an
actual outcome meaning you actually do
get stronger you do get better you look
better you have better longevity better
stamina whatever it is whatever that
thing is that you're motivated by you
really can achieve that but you have to
be consistent now I got motivated just
answering your question so I'm very
hopeful that that motivated you as well
the big thing and this is why I always
tell people there need to be two things
true about the goals you're trying to
accomplish one they need to be honorable
and two they need to be exciting so
we'll set honorable aside for a second
and just focus on being just absolutely
committed out of enthusiasm to
accomplishing your goal and this has
been one of the things that's propelled
me the most in my career is that I
legitimately am excited about the thing
that I'm trying to build and because I
value myself for this sincere pursuit of
this thing that is both exciting to me
and honorable in that it's you know
going to lift people up if I actually
accomplish it and I'm holding myself
accountable to actual results but the
game the game which is the right way to
think about it the game of trying to
turn my potential into usable skills
that can do something tangible in the
world to make that goal that's exciting
and honorable come true because all of
that game is predicated on making sure
that I love the time in the field that
I'm leaving everything out on the field
and I value myself for that I don't
value myself for accomplishing it but I
value myself for actually trying to
pursue it so now you can imagine I'm
saying this stuff to myself all the time
so the weekends are fun and I do wife
oriented things and I'm doing like in
your case I would be doing the things
that are oriented around my kids and I
would love it and I would have work shut
off in my mind and I wouldn't be trying
to work double duty on the weekends I
will be with my kids and then on during
the week I'm gonna be focused on that
goal that I want to be focused on now
here is the catch
if your value system is such that family
time is far more important and exciting
to you than work time you may want to
reevaluate your goals because it may be
that you're trying to convince yourself
to pursue something Monday through
Friday that actually doesn't resonate
with you now if that's true you've got a
couple different options you can either
find a way to make the stuff that you
want to do with your family for your
family that skill set you can find a way
to make that a big part of your Monday
through Friday so that it feels like
more of a continuation of the week it
may not be play time and I get it
everybody has to eat and pay your bills
and so you're going to have to find
something to monetize but there are
often things what I call Universe of so
if family time quality time with your
kids that's a skill set that you want to
be extraordinary at what's a way where
you could be in the universe of that
skill set those things during the week
so that you saw a direct correlation
between what you do during the week and
then that thing that really matters to
you which is your family time on the
weekend so it could be pursuing a degree
in Psychology it could be working at a
daycare it could be teaching you know I
don't know in what way that to you is
sort of the deep passion but that's
another way to approach this there's no
right or wrong goal there is only a goal
that is both exciting and honorable and
gets you amped on Monday so that the way
you're pursuing it through the week is
exciting to to and you don't feel like
you're living for the weekend and that's
where people are often falling apart is
their Monday through Friday is a should
thing it's I should want this I should
pursue this instead of being a
continuation of just the things in life
that they love and the way that I've
tried to structure my life is such that
on the weekend other than spending time
with my wife the most exciting thing
that I can think of to do are the fun
parts of my Monday through Friday that's
how much I enjoy what I'm pursuing and
what I'm trying to build is that sure
there's overhead look I I will say that
my work life is comprised of 60 overhead
meaning things I don't want to do and 40
things I do want to do but those that 40
is so much fun and the sixty percent
serves that 40 so well that on the
weekend I can pull from that 40 and and
just be energized and feel wildly
enthusiastic that it's the best way that
I could spend my totally free time and
that is a sign that you've got things
aligned so that would be my
encouragement if you find yourself
having a hard time revving back up it
tells me that you figured something out
on the weekends that you haven't yet
figured out during the week find a way
to align them being an artist right now
this is like the best possible time to
have something that you can do by
yourself that you can improve on by
yourself that's ultimately going to have
real world consequences for you when we
get to the other side of this so here is
and and something tells me that if
you're playing professionally you
already know this but here is the the
reality about greatness greatness is
about doing the things that are
tragically boring and that you have to
repeat over and over and over to get
better at them in a deliberate way you
don't just want to repeat them blindly
but in a deliberate way buckling down
and doing the things like for a musician
playing your scales practicing your
improvisation practicing your cold
reading all of the things that are very
easy to put off when you have a job and
you're busy and you're making a living
it's it's kind of like typing what they
find is most people sort of their their
typing rate if I remember I like 65 to
70 words per minute is where most people
tap out but I think the record is
somewhere around 250 correct words per
minute so if the average person is
tapping out around 65 but the Delta is
all the way between 65 and 250 you begin
to see like how far you can really push
yourself but people get to a level that
they deem acceptable and they just sort
of stop there but because everybody is
being forced to shut down right now if
you're a musician and you're saying look
I'm not worried about streaming and
going live and all of that which I think
there's a whole question to be answered
about doing that and about how you could
generate even more Revenue by going
online but you asked me to set that
aside so I'm going to set that aside but
right now is that chance to embrace a
level of boredom that most people are
not willing to push through in order to
get to Greatness so in a business
context I always tell people boredom
kills more entrepreneurs than anything
it kills more entrepreneurs than fear
most people they just just can't slog
through sucking at something and sitting
in the discomfort that you get from
doing the things that you're not good at
long enough to get good at even those
things so that you can truly go out and
create art because I don't think you can
create real art until you've mastered
the basics to the point where as Bruce
Lee said you don't think kick you just
kick
and I I love that quote there's another
Bruce Lee idea which is I Don't Fear the
man who knows 10 000 kicks I fear or I
don't fear the man that does 10 000
kicks one time I fear the man that does
one kick ten thousand times and that is
this moment and if you can take this
down time and let go of how good it
feels to perform I have to imagine a big
part of the reason you got into this and
that you did all of the work when you
were younger to get good is because you
love performing so much but right now
that's basically off the table
so if in this moment you can buckle down
be disciplined set your sights on
something very specific that you want to
get good at disciplined practice at that
thing to get good at this on the other
side of this you're going to be far more
extraordinary than you were when you
went in because you no longer have the
distractions of the actual performance
you can just get down to practicing so
flip that switch in your mind and think
all about coming out the other side of
this a beast an absolute monster better
than you went in and if you can tell
yourself that story I'm committed to
this I'm willing to do these things that
other people aren't willing to do and
put in the practice and understand as
you're going through that unimaginable
boredom that on the other side of this
is a skill set that has utility
then this becomes an extraordinary time
but if you keep telling yourself the
story that so many others are telling
which is this is you know a time of
deprivation it's um just lamenting that
you're not able to perform and all the
things that made you love music in the
first place then just because you're
repeating that it becomes a dark time
focus on the other side and you will get
through this amazingly there is a metric
ton of uncertainty right now there's no
two ways about that but you get to
control how you spend your time so when
you think about making the most of this
time if you allow yourself to get
overwhelmed by the uncertainty then
you're going to be paralyzed and you're
not going to make good use of this time
versus if you know what you want to be
accomplishing you know exactly what your
goal is you know hey six months from now
I want to be doing this a year from now
I want to be doing this whatever you
can't control what happens to the world
so literally shut that out of your mind
build the skill set that you want to
build that allows you to do the things
you want to do
at the end of six months a year 18
months two years whatever that is
however far out that you're looking
skills have utility decide what that
skill set is and now we're going to
spend the time building that because
that is something that we can control we
can go in and we can get good at that
thing now when you're on in the process
of getting good hitting plateaus is
absolutely unavoidable what you want to
do is figure out what is it that's
beginning to break down so if you're a
violinist what is it do you have a hard
time reading music cold reading do you
have a hard time with the finger
positioning do you have a hard time with
changing tempos like whatever is the
weakness that makes you feel like you've
plateaued you have to identify what the
difference is between where you are and
where you want to be now oftentimes as
identifying somebody who's better than
you and saying why are they better than
me and not like in a a judgment about
their Worth or anything like that just
what is it that they do better than me
and then begin to dissect it look there
is quite literally much to my dismay
nothing that as of today I'm the best in
the world at now uh drives me crazy when
people do this sure I could sub segment
things far down enough to say that you
know I'm the best person recording
podcast answers from the hours of 4 pm
to 407 p.m in the zip code you know of
whatever
sure but as of right now at a macro
level there is nothing that I am trying
to be the best at that I'm actually the
best at but I don't let it damage my
self-esteem to stare nakedly at my
inadequacies because my self-esteem is
built around entirely being the learner
acknowledging where I'm lacking right
lacking in the sense of there's a gap
between where I am and where I want to
be that's the lack self-defined and I'm
willing to stare nakedly at that and say
cool this person up here is better than
me I want to beat them I want to get
better than them but I also need to
acknowledge what they're better than me
at now can I just get better than them
at that thing do I need to find a
separate thing for me to get good at
right so if I were trying to play
basketball I'm not going to try to beat
LeBron James in a one-on-one he has
physical attributes that I think it
would be next to impossible for me to
counter directly but there are other
things that I might be able to get good
at I might be able to read the court
better I might be better at passing who
knows but you go and identify given the
50 of me that's hardwired that I can't
change and the 50 of me that is
malleable how do I bring the reality of
those two things together in a way that
allows me to perform at the level that I
want so you've identified what it is
you're underperforming at and now you're
going to go into deliberate practice so
there's a book by Anders Erickson called
peak in that book he breaks down the
process of deliberate practice of how
you take the things that you're not good
at not the things you already are good
at which is what most people will tell
you lean into your strengths that's some
you yes know what your
strengths are yes leverage them whenever
you're in a performance situation and
you have to outperform but when we're
talking about practice
we don't want to lean into the things
that we already do well we want to
systematically
break out the things that we're not good
at and find a way to do a a practice
cycle a repetition cycle that allows us
to actually get better this is not blind
repetition this is strategic repetition
designed to give a desired outcome
whether it's being able to reach music
faster you're gonna have to be able to
measure this stuff so figuring out what
it is finding a way to measure it
finding a way to break down the practice
elements into steps so that you get
better at one small thing which stacks
on another small thing which stacks on
another small thing until you're
actually bringing all of these small
things that you have practiced
religiously diligently deliberately to
get better and now when you go back to
perform again you're able to perform at
a higher level so not accepting a
plateau is a big part of it not thinking
well when I've hit this Plateau that
just is what it is and I've reached the
limits I can pretty much assure you
nobody is ever going to reach the limits
of their capabilities before they die
there just isn't enough time so
breaking it down into those smaller
pieces that stack practicing the things
you're bad at grouping it back together
and then going out to perform and not
letting yourself get overwhelmed by the
uncertainty that is the answer let me
tell you why so many people
procrastinate and experience laziness
number one the most important reason is
people just don't want it badly enough
that is the hard truth that not a lot of
people want to face but the reality is
when you're struggling to get something
done you have a desired problem there is
a very famous story that I think
perfectly encapsulates what you have to
harness if you really want to accomplish
something difficult think of somebody
drowning being held underwater and
desperately wanting that next breath of
air is the person lets them up and being
dunked back under and held back up and
dunked back under every time that
they're under and they're being held
under think about how badly you want
that next breath of air you would Claw
at their flesh you would tear at their
eyes if you could get a hold of it you
would flip yourself over you would go
deeper into the water to try to push
yourself back up you would do anything
including kill the person that is
holding you underwater to get your next
breath when you want success that badly
you will find a way and when it comes to
being an entrepreneur when it comes to
being successful that's what I always
tell people success is a game of problem
solving but you have to really want to
solve that problem and the only way to
really want to solve that problem is to
build your desire so people have to
understand everything in life is a
process love
is a process you go on dates I don't
believe and love at first sight lust
sure Evolution took care of that for you
but nobody loves at First Sight you
don't know the person well enough you
haven't done the Reps you haven't gotten
to know them you haven't spent the time
with them you haven't developed love
that's why we have dating that's why
first it's dates and maybe not a lot of
commitment it's just getting to know
them and then it's like whoa we're
getting a little bit more serious and
then it's an engagement and then it's
the wedding and then it's the actual
life live together it is a process love
even changes colors and textures as you
go so that in the beginning it's a very
lustful all-consuming drug-like effect
you can actually put somebody
in an fmri machine and scan their brain
and at the beginning in that passionate
love phase there is no difference on an
fmri between somebody who is in love and
thinking of the person that they're in
love and somebody who's on cocaine they
are identical scans
but over time that changes into
something more mature and I would say
more wonderful more sustainable more
incredible now once you understand that
desire in and of itself whether it's for
another person whether it's for a goal
is a process of building desire then you
realize that you can go through that
process you can build up that desire so
when you think about that person having
their head held underwater you can build
that level of intensity in your life to
want something so badly the only way
that you're going to do it the only way
that you're going to escape laziness is
by attaching meaning and purpose to that
thing that you want you have to want it
for a reason as Simon sinek would say
you have to start with why why do I want
this thing and you're tapping into the
evolutionary drivers that you have
embedded in your brain that are going to
compel you to get better
that's a huge part of this whole process
to serve not only yourself but the group
and get to the point where you can
translate your potential into usable
skill set so when you're doing those
three things when you're transferring
your potential making it usable skill
set that's allowing you to actually make
progress it's something that you care
about and serving not only yourself but
other people now you're going to get
into this positive feedback loop that's
light falling in love you're going to be
building that desire because you're
getting good at something progress is a
foundational pillar to human happiness
if you're progressing okay this is
evolution embedding something in your
brain you have a desire to progress
period end of story if you are a human
being you have an embedded deeply
embedded desire
to get better you will never feel a
sense of progress you won't feel good
about yourself you will have a profound
sense of disease if you're not improving
why because that was Nature's Way of
ensuring that you went out and did the
hard things that you would need to do to
feed your family to keep the group
intact to protect yourself from the
devastatingly vicious nature of nature
nature is doing its best to kill you at
all times okay whether it's from
starvation exposure to the elements or
being attacked by a predator we were at
risk constantly throughout our
evolutionary past and all of those
directives that nature had to give us
and implant deep in our brains to make
sure that we went out of the safety of
the cave to go get that next meal to go
find a mate to fight to raise our kids
to make sure that they had kids all of
those things that nature had to embed in
our brain still exist in us today and
they govern our wants desires Behavior
so if we don't take the time to build
add up to Fan those Flames to get us
hyped about this thing that we want to
do for whatever reason if we don't do
that then the laziness kicks in which is
the flip side of the evolutionary coin
so side number one you better get out
you better go do something you better
hunt you better take these risks you
better protect your family you better be
a tough nut that is going to contribute
to the group otherwise you're going to
get ostracized you're going to get left
behind and you're going to die laziness
is about yo this is hard finding
calories is tough you've got to go out
and forage hunt kill Chase
defend yourself against this thing that
you're trying to take down and once you
get those calories it was a lot of work
and oftentimes you had very little to
show for it especially if we're talking
plant matter which from a caloric
standpoint is not very dense and it's
not like it is today where we have Farms
everywhere you had to literally hunt and
forage in dangerous spaces in order to
get those calories so you had to have a
competing desire to chill so you've got
this desire pushing you forward to make
sure that you do hard things to make
sure that you're progressing
contributing getting better but then
over here you've got this weird ass
completely contradictory desire to chill
because the brain if nothing else there
are two things that just gobble calories
and that is muscle and brain and your
brain by far is the hungriest thing in
your body it's something like two
percent of your body weight and takes up
20 to 25 of your caloric intake just to
run your brain so you can imagine if
you've got muscles gobbling calories
even at rest you've got your brain just
mowing through calories to keep you
alive to leverage your intelligence then
you better have a directive embedded in
your brain that once you've gone out and
done the thing whether it's hunt protect
mate whatever that you then relax so
you're always going to have these two
competing desires it is a very weird
part of The Human Experience so to
overcome that laziness you've got to
have a very compelling reason to go out
and Hunt especially when the grocery
store is right down the street and for
very cheap you can get plentiful
calories you can swipe left or swipe
right and decline or find a potential
mate right everything has gotten so easy
you have to have a compelling reason to
go out and do these hard things but if
you don't then you have this profound
sense of disease because again progress
is a foundational pillar of human
happiness so people procrastinate
because nature is telling them to
procrastinate they are lazy because
nature is compelling them to be lazy and
if you don't build the desire to
overcome those things if you don't build
that up walk that process do the things
that you need to do to Fan the Flames of
Desire then you won't you will chill
you relax
because that's how nature designed you
so you have to go down the process of
building desire now the process of
building desire is very simple and I
will walk you through it it goes like
this you're going to tell yourself your
why I am doing this for this reason I
want this goal for this reason for me I
want to build this Mega Media Company
because I believe that the only way to
break the relationship between your zip
code and your success is through ideas
that it is a mindset problem a belief
problem a value system problem it is not
a money problem you can actually just by
where you live dramatically increase the
likelihood that somebody will remain
poor generationally okay that's an idea
problem that's a mindset problem it's a
it's a way to think about the problem
problem it's not an IQ problem plenty of
smart people it's an idea problem since
I believe that and I believe that the
best way to get ideas across is through
story I'm building a media company to
help people people like the people that
I have known and loved that did not
succeed because they had the wrong frame
of reference now the idea of frame of
reference is beyond the scope of today's
video because I have known extraordinary
people smarter than me that did not end
up having success that they could have
had if they had that right set of ideas
I have dedicated my life to building
this Media company that gives me a
pretty compelling why they're people
that I know and love that I can think of
when it gets hard and I'm exhausted I'm
tired and I do not want to keep going I
don't think about money I don't think
about adulation I don't think about
recognition all I think about is those
people having a better life or their
kids having a better life and that is
what propels me forward or I flip to the
dark side and I think about the people
that want me to fail again this may be
outside of the scope of what we're
talking about today but I have these
things that I tap into that fan the
Flames of my wanting that make me want
it
badly and when I can capture that sense
of wanting the success the way that a
drowning man wants that next breath of
air then I have the willingness to fight
to keep pushing to do the thing
recognize that in this Dynamic you're a
student and not a teacher and this is
hard man this is really hard for people
but this is the real stuff like this is
where you have to recognize me as a CEO
I've got to recognize when I'm the
student and so I'll put forth an idea if
an expert in that space is like that
doesn't make sense for this reason I'm
like respect this isn't my area of
expertise
but when I know something then I'm going
to go to the map for it and so you you
want to co-create but within the context
of a meritocracy so never lose sight of
that otherwise you can get paralyzed by
trying to protect everybody's feelings
this is where you come to be hardcore
this is where you come to be resilient
this is where you come to learn where
hey we want your opinion we are
desperate for we don't value ourselves
for being right we want to hear it but
if your idea is bad we're just going to
say it's bad and by the way I want you
to tell me if you think my idea is bad
I'm not above that nobody's above that
we've got a goal we're going for the
goal and anybody that's serving that
goal that idea is going to win every
time
but if all you want is to be heard and
understood then you're gonna get mowed
over you have to be more resilient than
that you have to be you have to be like
I want good things for you I want to see
you become a badass in your life
but that means you have to get
really comfortable
with being wrong with taking a chance
and failing with and then people telling
you yeah that didn't make sense and it
didn't make sense for this reason and
then now you've got more information and
you can move forward
so yeah I mean call this a warning
toughen up toughen up toughen the
up buttercup I literally have a t-shirt
that has the initials for that as a
reminder to myself
I don't need people to
hug me all the time pat me on the back
congratulate me cheer me on
I want to be elevated I want people to
want me to win
but when what I'm saying isn't going to
work I want somebody to tell me and I
have a core belief
any idea that can't withstand criticism
isn't a good idea
by nature is not a good idea
you've got a hunger for criticism to
find out if your idea is good or not
you've got to seek
seek
disconfirming evidence
you've not you shouldn't pursue
Yes Men
you should pursue
as Abraham Lincoln said A Team of Rivals
you don't want people who are trying to
destroy you but you want people who
think differently than you you want
people who see things you don't see and
you want to celebrate those differences
so often
moving forward
is about the friction between
styles of thinking
and you've got to covet that friction
and most people are just trying to
eliminate it most people are just trying
to surround themselves with people that
think like they think
that's dangerous
that will not take you where you want to
go
so I need a cool name for
hardcore
rivalistic
co-creation
because it's not co-creation in any sort
of hey everybody everybody come and
let's do this as a a democracy
this is let's let these ideas battle
and
I don't want deference as the CEO in
fact I ask for people to criticize my
ideas publicly and aggressively now I
don't ask them to do that to other
people because most people are not
prepared for that but I am and I want to
set the tone because I'm obsessed with
my goal I just want my goal to come true
I want to win
and to win you have to get really good
and to get really good
people have got to play against you with
everything they have but as a teammate
this is a team
not a family the thing that I love is
that you're using the word build because
that's exactly what we're going to be
doing here you're going to construct
what you want your life to be you're
going to break it up into different
hours and segments so you know when it's
go time and then you're going to build
rules into your life that mandate that
you show up during those times so I have
a whole host of rules in my life they
can be small simple rules like I get out
of bed in 10 minutes or less they can be
more profound and impactful goals or
excuse me rules and I have a rule in my
life where Monday through Friday if I'm
awake I'm either working or working out
so if I were doing something like you in
this situation I would say okay these
two day two hours or five hours however
much time it is that you want to
allocate to the business you're gonna
say I am working on the business during
these times I'm going to tell myself I'm
going to tell other people that way
there's accountability then I'm going to
score myself at the end of that session
did I show up did I start when I said I
was going to start did I go hard the
whole time time and I'm just going to
give myself a rating every day depending
on where I'm going how I did that day
was I distracted did I have flow was it
a great day a bad day and by doing that
I'm going to hold myself accountable so
I can see over time that I show up when
I said I was going to show up what was
the score that I gave myself for staying
focused staying on task and getting
things done and then the third thing to
really make this stick
you've got to find a way to be excited
about what you're doing and oftentimes
when people come and they say that
they're having trouble making a new
habit stick the reality is they just
don't want it badly enough and when you
realize that that's not an indictment on
you as a person that's a simple
statement about the fact that desire is
a process so you don't there's very few
things in your life that you just sort
of automatically are excited about most
of things if you really want to kick ass
at something you've got to build a ton
of energy into getting excited about
that thing now that comes in a couple
different forms number one is your why
why are you doing this so it might be
hey my husband and I were really excited
about this this is going to be our path
to freedom and building something with
him like this means everything to me and
I couldn't be more excited more honored
to be working side by side with my
husband to build something to show each
other what we're capable of to take care
of each other to you know give ourselves
what we we need to build a family
whatever you're gonna make that why
you're gonna say it you're going to say
it with enthusiasm it's what I call
embodying what you want to feel so if
you want to be excited when you're
telling other people when you're even
talking to yourself when you're talking
to your husband you're actually going to
let yourself get hyped up there's a
mechanism in the brain that says whoa
hey we're all hyped up about this it
must actually be worth being hyped up
about and it becomes a self-reinforcing
loop so we've got our why and then we
want to make sure that we're putting the
identity into it that we want to get out
so if we want to be the kind of person
that shows up and works hard then we say
I'm the type of person that shows up and
works hard and you're going to lean into
that and the why that you have with your
husband you guys are building something
you're excited about it you're telling
other people you're embodying it and now
you've got the identity statement if I'm
the type of person that does this I see
this through and you repeat that
cocktail over and over over and over and
following it up with that score and all
of a sudden over time and it will take
time because it is a process but over
time you're going to stick to it because
it means something to you and your
husband you've got the rule about
showing up you're rating yourself on how
you did that day you're feeling good on
the days you killed it and you're
reminding yourself to dig a Little
Deeper on the days where you don't and I
promise if you just work that process
over and over and over two weeks a month
into this it's just going to be second
nature you're going to be showing up
you're going to be excited you're going
to see it through one of the things I
think people don't understand about
being a CEO is that ultimately being a
CEO running a company is almost I mean
it's 70 percent people I mean the
strategy is definitely important but man
momentum isn't about moving fast or I
should say it isn't just about moving
fast it's about getting a group of
people pointed in the same direction and
moving fast and so understanding how to
Galvanize a team and get them pointed in
the same direction is really really
critical so in this specific time number
one is leading by example always and
forever if you want to do anything when
people are involved whether it's kids
whether it's somebody you love that is
um there's a piece of advice you
definitely that desperately want them to
take and they're not taking it whether
it's your company the answer is always
first and foremost lead by example that
is critically important so you want to
be hopeful you want to be optimistic you
want to show them through your behaviors
and your actions time and time again
with an inhuman level of consistency
exactly how to fail base adversity now
you don't want to you don't
want to lie so you want to make sure
that you're doing the work to make sure
that you're keeping yourself hopeful and
optimistic now how do we stay hopeful
and optimistic we have to have certain
beliefs in place and we have to have
certain rules in place so first of all
as it comes to rules I know that I
always need to be moving forward I can't
ever be afraid to make a decision that I
would rather be running a thousand miles
an hour in the wrong direction than
standing still okay that rule has served
me very well now why is it better Tom
you're running in the wrong direction
that's way worse than standing still
not true the reason that you never want
to stand still is there's zero progress
made when you stand still when you move
you're at least learning even if you're
moving in the wrong direction failure is
the most information Rich data stream
you will ever encounter let me say that
again
failure moving in the wrong direction is
the most information Rich data stream
you will ever encounter meaning you're
going to learn a lot so now when you
turn around and you start moving in the
right direction you're making a huge
amount of progress so even though yes
you have to backtrack it's still far
better than standing still and not
learning those lessons so that is huge
so you have that rule now beliefs you
need to believe that if it doesn't
violate the laws of physics then you can
solve the problem what happens is most
people stay in this Frame of Mind where
all they can see are the problems and
right now there is an avalanche of
problems it is so easy to get mired in
the problems
but if you have a belief that as long as
it doesn't violate the laws of physics
this is possible that any obstacle can
be overcome that you just have to figure
out what it is that's going to allow you
to go over this obstacle under this
obstacle through this obstacle around
this obstacle whatever but you know that
giving up is not an option now it's like
cool hey even if I fail even if I mess
up I'm going to learn so there's some
hope there's some optimism right you can
meet your team with a truism something
that you actually believe you can use
Jocko willing's language which he says
anytime something goes wrong his only
response is good the enemy is bearing
down on us good we don't have enough
equipment good and because he meets it
with that he stays in a solution
oriented mindset now you always want to
be in a solution-oriented mindset when
all you're doing is focusing on the
problems and the most Sinister thing
about excuses is how valid they are so I
get it you have every excuse in the book
for things to fail to not be optimistic
to not be hopeful I get it and it's all
real we are going through the most most
devastating time for a business ever
and how do I respond to that good
because I know in this there's going to
be a solution and I'm going to figure it
out where a lot of people are going to
break because they're not going to be
able to get their head in the right
place so my team can see that I'm
hopeful I'm optimistic because I have
that belief because I have the rule to
be moving forward to figure this out to
not be afraid to fail and they see me
with that like almost naive optimism
always moving forward but they also see
me learning from my mistakes reorienting
and moving forward again if you can do
that you're actually going to get
results and nothing is more hopeful than
results what I learned long before I
actually became successful was that
success wasn't going to change my
insecurities and I think most people go
into it thinking that success is going
to eradicate their insecurities they
look at somebody that's successful with
this admiration and they think when I'm
that successful I will look at myself
with that admiration and it doesn't work
like that so and what's super
interesting it's not surprising at this
point this would have surprised me in my
20s but like I said thankfully I learned
these lessons when I was still
struggling
is that you know your insecurities are
going to go with you wherever you go and
the name of the game is really about
skill set and skill set in a few
different ways skill set in there are
things that I want to accomplish in this
world and I must get good at them but
then there's also skill set in managing
my own mind and that that is the the
real juice so
um you gave me that poster outwork
everyone and when I was writing a
message on it it's like
to outwork everyone
there there is a certain thing that must
be true in your mind which is you have
to know that all you have is this moment
and so success is not something in the
future where you will cross a Finish
Line and feel forever the way you've
always wanted to feel which is what
people think
success will feel exactly like this
moment whatever your life is right now
if you in if it's a mess I could give
you a billion dollars and it would still
be a mess and so understanding the name
of the game is really to optimize the
way that you respond to your environment
the way you respond to your challenges
the way you respond to difficulties
that's it one I believe doubt is a gift
let me say that again I agree doubt is a
gift man if you know you're going to do
something that you will stick with it
you're not afraid to Pivot or change
directions whatever but that you know
you're going to go after the things you
care about you're going to go after them
hard and you're not going to stop when
you get tired you're not going to stop
when you get bored you're going to stop
when you when you're done like when you
know that about yourself then doubt is a
gift and so man I actually wish more
people in my family would doubt me at
this point my family they don't doubt me
externally like they don't vocalize it
they may all doubt me like crazy but
they don't do me the kindness of letting
you know exactly so the reason that that
is a gift is because I believe that
human beings are wired to leverage two
different things one the beauty of what
you're trying to create the people that
support you and love you and want to see
you succeed like that's amazing that
feels good it's going to give you energy
and I think you should spend eighty
percent of your time there
there are times however
especially when something gets really
hard really painful that and and I've
talked about this before but if you're
doing a research on pain tolerance the
one thing that they know universally
will allow somebody to tolerate more
pain is anger
actually expressing anger so if you put
somebody's arm in a nice bucket make
them hold it there like At first not so
bad but then it really gets to the point
where like this hurts and when it gets
to the point where it hurts if you want
something like 30 percent longer if you
let people go
and like really Express like anger and
rage they'll be able to deal with that
30 longer so there is something you're
able to Marshal the body's resources
when it gets really hard so in those
moments that's when I turn to the people
that hate on me that want to see me fail
the doubt that I can do it like and use
that in that aggressive dominant way to
really push through and like under no
circumstances will I let that person be
right so that's incredibly powerful now
the second part is they're doubting you
so much that it's beginning to hurt your
own mind so now here's the thing one if
somebody is chipping away at your
ability to believe in yourself you need
to distance yourself from them now this
gets really hard when it's family but
it's absolutely critical to me like if
my family were bringing me down with all
the love and compassion in the world I
would let them know hey I can't be
around this level of negativity so we
have to come to an agreement either
you're just gonna stop
like keep it to yourself or I'm going to
have to spend less and less time with
you so let me be very clear with the
Rules of Engagement are I love you like
let's really make it hard mom
I love you Mom I love you more than you
can imagine I love being around you I
want to spend time with you but the
things you're trying to do to protect me
because her intentions almost certainly
are good the things you're trying to do
to protect me are actually eroding my
confidence I would not words like this
these exact words okay this is the exact
conversation that I would have with my
mom
so it's beginning to erode my confidence
confidence is one of the most important
things that anybody needs to cultivate
if they're going to go on to be
successful so I fully understand that
you only have my best interests at heart
that you really want to help me and you
want to make sure that I don't make a
mistake that can be very detrimental to
my life in my career and where I'm
headed so I understand that those are
all really really beautiful intentions
but they're having this unintended side
effect so because of that either need
you to stop or I'm gonna have to spend
less and less time with you which would
be utterly heartbreaking for me so let's
agree to disagree let's agree that when
we come together that we're going to
talk about positive things beautiful
things wonderful things and then if she
can't help herself stop spending as much
time with her it's that simple it's not
easy I get how painful that would be but
you have to and when she then calls and
is like you don't come around as much
anymore you say we had the conversation
I was brutally honest with you what I
need to protect my self-confidence I
know that you don't mean to do it but
you're still doing it I can't be around
it so until you can figure that out and
let me tell you all the times where you
were saying this out of the other and
again
I'm not questioning your intentions I
know your intentions are good because
that's immediately where she's going to
go but I'm just trying to protect you
like I say the same to God they're not
really negative why are you taking them
negatively this is your fault
you can hear words like that and so you
just need to be abundantly clear I have
a line in the sand I love you of all the
empathy and compassion
but I'm not gonna be around that so and
then as you distance yourself she will
change her behavior or she'll entrench
if she entrenches you know everything
you need to know about her mindset
that's toxic whether it's your mother or
not and then if she doesn't entrench and
realizes whoa like even if I believe to
the core of my being that I'm not being
negative those things are perceived as
negative and that's one thing that you
can say that'll lighten the load hey
maybe those things really are positive
but just so you know I'm interpreting
them as negative they're affecting me at
a visceral level as negative so for me
to keep coming around they have to be
excised from our relationship period
simple if you are already in a job
you're making some money there's no
reason to quit your job and all of that
like keep that keep paying the bills but
in terms of what's that real Vision that
you're trying to build don't like nickel
and dime yourself with like I'm gonna
have three things it's like pick a horse
write it right so let's just beat this
analogy to death you're in a room
there's a thousand doors your job is to
shut 999 of them and walk through one so
don't plan for failure because then your
mind is thinking about all the things
that you don't want you get what you
focus on so if you're like hedging and
like planning over here like instead
take our boy Richard Branson's path
which is I'm gonna launch an airline and
I'm gonna protect myself from the
downside so I'm going to make Boeing
agree contractually to buy it back if my
Airline doesn't succeed so there's no
reason not to protect yourself from the
downside there I'm a huge believer in
that but in terms of like what is your
path what are you trying to accomplish
what is the thing that makes you feel
come alive like do that like don't try
to have a bunch of different things
you'll be so distracted you won't do any
of them well so pick one thing go hard
and allow for the like emotionally
prepare I may fail spectacularly in an
ugly horrific fashion
but I've done everything I can to
protect my downside I really believe in
the thing that I'm doing and I really
believe that I'll learn from the failure
if it comes I'm not going to think about
it I'm not going to plan for it I am
literally
I'm I have a why there's something that
I believe in so much that I'm prepared
to give myself to it completely and I
think that that notion of give yourself
completely to it like I am not
conflicted about what I'm trying to
build here uh which is why I don't mind
dedicating seven days a week I don't
mind spending an inordinate amount of
time on it I got you know my wife and I
did it together so that we could be
growing together like um spending money
on it it's just not a problem because I
know exactly what I'm trying to do and I
know why I'm trying to do it do I still
want to strive enough to make it worth
not going and doing that peaceful
stress-free life which for me would be
writing just write full time I have
enough money I never need to work again
ever not a single day of my life so
every day that I choose to go to battle
I'm choosing to go to battle and so the
second that the answer is no I actually
it isn't worth it anymore then I would
go do that and I would just write and
knowing that I have that in my back
pocket is
extremely liberating so I know at any
time I can stop I can detach I cannot
continue to pursue this and that has
allowed me it's like this magic trick
that allows me to carry a lot more
weight to deal with a lot more stress
because I know every day is a choice and
so that allows me to have fun it allows
me to remain playful it it is like when
I think about
how much stress I've taken on in my life
with business
I wouldn't have been able to do it if I
couldn't imagine a life that would be
just as awesome
and so there is a parallel life where
I'm a writer and I chill and spend time
with my wife and you know whatever learn
language is and just travel around
whatever like that'd be awesome I would
love that so
um I just love this one a little bit
more but if I if this diminished in its
Joy I've got this other thing that would
be so dope so yeah I don't have any sort
of like oh my God what would I do and I
remember so I've proven this stuff to
myself and look never teach something
that you isn't like you're not living it
the every word out of my mouth I live
and I realized that I could very easily
just
detach myself from the success the
achievement the whatever because when we
left Quest it was like huh just done and
it wasn't hard for me in the slightest
like Lisa really was part of her
identity so for her having been a
founding member of quest like it was
hard like in fact I still think she sees
it as like her child whereas like people
will almost remind me oh yeah that's
right I did build Quest I don't think
about it it's not a part of my identity
it's just not my brain isn't wired that
way I don't
um
I don't cling on to things like that so
for me it's like
I want to feel good about myself when
I'm by myself I want to have fulfillment
and I want to do things that I love in
and of themselves and because and and
this is the one thing that haunts me in
fact this like I say this I think people
think I'm kidding but I actually worry
about this in myself so I have one thing
in me that is
problematic it's the very thing I have
to struggle against in business like I'm
constantly having to course correct when
people hear me teach the opposite of
this is because it's the lesson that I
need to constantly remind myself
I really believe you can do anything you
set your mind to
but not everything
and that really bothers me and I'm not
sure why but I have something in the way
that I view the world my belief system
my value system uh the Natural Rewards
that I get for
um like even in this podcast we've
covered a lot of weird things and I can
talk pretty deeply about a lot of
different topics
because I love that I want to be able to
go deep on a lot of different things I
don't want to do just one thing
and so that is the the one thing that
haunts me is I I can
I could give something up and go do
something else very easily my identity
is not tied to this that or the other
um but I want to do everything I want to
do why the question I get asked the most
is Tom how do you find your passion
and I walk people through the process
you don't find it you build it
now one thing that I've
I worry about is because all of our
minds are different and because there's
a region of the brain that I just
recently learned about for determination
where they can hit you with transcranial
magnetic stimulation hit the region of
your brain that deals with uh
determination and you'll be like I can
do it I know I can do it what can you do
I don't know I just know I can do it so
they can actually trigger this sense of
like I won't stop I'm gonna do it but
you have no idea what it is that you're
not going to stop doing
so there's all these weird things so
anyway there's a region in your brain
for motivation which only reinforced
this idea in my head that maybe I'm just
really good at building desire and so
over my life I re when I react to things
very strongly and then when I like
something I pour myself into it and I
remind myself how much I like and I tell
other people how much I like it and I do
it in this embodied way where I get
really excited
and so I've reinforced all these things
in my mind that I really like like I
really like Japan man I really like
anime I really like manga I really want
to make like those essay anime videos
that people do and like get into some
really obscure anime and I want to watch
every anime on Netflix and like write
books about that and write books about
why as a storytelling format it's just
different man like I'm obsessed but I
also want to learn Greek that'll be dope
learning Greek like with my wife I'm
super passionate about that at one point
we were going to move to Greece and I
was going to learn I promised myself at
one point I would get published in Greek
like this whole thing I also want to
write a book this mindset stuff man it's
really like a big thing for me but by
the way nothing gets me like
storytelling so I really want to tell my
stories but I also like video games so
it's like yo
so all of these things speak to me at a
level that's like screaming passion
where I am passionate I could live an
entire life where I was an anime scholar
I didn't discover anime until I was in
my 40s but now I could live I'm not
kidding I could become an anime scholar
and live an extraordinarily joyful life
so I have to be really thoughtful and
people that take my course uh hear me
say this a lot you're standing in a room
with a thousand doors your job is to
close 999 of them the problem isn't
finding a door to walk through it's
shutting the doors and only walking
through one
that's the hard part and so my life has
been a never-ending series of
frustrations that I can only really
excel at one thing at a time but it's
not confusing to me that every 10 years
I've completely reinvented myself money
can't buy happiness I'm sure you've
heard that a thousand times but I want
to tell you why it can't buy you
happiness but why people keep chasing
money because people are always going to
chase money and the reason people are
going to chase money is because it is
extraordinarily powerful but it can't
touch how you feel about yourself
so I think that people have been told
lies about money like we were talking
about earlier but one of the lies that
you've been told is that money isn't
powerful it's not going to make you feel
the way that you want to feel and the
truth is it isn't going to make you feel
better about yourself but it is a great
facilitator and so if there's something
that you want to build money is going to
unlock that money can make you feel
amazing that you can do something
incredible with your uh your time your
opportunity your knowledge you can build
something extraordinary that is this
economic engine that serves people I
think entrepreneurship is turning your
potential into skill set in a way that
allows you to build this ongoing
economic engine that allows you to
create something that improves people's
lives that to me is entrepreneurship and
that's awesome that feels amazing
so when he's more powerful than people
think
but it doesn't make you happy what makes
you happy is striving to add value to
people's lives to improve every day
those are the things that are going to
make you happy so even if you're
pursuing trying to create a business and
that business fails and you end up not
only not making money you lose money
the failure will suck don't get me wrong
but when you're going all out every day
and you're improving and you're helping
people and you're bettering their lives
and you're sincerely pursuing getting
better so that you can serve people in a
way that feeds you and gives you more
energy than it takes that is the juice
the greatest thing that life has to
offer you is the following okay this I'm
telling you this from the position of
somebody who's made a lot of money
the greatest joy life has offered the
highest amplitude joy that life has to
offer is the following
you are working very hard you are
scaling a mountain and that mountain is
incredibly difficult I don't mean any
literal Mountain you're building a
business you're working to become a
great athlete whatever you are working
your ass off it is hard you were on this
Mountainside you have frostbite in your
fingers you can barely hold on but
you're going you can't believe it you
look down it is a terrifying drop if you
fall you die it's nerve-wracking man the
stakes are high but you decide you're
going to keep climbing you're going to
keep climbing and the moment where
you're working your ass off but you can
see the ledge you're about to get to it
it's all working everything that you've
been busting your ass it's actually
happening oh my God and if I get to that
top and I push myself up it's you know
it's it's success it's a buffet it's an
orgy it's whatever it's something
incredibly exciting that you have just
been so amped to get up there to
that is way more exciting than the
success the having of whatever it is
that's on your Mountaintop
it's that moment there where you're
clinging to your fingers you're clinging
to the side of the mountain with your
frost bitten fingers
and it looks like it's going to work
but it hasn't paid off yet but if it
does pay off
it will be extraordinary
that dream that moment it's all working
and if I pull this off my dreams come
true that's better than your dreams
coming true
why
because the way the human mind works
you can never eat a meal
so satisfying that you're never going to
be hungry again
you can never drink a drink so thirst
quenching that you'll never be thirsty
again
you can never have sex so good that you
never want sex again it's just not the
way that it works we have this internal
hunger that nature has given us to make
sure that we keep going and we keep
getting fed and we keep
getting water and we keep procreating we
have to keep doing all this stuff so you
have from an evolutionary perspective
buried inside of you an insatiable drive
to keep going so you can't ever have
that thing even happiness is fleeting
you can't have happiness you can't hold
on to it it's never going to be yours
forever
it will come in and out of your life
but the things that create happiness
Improvement
sincere Pursuit
doing something you're passionate about
helping other people
those are the things that are going to
make you feel the way that you want to
feel let me tell you in my 20s I don't
know about you but in my 20s I was a
mess in my early 20s I was so lost
frustrated afraid
insecure
overwhelmed
paralyzed I mean it was it was a dark
period in my life
that's the nature of your 20s now in my
20s as old as this is going to make me
sound in my 20s the internet barely
existed so we certainly didn't have
YouTube there wasn't people putting out
content that would allow me to
re-contextualize my world the fact that
you already know the quote that success
is going from failure to failure to
failure without a loss of enthusiasm you
were so much farther ahead than where I
was
now I'm going to use an analogy of love
if I may one of the things I find most
interesting about love is that
in love
you are opening yourself up to being far
more easily hurt
when you are in love it's a very
vulnerable state you have opened
yourself to somebody you've given
yourself over in a way to that person
and now you are far more easily hurt
they know your insecurities they could
weaponize them against you
and when heartbreak comes along
it's very tempting to Turtle up
and to protect yourself
but then you're closed off from the
things that make love valuable in the
first place the very thing that makes
love worthwhile is being able to be open
like that to somebody to be vulnerable
to somebody and the thing that makes
love so extraordinary
is that even when you get hurt
the people that can open themselves up
again and approach somebody
without the baggage of previous
relationships are the ones that end up
finding that beautiful relationship that
ends up being worth the vulnerability
and worth the sacrifice and speaking
from experience ends up being the single
greatest thing in your life
now if you learned nothing from the
Heartbreak I understand why it's scary
to go into the next thing
but the idea here the very way that we
bounce back from failure is by looking
exclusively at what we can do
differently
and when you look exclusively I'm not
saying other people didn't do something
that maybe it's
maybe any rational person would say it's
all their fault maybe the list of things
you gave us is literally you were just
the world's unluckiest human being
but the reason that we're going to say
good the reason that we're going to look
at this like Ai and samples the reason
we're going to remind ourselves that
success is going from failure to failure
to failure without a loss of enthusiasm
the reason that we're going to think of
that love analogy and be willing to open
ourselves back up
is because we're going to figure out
what we could have done differently
we're going to see what can I improve in
my skill set what did this catastrophe
reveal about my strategy and whenever a
strategy yields a result different than
the desired result then you know the
strategy is by definition wrong
and I want you to own that doesn't mean
you're a bad person okay but it does
mean that your strategy wasn't working
go back to AI right it's wiggling around
it finally realizes oh I need to hit the
ball Okay cool so now I'm going to track
the movement of the ball and I'm going
to adjust my paddle to be there okay
cool I gotta oh I actually see that
hitting it on the sides is far more
advantageous than hitting it in the
middle because once I clear a path on
the side then the ball can bounce around
on the top and Destroy bricks far faster
than any other strategy okay amazing but
you had to First have the reaction that
that failure was good
good because it revealed the flaw in my
strategy and because I'm playing the
long-term game I'm going to open myself
back up again I'm going to allow myself
to be vulnerable again I'm going to
let the wound hurt as much as it needs
to for me to learn the lesson
no more not going to beat myself up over
it I'm not going to end up in a death
spiral of Shame
but I am going to recognize that I could
do something different the next time and
get a different result
that to run the same strategy and expect
the result to change is as Einstein said
the definition of insanity
so that's what you have to do here you
have to recognize that this thing that
you consider the worst thing that ever
happened to you with the change of
framing is actually the best thing that
ever happened to you and if you change
the question that you ask about this
and say how did this help me what did I
learn from this or what could I learn
from this and how can this improve my
strategy moving forward then all of a
sudden the frame of reference changes
the emotion the way you feel about it
the dark energy that's around it begins
to change because you're stoked right
this is good all right I'm going to
learn something from this and it's going
to be XYZ and maybe you only get
incrementally better and you try again
and maybe you fail again and you get
incrementally better and all of a sudden
if your life is anything like mine your
20s were getting kicked in the face over
and over and over but getting a little
bit better at blocking a little bit
better at avoiding and then finally in
your 30s you begin to find your footing
and then you turn into beast mode late
30s early 40s and now
you feel like you can really
move the world
it's exactly what it feels like when you
understand how your own mind works how
the minds of others work and just sort
of the nature of the world
it's really incredible but the only way
to get there is to flounder around to
make horrendous mistakes and say good
we're now dealing with the physics of
the human mind and my obsession is to
get people to understand that you are
having a biological experience now why
do I want you to understand that you're
having a biological experience because I
want you to understand that the brain
reacts a certain way and you can
actually insert yourself into that and
change your
approach framing the way that you react
and in changing those things you will
change not only the way you feel but the
outcomes that you're able to get and so
I want to introduce you to Victor
Frankel and cognitive behavioral therapy
so Victor Frankel said between stimulus
and response is a gap
and how we choose to react in that Gap
will determine the rest of our lives now
if you don't know Victor Frankel he
wrote a book called Man's Search for
meaning he wrote that book after getting
released from Auschwitz okay this is a
guy that survived multiple concentration
camps and he was a neuroscientist and
his ability to explain
what is happening Inside the Mind of a
human during something that catastrophic
is breathtaking hi Tom I love the show
you've mentioned previously that as an
entrepreneur you've had to battle
extreme laziness and personal
disengagement how did you overcome this
Challenge and win the battle for your
mind all right so
um at some point we're gonna need to
like have a mechanism where I want
people to guess the answer that I'm
going to give because I know there are
Die Hard people right now that already
know what I'm about to say and the
answer is identity that is it so you
have to put in place things about
yourself that you are going to make true
so it usually starts that it's something
that is not true about yourself but
because you believe at least I do that
even identity is malleable and that you
can change it at any time I just started
telling myself I'm the type of person
that I'm the type of person that does
their work I'm the type of person that
gets out of bed after 10 minutes I'm the
type of person that follows through I'm
that you know whatever like those things
that you want to be true about yourself
like close your eyes imagine the person
that you want to become uh watch a movie
be inspired by somebody you read a book
be inspired by how that person is what
are traits that you can take into your
life I mean this is why we're doing
impact Theory because we want to create
the kind of content that shows people
these are the types of traits these are
the outcomes of those traits that you're
going to want to bring into your own
life life and then do the social
commentary on it to show people how to
extract that information and really put
it to use in their own life so be
inspired by somebody something so that
when you close your eyes and think about
the person that you want to be of
something very specific that you can aim
towards and then begin to Brick by Brick
bring those traits into your world by
saying I'm the type of person that so um
I would say things like I'm lazy by
nature but I'm the type of person that
overcomes this nature so I'm the type of
person that despite being lazy I get up
on time I do my work I push myself I
don't relax until my work is done if I'm
during the week if I'm awake I'm either
working or working out it's just like
you start doing all these things and for
them for you not to feel like a total
ass like you have to act in accordance
with them otherwise you have to remove
them from the same things that you say
about yourself that you get to take
pride in that you get to tell other
people that you do and I've just never
found that lying about stuff feels good
so it's like when it's
um not true then I just don't say it and
so when I really want to say something I
really want it to be true about myself
then I know that I have to force myself
to act in accordance with that and so
identity identity identity identity and
values Drive Behavior period I've been
here for almost six years and
desperately want to leave but don't have
a skill set to get me away from this
industry so I'm miserable and it's hard
to hide what I'm feeling how can I cope
here while I build up other skills thank
you
okay what would I really do I have the
cheap cheesy answer which I'm going to
give you really fast and then I'm gonna
we're all gonna give me like seven
seconds to just sit blankly and think
um my cheap and cheesy answer is that
um I would start looking for what's the
ideal industry that I want to be in and
I would identify that and I would then
say okay like vision board it hang it on
the fridge whatever like I want to get
into this world I'm really excited about
deep deep and passionate and then I
would start nights and weekends working
to acquire the skills and I would set
myself a goal and honestly a year is
plenty of time a year is plenty of time
for you to get enough skills that you
could go into an interview and convince
them that you know what you're talking
about and it's worth taking a shot on
you even if that means taking a pay cut
all right so that's kind of answer that
we've heard from me a thousand times
it's very true it's very real and that
may be exactly what I would do but I
really want to think about this for a
second
so I'm fascinated by how much of the
culture can you change from within and I
think it's hard as hell I think it's one
of the most difficult things that anyone
can undertake which is really trying to
flip people but I really want to know
like if you couldn't leave like if for
five years you had to just grind it out
to get the skill set that you wanted to
acquire
um what would it look like to find a
path to happiness inside the company
here's what I would do I am utterly
convinced that people will recognize you
if you get good enough and I would start
getting so good at my job that people
would want to um steal my ideas so that
would be step one I would want to put
myself in a position where my managers
are stealing all my ideas because now
they're going to have fear of loss
whether they say it or not if you're the
one actually generating the ideas
they're gonna have fear of loss also if
you can execute against that then
they're really going to be afraid to
lose you now that puts you in a position
of power second of all and that that
power is going to feel good right so
you're going to be progressing you're
going to be getting better that's going
to be feeding your your confidence your
self-esteem which is very very helpful
when you're dealing in a difficult
environment then I'm also going to never
ever ever engage in Gossip or anything
like that and I might now I'm not sure I
would have to really read the situation
because you don't want to come across as
a total douche but one thing I might
start doing is go the next time
somebody's like being really gossipy
about somebody I would say you know it's
really interesting I'm practicing the
saying I heard this piece of advice on
this random guy's web series and he said
you get what you focus on it's really
interesting so while that may be true
about that person
um I've I'm trying this new method of
flipping my criticisms into compliments
and I don't know you guys might think
I'm crazy but what do you think about
this and then I would compliment that
person or just get out of that
conversation but if I thought I could
pull it off without being a douche and I
thought I might be able to begin swaying
people's
um ways of being and I trust me I know
that that would take a very long time
because humans are prone to gossip it is
by the way one of the ways we transmit
ideas so you may not ever be able to
stop the gossip and we may not even want
to as a species stop the gossip but 80
20 right 80 of the time should be about
the things we're excited about cheering
people on totally amped up super excited
for them so because I'm such a huge
believer in the principles which is only
talking truth
um not saying things behind somebody's
back that you wouldn't be willing to say
to the face I would just start
implementing that in my own life and I
would walk people through I would tell
them why I'm doing it
um
I really could go on and on about that
and I'd be so interested to see if that
would really work in real life
um but I don't think that you have to
choose between those two so I know that
on the other hand nights and weekends
getting the skills to get out
um that you can do and also honestly
what I would do is cut your expenses to
the quick so that you don't need as much
money so that you can leave sooner in
turn for somebody nights and weekends if
you can go part-time do it and then
start interning for the industry that
you want to be in on the day or days
that you're able to free up or go be a
freelancer I don't know what industry
you're in so I don't know how easy it
would be to freelance
but that would be incredible but I would
get out of the toxic environment as much
as as rapidly as possible there are
almost certainly a lot of things that
you're doing that are going to keep you
broke the first is what we were talking
about in the last question it's all
about financial literacy do you know how
money actually works as somebody who
came to this game really late I
understand how easy it is to be educated
to be dare I say intelligent and still
not actually understand how money
actually functions and so you want to
make sure that you're taking time to get
financially literate the next thing is
and some of these are going to be so
basic and people don't do them
you need to stop spending so much money
most people live paycheck to paycheck
even people that are making six figures
live paycheck to paycheck it's something
like two-thirds of people that make 250
000 a year still live paycheck to
paycheck so the goal is instead of
flexing on how much money you make you
want to make sure that you're living
below your means if you want to
dramatically reduce the amount of stress
in your life and set yourself up for
Success you want to make sure that
you're living below your means now as
you begin to live below your means first
the first habit you're going to want to
introduce is that you're going to start
saving some of your money so of course
there's going to be amount that you're
going to allocate towards your living
expenses your house payment or your rent
your car payments Insurance all of that
stuff food but then you want to make
sure that automatically you're saving
money if you're not automatically saving
money then you're walking down the path
of remaining broke so you want to make
sure that you're living below your means
and you want to make sure that you're
automatically saving money now once you
have saved up enough money that you have
somewhere between 6 and 12 months
of emergency cash on hand
if you get sick if you hate your job any
of that stuff is exacerbated a thousand
fold if you're living paycheck to
paycheck because now you've got nowhere
to go there's no way for you to be able
to weather that storm and so it's what's
known as a threshold event everything in
your life may seem like it's going well
until you hurt your back and you're
unable to go to work for uh two months
and you were living paycheck to paycheck
and now you're in financial ruin or God
forbid you get a diagnosis and you end
up with medical bills and you go
bankrupt from that that happens so
frequently so you want to make sure that
you have six to 12 months saved up now
once you have six to 12 months saved up
now we want to start thinking about
investing now if you're not investing
you're going to be getting eaten alive
by inflation now a lot of people are not
thinking about inflation
and the reality is even in a good
economy
you're looking at inflation being around
two percent now right now as we're
recording this inflation is about eight
and a half percent so you don't want to
count on it being as low as two percent
because that's not always going to be
the case now the crazy thing is most
people don't understand what inflation
actually is so inflation is your ability
to buy something goes down every year
that's the same as losing money every
year so imagine if you have a hundred
dollars inflation if inflation is eight
point five percent like it is now the
next year by the next year because it's
happening every day by the next year you
don't have a hundred dollars even even
if you saved it didn't touch it it's
locked away in your bank account you now
have the equivalent it'll still say a
hundred dollars but that hundred dollars
now only buys you the equivalent of
ninety one dollars and fifty cents okay
that's inflation so you're buying power
even though the number stays the same
the buying power is going down so as of
right now as we're recording this you
would need to make
eight and a half dollars every year in
order to stay at the buying power of
your 100 okay so saving money even
though I just told you to save six to 12
months you want to make sure that you
understand that you can't just sock all
of your money away and think that it's
going to stay and this doesn't haunt
anyone more than me I get it because
investing is nerve-wracking
but if you don't invest you're not going
to be able to keep up with inflation if
you don't keep up with inflation you're
going to be losing money over time and
if you're losing money over time that
nest egg that you're going to Hope takes
care of you at the end of the day isn't
going to be there for you and so you
really have to be thoughtful about how
you invest here's
this may be the biggest problem we face
as a society
people don't remember that skills have
utility they let you do something
you don't learn to build a house to
impress your parents you learn to build
a house so people can live in the house
you build and once people understand
that like holy you're building this
house so somebody can live in it build a
home in it have a family be sheltered
from storms like it's a real thing man
and so all of that effort and energy
went into I have the chills right now is
so you can create that moment for
yourself for other people it is it is
something so much more than going to
architecture school which maybe you went
to because your parents wanted that and
they they were Architects and so you do
that thing for that and you forget that
the whole reason you became an architect
was to build houses and so once people
realize oh I'm putting all of this time
and energy to build these things because
they let me do something what do I want
to do what do I want to give what do I
want to create when you look at skills
from that perspective it is like
it is being a superhero it is being a
superhero you're going to collect these
abilities these abilities actually let
you do something the fact that Superman
can fly allows him to save people allows
him to do things other people can't do
we all have this opportunity to become
capable of the extraordinary to be able
to do things other people can't do and
that feels so good there's a gap between
who people are and what they tell you
they want to accomplish because in the
beginning I hired everyone everyone
right not because I'm super smart and
thought hey I should there was no one
else right right like we had the
smallest handful of people ever and so I
started doing the interviewing as I was
doing it I started realizing God these
guys tell me they want to do something
amazing with their life and if you just
listen like wow yeah like I want to be
on your team dude you're going to do
amazing stuff and then you realize they
can't execute on that dream so why can't
they
they don't have the mindset yet like
there's a you could do an entire podcast
series on how to get the mindset but
I'll just use Carol dweck and her
amazing book mindset
somewhere I'm sure such a good book I
see Simon sinek up there who is also
very influential on us and she says some
people either believe they're as smart
as they're ever going to be and that's
that so they're going to be ego
protective and they're going to you know
try to thwart anything that makes them
feel like they're not the smartest
person or whatever and then there's
people with a growth mindset and they
realize I'm not the smartest person and
I'm certainly not as smart as I could be
so even if I am the smartest person ever
lived I could get a little bit smarter
and so when they're confronted with
contradictory information they learn and
they soak it up like otherwise other
people are fixed mindset right correct
fixed on like no this is the way and I'm
right and that's wrong yes and I would
say the world everyone's on a spectrum
right even I as much as I believe in it
and work my ass off to be a growth
mindset I still have let's call it 10
where I catch myself I'm like come on
dude you know better than that yeah but
so people that fall unless they sub 50
spectrum of the growth mindset it's got
to be 98 what is the best way to truly
experience gratitude when you have a
goal-oriented mindset
um well I'll give you just like raw
tactics so first of all um I do this as
a part of my meditation routine I try to
experience gratitude both in like the
big things and in the small things
they're not always tied to my goal it is
purely something to get the
neurochemistry pumping
um in the right direction to be in a
good headspace to really feel and
internalize on a visceral emotional
level
that sense of like real deep fulfillment
gratitude appreciation for what you have
going on in your life so like I said
I'll pick something big and I'll pick
something small so it might be something
like you know I'm so grateful for 17
years with my wife somebody that really
understands me that knows my pettinesses
knows my like the dark ugly corners of
my mind like they know all of that and
they still love me and they they're with
me on this journey and you know she
picks me up and brushes me off when I'm
down I mean it's just like beautiful I'm
literally slipping into the mindset
right now like I am so grateful for that
woman and by the way that's how easily
it happens like you start and this is
exactly what I'm going through in my
head these are the exact words that I'm
thinking in my mind I don't say them out
loud but I'm thinking them in my mind
which then creates this neurochemical
Cascade and you find yourself actually
experiencing the emotions of that
gratitude then I will pick something
small let's say take my dog bonsai
man when he gets a haircut there's some
his fur feels like velvet there it is I
loved had that dog just don't know when
his hair is freshly cut super small
super stupid but I'm actually grateful
for it and it's amazing
um so I might think of something small
like that I might think of like whoa on
a warm day like that Cool Breeze is just
amazing or air conditioning air
conditioning is amazing let's all take a
second to just be appreciative of air
conditioning that again literally as I'm
talking about this I'm actually feeling
the gratitude for these things so it
works just like that I so often see
people make the same mistake that I
suffered from for years and still to
this day must stop myself from doing
and that is doing the easy things first
doing the fun things first
the right order to do things is order of
importance what's the lead Domino as Tim
Ferriss would say you know what your
goal is you know where you're trying to
go you know what you're trying to get to
what's the order in which you can
execute on your task list that's going
to make everything easier if I do this
first thing first everything after this
is going to be a little bit easier
because this contributes to the most
things in the downline
so I'll give you an example in business
if ever you have two tasks before you
that are of equal importance and one of
those tasks is hiring hiring is always
the lead Domino because now you have
doubled the amount of things that can
get done because before it was just you
if you hire now there's you and this new
person but all the time I see people
avoid doing the hiring because it's a
pain in the ass it is a long difficult
process it requires you to do a lot of
boring but the reality is if you
keep putting it off it never happens and
you end up doing everything yourself
forever because you failed to recognize
that hiring is a lead Domino from there
everything else in your life gets easier
so yes you have to do the hard thing up
front and I struggled with this with
hiring I came up with this rule because
as Nietzsche says I don't know if you
said this exact words because this might
be somebody else's phrase but certainly
this idea
is well in his world
that every theory is autobiographical
every theory is autobiographical so if
ever you hear somebody say everybody's
an what do you know about them
they're an so when I say
that hey
if you struggle with getting out of bed
it's because
hey
you're doing the easy things first it's
because these are the things that I've
struggled with my life so no judgment
but it is not useful it is not easy it
is not going to serve you you want to
make sure that you write things down so
write them down before you get to that
point so I keep an important things list
so just doing things willy-nilly one of
the biggest habits I had to break so I
started writing it down
I put them in order
and I forced myself bad habit oh these
things are equally important
no they're not you have to force
yourself to Force rank them so break my
bad habit no they're not I'm the kind of
person that can put things in sequential
order there's only one number one there
was only one number two there was only
one number three so on and so forth
some of this stuff comes down to you
just do or don't do it it's that simple
as Yoda would say
there is no try do or do not so we're
not going to allow ourselves that excuse
we're going to put things in order the
number one thing is the lead Domino
that's going to knock everything else
out and then I'm going to be disciplined
enough to actually execute in that order
and I because I'm so easily distracted
I'm not going to allow myself to be
distracted and because I know how easy
it is for me to get off task I'm going
to practice coming back to the task back
to the task back to the task for
meditation so I'm going to do that at
least five days a week and I'm going to
bring myself back to the breath back to
the breath so I get very good
coming back to the breath which makes me
very good at getting back on track let
me tell you right now that there are a
few things more important to your
success than reading now when I say
reading I mean reading watching YouTube
videos listening to podcasts uh and by
the way when I also say reading I almost
never and I'm talking less than two
percent of the things that I read in my
life are actually read by running my
eyes across words on a page I do almost
everything in an auditory fashion so I'm
doing audio books on Audible uh using
speechify to read PDFs all of that you
can even now get speechified to read web
pages for you so I find that it's far
easier for me to get in a lot of time
reading I read about two hours a day on
average
365 days a year
and the way that I'm able to do that is
I'm reading in all of my transitional
moments if I'm brushing my teeth if I'm
moving around the house if I'm lifting
weights working out whatever I am
reading the entire time again reading
YouTube videos podcasts documents
whatever so it's critically important to
do all of that because the whole point
of
the way the human psyche and brain is
designed is for us to leverage culture
in order to
develop ourselves so if you look at
every other species
they all have to make a choice between
hard wiring everything so you're doing
everything instinctually or learning
from your parents from the culture
around you
as you go up the food chain the more
flexible the cognition is of the animal
the more likely they are to be thriving
obviously humans are the ultimate apex
predator it's a cool way to think about
it from my perspective but certainly we
are the most successful species I think
even by certainly by biomass
I don't know if it's by number but
definitely by biomass humans are the
most successful creature on planet Earth
we uh outperform ants and other insects
which may have more numbers than us but
certainly we reign supreme in a lot of
different ways and the reason is that we
are the most able to flexibly organize
ourselves so you can get ants that can
organize themselves or bees that can
organize themselves in huge groups but
they can't do it flexibly so we can come
together and do this there are multiple
people in the room right now as we're
filming this that do different aspects
of this certainly the company even more
so cities states countries this is all
people organizing themselves but we can
come together for a show we can come
together for government the number of
people that would be required to publish
a book the people that are uh cutting
the trees down developing the paper or
developing the ink or an e-reader the
number of people that would have to come
together to create the the physical item
the software all of that so humans can
come together in very flexible ways they
can be in multiple groups throughout a
single day in their life so
the whole point the very thing that
makes the human species that successful
is our ability to learn from a cultural
standpoint now the ultimate way to do
that is to find some medium where we can
transpose knowledge across time and
space and books were that first
Revolution well I guess first there were
story so what you could say orally not
nearly as effective as being able to put
things down in print so you've got the
Gutenberg Revolution as a printing press
comes online then you've got the next
major one which is the internet and
there will of course be more beyond that
AI is massive I think web 3 is going to
be massive so there are these
technological moments that allow this
information to go far and wide and right
now if you really want to get
information in rapidly you're going to
be reading books watching YouTube
listening to podcasts it is massive so
the whole point is is to be able to
transform your potential into skill set
and so I want everybody to understand
why this is so important you don't read
a book to check a box you don't read a
book to impress your parents you don't
buy a book to have it sitting on your
shelf to impress people you read a book
to get good at something to get so good
that people can't stop you I really want
people to understand this I'm going to
crawl through the screen
skills have utility they let you do
things that other people can't do they
let you beat things they let you out
compete they let you grow they let you
push yourself they let you get to the
point where you cannot be stopped no
matter how much people might hate you
you can get so good at something that
even if they want you to fail even if
they're willing to go after you and
systematically try to destroy your
ability to succeed they can't because
you can outperform
as the legend
may he rest in peace Kobe Bryant said
booze
Boos booze don't block dunks
booze don't block dunks
Kobe practiced so much
so relentlessly
so unceasingly so much more than
everyone else that he was able to
compound his natural gifts and turn
himself into an Unstoppable scoring
machine think about this the greatest
Scouts in the world were paid a lot of
money to scour the world the entire
world to find the best players on the
planet
and then those best players on the
planet were given the best coaches on
the planet paid a ton of money with the
sole intention
of stopping Kobe Bryant from scoring on
the basketball court and yet despite all
of that
he scored 81 points in a single game
that's why I read
because you can get so good at something
given the way that the human mind is
structured you will learn from that
those things that you learn will become
capabilities those capabilities will
allow you to do things that other people
can't do and whether it's build a
company be a better parent be a better
teacher whatever it is you're trying to
do
you can get extraordinarily good at that
thing on balance people see the rate at
which I improve
they see that I have a goal and I'm a
servant to that goal
and then I build skills based on what
will take me to that goal
and because I win on balance more than I
lose
people still follow
so leadership is not about perfection
it's about progress
have you ever dealt with a bad leader if
so how do you go about it yes
I think we've all seen bad leadership
and it depends on where you're at in the
hierarchy is going to determine how you
can handle it now because I'm the CEO
it's very easy if somebody is displaying
bad leadership you go and explain you're
displaying bad leadership and you
explain what they're doing well what
they're doing poorly what they need to
improve on and how to improve upon it
you just lay it out like I said at
impact Theory there is only one way own
your opinion speak up or get out and
that's not true for anybody more than
it's true for me so I have to tell
people exactly what I think they're
doing right what I think they're doing
wrong and then help them adjust if you
are
reporting to them
then it becomes a very different game
now I would hypothesize that if you have
a toxic leader somebody who is not going
to listen somebody who is abusive
whatever that you have two choices you
can either outperform them and go around
them which I would never be shy or
bashful about
or I would leave the company but
personally I would not just sit there
and suffer in silence so at the end of
the day you want to play a long game so
um you know outperforming I cannot tell
you the number I almost got in a fist
fight once because I got hired at the
same time as another guy and just kept
getting promoted above him until I was a
direct boss and he was very displeased
by that nobody well I won't say nobody
most people can't handle that
and in that
you have to figure out how to
get around somebody that's toxic
on the other hand if they aren't toxic
but they're just
displaying bad leadership an open
conversation with them is the first
place to start give them a chance to
improve based on improved understanding
so coming to them and saying hey
I feel like you led me astray or I feel
like I'm not getting what I need or
whatever the problem is in very simple
clear language don't do it cruelly don't
try to be punitive don't set out to make
them feel bad or stupid just say hey
here's what I'm looking for here's what
I don't feel that I'm getting and I
would love to discuss if there's
something that we can do so that I can
get these things that I need either from
you or from somebody else but oftentimes
people don't realize where they're going
astray and oftentimes people have never
had that kind of direct and open
feedback now it is going to sting that
is going to hurt them and I would
actually encourage you it might be
worthwhile to get one of their peers to
come into that meeting which of course
they're not going to love but you're
going to avoid it he said she said
moment this is where the culture of the
company comes in at impact Theory we
tell people that they need to do that so
if you've got conflict between two
people you need to bring somebody in
that can sort of mediate that
disagreement so that we can figure out
what's going on we are not an
organization where it's like hey go tell
HR you need to tell that person directly
you need to let them know if you don't
get the response that you want from them
go to somebody else this is not a
company where you suffer in silence this
is not a company where you behind
people's back this is a company where
you speak directly to people now a lot
of people can't handle that
and I get that there are realities to be
faced about feeding your family keeping
a roof over your head all of that
there are also realities to be faced not
everybody's like that there are amazing
people out there that are extraordinary
leaders there are companies with
Incredible culture and you can find them
but you have to look
so in this particular example it starts
with very direct open and honest
communication done in a way that is
protective so that you've got somebody
else there so that there's you know not
going to be some Claim about
insubordination or whatever and
if you really are looking for a solution
and not just a punishment for bad
leadership then you guys can work
together and hopefully get exactly what
you want but open and honest
communication is the path I can't rule
out that you may be in a toxic
environment so let's just say if you're
in a toxic environment that's a real
thing you want to get out of that toxic
environment you want to move on to
something else like the just trying to
change a whole organization if they are
toxic is not interesting to me in the
slightest now toxicity comes from
insecurity so if that helps it actually
does help me to know that when people
are
um
mean-spirited when they like to see
other people fail it's all coming from
their own insecurities I find tremendous
emotional relief in that uh
now I want to talk about being low
in a non-toxic environment
while I don't think anybody races to
have others witness them at their worst
we've all been there
we are all deeply flawed emotional
creatures and
showing vulnerability
should never be frowned on for you
forget how people are reacting right so
there's wallowing
and that is an interesting
shouldn't be interesting to you in
yourself or in others there is
wanting sympathy instead of empathy
so sympathy is
feel bad for me
you should never want that empathy is
understand where I'm at
being seen is rad
and my wife and I have an agreement I
don't want sympathy from her no matter
how hard my life gets empathy
desperately
and the way that we've always explained
it to each other is if I'm ever knocked
to my knees
I don't want you to get on your knees
with me and cry
I want you to extend a hand
tell me how much you love me
pick me back up brush me off and remind
me of who I can become
that's rad
so I'm not worried if she sees me low
I'm not worried if my team sees me fail
um I think all of us if you're really
going for something extraordinary I
think all of us are going to fail at
least as much as we succeed maybe more
and so fearing the low moments is not
the right way to think about it we
contextualize that failure as a learning
opportunity earn people's respect not
command it earn people's Respect by
getting back up on your feet
not asking people to feel bad for you
focusing on the learning opportunity
show that you have a growth mindset get
your ego out of the way
Focus entirely on getting better
and if you rebound quickly
with energy and enthusiasm
even if some people take the opportunity
to kick you while you're down
in the long run people will gravitate
towards you because they see that you're
real you're not posing they see that you
bounce back that you don't whine wallow
complain you get up you're focused on
Improvement and moving forward and look
the reality is getting great requires
you to fail over and over and over
there's an amazing quote by Winston
Churchill and he says success is the
ability to go from failure to failure to
failure without a loss of enthusiasm
and you just can't worry about what
other people are thinking when you're
down you have to go cool this is a
learning experience I'm going to get
back up and your response to that
shouldn't be orchestrated to command
respect earn respect to even think about
people it should be you have a goal
and you know to build your skill set to
the point
where you're so good that you can't be
denied that all the booze in the world
can't block your dunk you have to fail
because it really it it really is it
isn't a saying failure is the most
information Rich data stream you will
ever encounter in the failure if you get
your ego out of the way and you're not
crying about it and you're not you know
worried about what other people are
going to think you're just thinking okay
cool I failed and if I can understand
why then I can get better
now you do that day in and day out all
of a sudden you're gonna earn respect as
as a consequence of you're just
consistent Improvement
and if I were going to sum up everything
that we've talked about today it's that
it's
not focusing on earning people's respect
or worrying about what they think it's
about
the physics of how the world works and
the physics of how the world works
pretty straightforward
you have a goal you have an idea of how
to reach that goal right there's an
impediment between where you are and
where you want to be you've got a theory
about how to overcome that impediment
you try it many of the things you try
will fail or they'll be insufficient
you'll assess why it was insufficient
and you'll begin again more
intelligently as Henry Ford said failure
is just the ability to Begin Again more
intelligently and you do that over and
over and over and over and over and it's
what I call the physics of progress it
it's just you can't boil it down any
more simple than that
all right so don't be afraid of your low
moments if you're in a toxic environment
get out focus every day on getting
better and the respect will come as a
result of that there really are only two
macro level motivators that we have in
life and that's Pleasure and Pain and so
what I want people to understand is okay
so if nature only gave you two things to
motivate you Pleasure and Pain why would
you eliminate half of them and so most
people think that life is about avoiding
the pain I'm here to tell you right now
in a very controlled fashion it is about
really experiencing the pain learning
from it so Ray dalio the most successful
hedge fund manager of all time has a
perfect math equation pain plus
reflection equals progress if you don't
feel the pain you never reflect on it so
my thing is I spend eighty percent of my
time focused on the beautiful things in
my life the things I'm grateful for the
beautiful things that I want to bring
into existence all of it twenty percent
of the time though I'm in the darkness
man I'm in that Tim Grover Relentless
I'm going to make this happen if I have
to break myself and I'm not afraid to
lean into that because I know how
powerful it is now if you really want to
put numbers how powerful this is they
did a study and they wanted to find out
what happens how can we get people to
endure more pain and the punch line is
hilarious so they would take people and
they would submerge their arm in a
bucket of ice and they would just hold
it there as long as you can now at first
it's just cold but after a while it
really starts to hurt and so people
would end up yanking their arms out
they found that people could hold their
arm in the bucket 35 percent longer if
you let them display anger
so put it in they get to that point
where they're about to pull it out and
you tell them yell cuss do whatever you
need to and they'd be able to do it
they're the expression of intensity even
what I'm doing right now I can feel
myself ready right I'm ready to strike
my muscles are tense I've got a
different posture I bring my chin down
there's intensity in my eyes like dude
I'm now feeling that because I'm I'm
embodying it right so it makes me really
feel that and so I actually started to
tell the story earlier I hate the gym
but what I would do to make myself work
out is I would my wife would be on the
opposite side of the gym and I would
stare at her and I would imagine her
being attacked and I would imagine her
being attacked by people bigger than me
and that the only way that I could fight
them off is to get stronger there was
nothing beautiful in it I was not
worried about Aesthetics I was worried
about saving my wife and by stepping
into that dark place and because people
are like what are you doing yeah but
dude that was I needed that motivation
to push past what I want to push past
pain boredom all of it and just to
really get into it and get a result but
I find that people shy away from that
look to me it's an 80 20 split if you're
spending more than 20 of your time there
it will be corrosive yes it will start
to erode your sense of self because
you're going to feel badly right because
I would be saying to myself you're weak
come on like you've got to get stronger
if you spend 80 of your time doing that
that sucks yes I don't want to live like
that right but not being able to dip
into both you'll just never hit the
level of extraordinary you may be fine
you may even be good yep but you're
never going to be great what tools do
you use to keep yourself dedicated and
focused on your main priority on a daily
basis all right so much of what I do and
how I'm able to accomplish the things
that I'm able to accomplish is because
I've taken the time to actually build
the desire to want the thing that I'm
chasing now a big part of that is
assigning meaning and purpose to your
goals
your goals should not be random they
should not be designed to make you rich
even if that's a second or third order
consequence great but the primary goal
should be something that gives you
meaning and purpose now when you have
meaning and purpose you will be willing
to fight through the lame the boring the
difficult okay I've said many times
boredom kills more dreams than fear than
failure it's you get in there and to get
good enough to do the thing you want to
do it's really boring you have to do a
lot of stuff that you do not want to do
over and over and over and so the only
way for you to have the stamina to see
that through is to really want that
thing you're pursuing now if you really
want that thing you're pursuing and
you've tied meaning and purpose so back
at Quest
it's real boring being under the
equipment trying to fix it
but I was there fighting for my mom and
my sister I wanted to end metabolic
disease I wanted to make sure that they
lived long enough that I could enjoy
their company for decades and decades
and decades to come but to do that the
price for that if you will was I had to
create food that they could choose based
on taste and it happened to be good for
them
at impact Theory I am trying to make
sure that nobody gets to the age of 15
without encountering a growth mindset
through story at scale and so all the
boring things dealing with finance and
contracts and all of that stuff
I do it because I really believe in the
people that I'm trying to help and I
have deeply personal connections with
the with people that I've encountered in
my life that because they didn't
encounter a growth mindset in those
years they have struggled needlessly in
their lives and so that really matters
to me so when it gets hard when I get
bored I can stay focused because I
really have this deep spiritual quite
frankly connection with what I'm trying
to do it isn't about making money it's
not about getting famous it's about
helping people that I love and care
about and so when you have that you're
going to be able to keep yourself
focused and on your main priority and
then if you actually believe that you
can accomplish it that helps and so you
need to believe that you can get good
enough you don't have to believe you
already are good enough but you need to
believe that you can get good enough in
order to achieve this let's say ethereum
just doesn't make it as a currency what
happens to our nfts that were minted on
that blockchain are they still safe
forever okay they're safe as long as the
blockchain exists and ipfs exists so
ipfs is beyond the scope of the basics
but earlier when I was talking about how
you have this thing that points at this
thing over here when it's pointing to
this thing over here it's usually
pointing at an ipfs server
um
so
if the project doesn't pay for their
ipfs server then the thing that the
blockchain is pointing to would become
blank but as people have noted if that
were ever to happen somebody could spin
that back up because the blockchain
unless the blockchain went down which
would whoa be
very
it would require that the entire
blockchain implode on itself which is
possible I want to be very clear that if
everybody stops believing in the
ethereum protocol and there are no
people that are securing the ethereum
protocol than the ethereum protocol
would for all intents and purposes cease
to function given the network effects of
how many people are securing the
ethereum protocol and how much value
there is in the ethereum protocol in
terms of money invested that seems like
a long shot it is definitely not
impossible again I am not a financial
advisor do you own research but it's
highly unlikely so the short answer is
yes it could collapse go to zero be
totally meaningless cease to effectively
function as a blockchain and everything
you had on it would be gone
but I feel way more secure about the
things that I have secured on the
blockchain than I do say something in my
house or my car which can be broken into
so
keep that in mind but if it didn't make
it as a currency and the blockchain
collapsed then yes it would go away and
no your things would not be safe forever
in that instance so it really comes down
to what do you think are the odds and
this is why I'm focused on the top two
biggest the ones that have the biggest
Network effects
um it just is way less likely that they
implode it's not impossible but it's way
less likely so be very very thoughtful
again only invest
what you can afford to have go to zero
I think that is the right approach to
take
um at this stage or any stage I wouldn't
buy more in Gold than I could afford to
go to zero so be thoughtful out there my
friends what is the biggest needle mover
for moving your business forward in your
experience what can I do if I feel like
my startup is not moving fast enough
okay
whenever you're trying to build a
business you are saying I'm here I have
a goal that's there your goal needs to
be hyper specific
between me and my goal is an obstacle
and I need to get past that obstacle now
to get past that obstacle you're looking
for what Tim Ferriss calls the lead
Domino I think this is a brilliant
concept you're looking for that thing
that you can do first that if you do
that that's going to have the biggest
knock-on effect in terms of making other
things easier so at impact Theory I'm
trying to build the next Disney my lead
Domino with social media my set so the
reason I wanted that was I needed people
to know who I was so that I could
attract Talent so that I could go get
doors open for me in Hollywood because
people had seen my content and I knew
that that was going to be a chain that
worked for me because that is one of the
talents that I've just put a lot of time
and energy into is the ability to
articulate ideas for people so I just
had a feeling that I'd be able to build
a big social ecosystem it just worked
out exactly like that and because of
that I've been able to get meetings and
open doors that I never would have been
able to do before now the second Lee
Domino is
video content being competent at
creating visual content because if we're
going to be the next Disney we know that
we're going to be dealing in uh film TV
video games
um
storytelling books Comics all of that
okay so all right cool so if I know that
that's what I'm gonna have to do what
are those areas of core competency one
was going to be video content another
was going to be comic books those are
the first that we attacked for several
other reasons but identifying what your
core competencies are going to need to
be and that if I were to get those core
competencies they would necessarily make
it easier for me to do other things okay
that's what you want to identify now
once you have that you're going to run
something that I call the physics of
progress and I actually teach a whole
class on this in Impact Theory
University in something called business
decision making so if you guys have a
business already and you're looking to
scale it go check out business decision
making we go into into a lot of depth on
this but the idea is as follows there is
a an actual nature to progress there is
a way that it works now the reason I
call it the physics of progress is
because it's getting down to First
principles thinking now what first
principles thinking is you know no
longer reasoning by analogy okay we're
not saying this is something that's like
this we're saying this is it this is the
thing this is how it works so take the
Human Experience for instance The Human
Experience the first principle's way to
view it is that
humans are the result of evolution and
when you understand how Evolution shape
the brain and the body and how they're
in communication now the human animal
suddenly becomes a lot less mysterious
and you don't have to wonder where that
negative Voice is coming from or why
you're so ambitious why you're afraid of
public speaking all of those things you
could understand from a first
principle's perspective of understanding
how Evolution shaped Us in business
there are very similar physics right
you're trying to sell something for more
than it costs you to make it to scale
you're going to have to have employees
employees or humans and they have all
kinds of what Dan arieli calls
predictable they're predictably
irrational so looking at all of that
understanding how markets move
understanding how marketing Works
understanding the tools you're going to
use in your business understanding
business structure when you understand
all of those things now you can think
from first principles when we talk about
making progress there are very simple
steps that you have to do and it's
basically the science method
re-contextualized for business and it
goes like this I'm here my goal is there
I have identified the obstacle the
impediment that stands between me and my
goal and a way that I like to ask it is
why if I just keep doing what I'm doing
now why won't I automatically get to my
goal
and one of the most important things to
understand is the second law of
Thermodynamics which applies
aggressively to business which states
that any closed system moved toward
moves towards entropy meaning
that if you don't have energy coming
into a system everything goes towards
chaos right your room becomes messy the
fire burns out like or the forest fire
rages across everything
everything moves towards chaos and the
only way to organize something to
structure it to get it to work in a
specific way is to pump energy into that
system I know a lot of people out there
if you're new to the building your
knowledge game one of the things you're
struggling with is reading a lot but not
making progress so one of a couple
things could be true first of all if
you're reading things that don't matter
to you then odds are that it's not
sticking and so you want to make sure
that you're reading in topics where you
have a goal associated with that topic
So reading that thing really matters to
you that is one of the most important
things you can do is get a hyper amount
of clarity around what your goals are so
you know exactly what books you need to
be reading in order to bolster your
skill set so that you can move forward
most people lack the clarity and because
they lack the clarity they're not
reading they're not excited about the
things that they're reading and when
you're not excited about the information
that you're in taking then forget it
it's never going to stick the next thing
is if you're not progressing I promise a
big part of this is you're not deploying
what you learn
most people are afraid of embarrassing
themselves stop immediately stop
worrying about embarrassing yourself it
doesn't matter what matters is on a long
enough timeline you can be anyone at
anything if you're willing to go and
up but most people are so afraid to
make mistakes they're so afraid of
looking stupid that they're paralyzed
they're indecisive they won't move I
make mistakes all the time and it's
embarrassing and it still sucks it's not
fun but what I know is that I will get
better and people may laugh at me in the
short term but they all give up they all
give up everyone stops everyone quits
everyone quits whenever I encounter
somebody and they are wasting time
making fun of me the one thing I know
that's gonna quit
because if you've got energy to waste
time making fun of somebody your
priorities are so Fubar you are trying
to self-soothe yourself from feeling
like an idiot by making fun of me
so I don't waste time on what somebody
like that thinks because I know that
skills have utility if I can re I have
this goal I have massive amounts of
clarity about what my goal is I'm
reading this thing
not because I'm going to check a box
but because I'm going to turn potential
into usable skill set which is going to
let me do something which allows me to
outperform other people but it requires
that I deploy it it requires that I use
the things that I'm learning so that I
can make them concrete my own mind so
that they become a skill rather than an
idea
don't collect ideas collect skills push
yourself figure out how you deploy all
this stuff how do I actually use this in
my real life what is it good for if it's
not good for anything you're not going
to have the energy to keep learning
about it and you're not going to make
the progress that you want so make sure
I got my goal I care about this thing
I'm reading this not to check a box I'm
reading this to get good at something
and then I'm deploying it to make sure
that it sticks so that I'm making
progress and I don't care if in the
moment
I make a mistake I don't care if in the
moment I fail I don't care if in the
moment other people think I'm ridiculous
I don't care if they think I'm stupid
because I am acquiring knowledge and
knowledge stacks
you get good at this thing it allows you
to understand this thing which allows
you to understand that thing which
allows you to understand that thing and
each one of those things is minor unto
itself
but just like a Lego piece by itself is
not very interesting you can build
virtually anything you want with Legos
but you have to be willing to take the
time to put them together and have
people look at the incomplete thing and
say that that doesn't make sense I don't
see it I don't understand what that is
that's going to take too long why are
you doing that Legos are stupid
but when Legos are knowledge
it will change your life
but you've got to be willing to deploy
it
so
don't waste time
lamenting your stupidity your
frustration at being slower than other
people it just is what it is
Focus all of your time and energy I have
a goal that goal makes demands those
demands require that I get better at
something that I'm not currently good at
and I'm going to read about it and then
use it
because it is only in the using that I
will make progress
so if you do that if you follow that
formula learn in the morning use in the
afternoon not research for six months
and then try learn in the morning use in
the afternoon or learn during breakfast
and use immediately after breakfast the
faster you can begin using the things
that you're learning the faster you will
make progress and remember progress is
iterative it's not overnight you go from
nowhere to somewhere you go from one
step to the next step to The Next Step
One Foot In Front of the other and you
make these tiny little incremental bits
of progress with every new thing that
you deploy after learning but if you
don't deploy it if you don't use it one
it's not even going to stick because a
lot of these ideas are just going to go
in one ear and out the other you're
really only going to retain what hits
you emotionally and what you use and if
you wanted to hit you emotionally there
better be a goal driving you to read
that thing when you read something I
remember one time I was on an airplane
this was the craziest ever I was reading
the book Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon
Hill
and I'm going through the book and he's
talking about how uh hey there's a
secret to this book and I'm going to
give you that secret to the book
and I'm oh my God Think and Grow Rich I
want to grow Rich this is amazing I'm
broke at the time so I'm reading reading
and reading and every page is like I'm
telling you the secret I'm telling you
the secret I'm telling you the secret
and I'm like what and about I don't know
page 52 in he's like I've told you the
secret to this book on every single page
without fail and if you don't yet know
what it is you're in trouble
and I was like
what has he said on every page
and I was on an airplane
and I remember it finally dawned on me
the only thing that he had said on every
single page was if you believe you can
you can and if you believe you can't you
can't
and I was like
holy sh I got Goosebumps all over my
body I remember I looked up and looked
around the plane because it it
transformed me as a human being you can
draw a line in the sand me before
realizing that piece of information me
after realizing that piece of
information and it felt it rocked me so
hard some weird part of my subconscious
was like surely other people just felt
that and I looked around to see if
anybody else was feeling what I was
feeling of course they weren't because
all I was the only one reading the book
but that's how hard it hit me
and when you have an emotional reaction
on something like that you remember it
but you've got to want that information
so badly I was so desperate at that time
to get rich that I was like oh my God I
need to understand what's going on in
this book I was desperate for that
information and when it hit me when I
learned the thing that that book was
trying to teach me it rocked me to the
degree that I remember to this day where
I was sitting what it felt like when I
realized that thing and I will never
forget the lesson if you believe you can
you can if you if you think you can you
can if you think you can't you can't
just facts so understand that you have
to have a goal there has to be a reason
in order for that thing that you're
learning to hit you emotionally and then
you're way more likely to remember it
deploy it deploy it with immediacy and
aggression don't be afraid to fail or
look stupid because no matter how dumb
you look in the moment knowledge stacks
and a long enough timeline you can beat
anyone at anything it's literally true
but it's so directionally correct you
should live your life as if the ability
to assess accurately whether or not
you're actually moving towards your
goals so everything starts with this
hyper specific goal and this is why you
can't in any way shape or form be
nebulous about what it is you want to do
and I think that a lot of people are
super vague about what their goals are
and the easiest way for me to explain it
is to say most people have the
equivalent of a goal in their mind of
something like this what the words they
actually use this is the single most
common I want to help people
okay great that's really Noble and I
love that and I love that that's
something that I hear all the time but
the problem is it's like saying I want
to win a gold medal in the Olympics okay
well summer or winter summer great uh
tennis or swimming swimming great which
event because until you get to the exact
event that you want you don't know what
to train you don't know what skills you
need you don't know what muscle groups
you need to be training you don't have
the goal in mind and if you can't
measure it you can't improve it so you
need to create some environment where
you know here are the things that I'm
going to measure that I need to get good
at in order to win that gold medal so if
you want to win the gold medal then you
need to understand what kind of time do
you have to swim in that event in order
to qualify historically for a gold medal
that's a really good place to start and
then looking at the Contemporary
competition and understanding on their
best day where they're setting the bar
for a gold medal and either you're
swimming that fast or you're not and so
it all becomes entirely measurable you
can find trainers and coaches that
understand how to get you there but it
all started with that really really
specific goals so if you don't have that
specific goal then you can't even put a
road map by which then you can see if
you're actually making progress towards
that or not so
invariably in the beginning you're
almost certainly going to be doing the
wrong things you're going to be doing
things that aren't moving you as rapidly
towards your goal as you want but when
you can measure it and you have that
road map and you can accurately identify
whether or not you're taking steps then
you can adjust tweak and move on so I'll
give you guys an example the whole
reason that I'm here in New York was to
meet with the former head of one of the
major
comic book companies and literally I
said I have two questions and I spent
two days with them over the next two
days your job is to help me answer two
questions question number one why am I
going to fail
and then question number two once I
understand why I'm going to fail how do
I ensure that I succeed
and then you really look at just the
really hard answers and once you have
that in place then it's like okay I've
got a rough idea of what I need to be
executing against the things that I'm
going to need to learn the people that
I'm going to need to talk to the
problems with distribution that have to
be solved or accounted for all of that
and then you go build out answers to
those problems you see which ones work
and then you change and adjust as you go
but that really is
um at a very high level one of the
things you have to do talk to people
that already know get them to break down
for you the things you need to be doing
and that's how you evolve your thinking
over time all right next question is
from Carolina Wilk this is from Facebook
Tom exclamation point how do you make
yourself do things that you don't want
to but have to
there's really only one way that I know
to do this reliably and that is to
really care deeply about the thing
you're trying to do so to me it's it's
about identifying something that you get
more energy out of than it takes from
you and I think people try to sum that
up by saying find something that you're
passionate about and first of all you
have to be really careful because you
don't find you're going to create
passion passion is created it's not
discovered so how do you learn to create
that excitement around something that
you care about so do that by
encountering a lot of things until you
find one that really piques your
interest and then engage with that
heavily and as you engage with that
learn to Fan the Flames to really create
it as an obsession which one of the
easiest ways to create it as an
obsession goes like this say in your
head this is something that I really
enjoy I love it interests me for all
these reasons like loop back over that
as to why it's something that really
drives you focus on the things that you
like repeated in your head man I really
got into that I got into it for this
reason this this is why I'm excited
about this and then externalize that and
a huge part of this and one of the
things that I do one of the reasons that
when I'm doing a live like this like
these guys will tell you in the room two
seconds before we started rolling I was
talking in a totally different manner
than I am right now I'm using much
bigger physical expressions and I do
that because I for these lives to give
me more energy than they take I need to
embody the excitement I need to remind
myself of connecting with you guys and
why that's important to me and why
that's fun and in doing that it makes me
want to do the next live even more
because I remember how it gave me energy
instead of just taking it away and I
think about connecting with you guys and
I think about the people that write in
and all that stuff so I'm intentionally
doing that I'm intentionally a looping
looping around the things in the
community that bring value to me I'm
intentionally embodying my excitement
during this so that then as I replay
this later in my mind that I remember
how it was exciting and it was fun so
learning to do those things learning to
take conscious control of that process
is going to give you the excitement that
you need then when you hit those things
that you don't want to be doing you're
so excited and you so embody that
enthusiasm for the thing you're trying
to do that you believe in that mission
that goal that thing that like you would
you would die for and you've built into
your life to live for it that thing is
giving you that energy it it becomes
your passion and that passion is the
thing that's going to see you through
but you created all of that so make sure
that whatever you're trying to do you
actually give a about that's the
real answer when you feel broken when
you feel embarrassed when you've been
knocked your knees you're going to be
able to rebound quickly because you have
a mindset that understands the nature of
failure itself and the nature of failure
itself is that if you're willing to
stare nakedly at your inadequacies
completely accept that that failure was
entirely your fault not point the blame
at anybody else even if there really are
people to blame because that's not going
to help you other than to say I picked
the wrong people or I didn't help them
get the skill that they needed whatever
but looking for what you would do
differently next time so you can
actually do it different next time so
you can actually get the better result
if you can do all that stare nakedly at
your inadequacies recognize what you
need to do differently and then have the
strength
to endure through all of that emotional
pain and the boredom of having to do
this again with a slight tweak on it to
improve to iterate
and then try it again
then you're going to be able to get
where you want to go then you're going
to be able to run what I call the
physics of progress the physics of
progress are exactly what I just said
you try something to the best of your
ability you fail to some extent
you don't make excuses you stare nakedly
at your inadequacies you figure out what
you did wrong what you can do
differently next time then you do that
different thing next time
you will fail again though but you'll be
a little bit closer you'll once again
assess nakedly you will get a little bit
smarter you will try again and you will
just keep going in that Loop over and
over and over and that Loop will lead
you where you want to go
so when you feel like you've lost your
willpower the answer is just get up and
try again
and if you don't have the energy ask
yourself one simple question why are you
doing what you're doing there's a reason
that Simon sinek Says start with why
once you know why you're doing what
you're doing now you've got the chance
to actually dig deep in those moments
where you feel that everything you've
built inside of you has failed you
you're going to be able to reach in
remember why you're doing this which is
definitively going to be about you and
how you can help other people and if
it's not if it's just about you we found
the problem
because you need to do something that
allows you to serve not only yourself
but other people we have an inbred need
to serve the tribe so figure it out
figure out how what you're doing is
going to help other people lock in on
that
also in those moments where you're down
and if you ask yourself why am I doing
this and you think of all the beautiful
things you're going to do all the people
that you're going to help and it's still
not enough
and those times will happen
you're on your knees
no amount
of helping somebody else is going to get
you back up
do you know what's going to serve you in
that moment
the darkness
the dark side
anger
rage
Fury
ferocity
if you don't have those if you can't
access them if you think that they are
off limits in some way
you won't have what you need to be
resilient when your willpower fails you
so my friends
as Jordan Peterson says
become a dangerous man
or woman
be capable
of great violence
and keep it under wraps
because in that moment when you're
broken what I want you to do is channel
into that and you're going to think
about the people that want you to fail
you're going to think about the people
that will dance in your grave you want
to think about the people that will
laugh as they read your obituary who
will laugh as they think about all the
things you said you were going to do
that you never did and that they knew
you were a loser
think about them
and in that moment
Raise Your Weapon
in your mind of course
and refuse
to let them be right pain is amazing
it's wonderful and it is as Ray dalio
would say and unfortunately I'm not
pointing to Ray dalio but I am pointing
to somebody who is deep in his world who
shares my love for principles as Ray
Dalia would say pain plus reflection
equals progress
some part of me wishes that we didn't
need to go through the pain some part of
me wishes that pleasure burn things into
your mind as powerfully as pain but it
doesn't so going through the painful
experiences really is incredibly
incredibly powerful but there isn't
anything in my life that I'm like hey I
want to go through that again the fact
is the reason that I remember it is
because it was painful and so the pain
was exactly what I needed in order to
burn it into my nervous system in order
to not make those mistakes again so I'll
give you some of the powerful lessons
that I had to learn in in very painful
ways so wanting to be right thinking
that I'm good and smart and all of that
that really was
one of those things that over a very
long period of time brought me so close
to depression that I knew that I never
wanted to be there again and it was
feeling like I was a sham feeling like I
was full of and not knowing how to break
into the film industry like that was
paralyzing and I thought that you either
were good or you weren't and so when I
made my final thesis film at USC which
should have been the highlight of my
career up to that point I should have
just looked at it as a breathtaking
learning experience but instead it made
me feel worthless and it made me feel
like I didn't have any talent and so
that was so
uncomfortable and so painful that that
really echoed through my life for years
and years until I learned how to really
frame that so while I don't want to go
through that again it really taught me
the most fundamental lesson which is to
embrace that we're all hopelessly
average and that the reality that we
need to face is it's all going to come
down to your willingness to acquire
those skills the way that I found to
stay focused be productive and not get
distracted is one by auditing my time so
that I know one what I'm supposed to be
working on and then two that at the end
of any task I'm going to reflect back on
how long it took me how much time did I
spend on task and also I have rules like
if I'm working on something I don't take
out my phone I don't look at it no
matter what I have no alerts on my
computer no alerts on my phone if
somebody's calling I would never know if
somebody's texted me I would never know
I don't have anything that pops up on my
computer you want to eliminate
distractions I don't even work facing a
window I will go into a room and I will
intentionally face myself away from a
window there was one period of my life
the only reason I stopped doing this is
because I think it's really important to
get daylight in your eyes but I was
putting myself in a dark room and
literally with a stand-up desk was the
only thing between me and a wall so even
though I was in a nice expansive
beautiful room I was putting myself
facing the wall so that there was
nothing for me to even look at that I
want to be working on the thing that I'm
trying to accomplish and the other thing
is that's hugely important is to make
sure that you care about what you're
working on the number of people that
don't give about what they're doing with
their life is terrifying and when you
don't care about what you're working on
there's no meaning or purpose behind the
thing that you're trying to do then of
course it's going to be harder to stay
on track of course you're going to be
looking for that dopamine hit from your
phone from that email because working on
the thing that you're working on doesn't
give you the dopamine hit making sure
that you're pursuing things that you
care about that's a huge part of it if
you want to be successful mindset is
everything the reason that mindset is so
important is at the end of the day only
execution matters so if you have big
dreams if you have goals something that
you're trying to accomplish in your life
you're going to have to execute against
that so why do I say that mindset is so
important in that scenario the reason is
that ultimately to achieve the things
you want to achieve I can promise you
when you start out you're not good
enough yet to achieve that and or you
don't have the right plan and so the way
to refine the plan to actually do the
thing that you want to accomplish you're
going to have to run through what I call
the physics of progress the physics of
progress are very simple they require
you to have a hypothesis which is simply
your best guess this is what I think I
have to do to achieve my goals then
you're going to turn that into something
you can do you're going to do that thing
it's going to fail to some degree that's
just the way it works but failure is the
most information rich data stream on
planet Earth but to accurately assess
the data and figure out what it's
telling you about why you failed to some
extent or why it was more
inefficient than it needs to be
you have to be willing to stare nakedly
at your own inadequacies take
responsibility for the outcome not make
it somebody else's fault or the
economy's fault or whatever any external
Force if you're making it an external
problem you're never going to be able to
learn the lesson you need to learn in
order to improve your behavior so that
you can then execute better and make
more progress that really is it that's
the physics of progress hypothesis
turn it into something actionable run
that action learn from the partial
failure get a little bit smarter
come up with a new hypothesis that is
more informed turn it into something
actionable run that it will fail again
to some degree figure out why by
lowering your defenses having a growth
mindset making sure that you are able to
take on the responsibility now why is
that a mindset question why can't you
just run that equation if it really is
that simple the answer is you have in
your brain something called the
psychological immune system this is
something given to you by millions of
years of evolution we should all be
extremely grateful for it and the
psychological immune system's job is to
make sure that you don't commit suicide
it is designed to make you feel better
about things it's the reason why you can
mess up make a mistake and you can
soothe yourself now the problem is that
the goal of the psychological immune
system is not for you to achieve your
goals it's simply to make sure that you
feel good enough about yourself that you
can keep moving through life
now the reason that that becomes wildly
problematic and is one of the most
important things you have to address in
your mindset if you're going to be
successful is because the number one
tool that your psychological immune
system works to soothe your ego is to
make everything somebody else's fault it
is the fault of the government it is the
fault of rich people it is the fault of
not being born the right color not being
born the right sex so on and so forth it
is making something the external problem
now here's the really bad news your
psychological immune system is going to
grab for a very valid excuse those
things that I listed may all be true
they may really all be holding you back
the problem is you want to know what the
right mindset for success is and if you
want to be successful you are going to
have to overcome a endless parade of
problems and to overcome the endless
parade of problems you have to have a
way to take responsibility
for what you can do differently to
overcome those problems instead of being
annoyed instead of shutting down instead
of just pointing the finger you want to
adapt your behavior turning a want into
a crushing need is one of the most
useful processes that you can master and
when you understand that we don't get
what we want but we get what we need
then you begin to understand okay this
is something I want to learn how to line
up so I want to take this thing that I
want and isn't a need it really is just
a want and I want to figure out the
process of how I increase its level of
importance in my mind so one of the most
important things to understand about the
human brain is that the the brain the
conscious mind will
work backwards to justify what it's done
so the the human brain is absolutely
fascinating and it has a mechanism so I
talk about this thing called the physics
of Being Human like what does the brain
just do in and of itself and one of the
things that the brain does in and of
itself always and forever is it will
justify what happens there's this
amazing thing a study that was done on
people that have short-term memory loss
so that they cannot form new memories
they they have brain damage that makes
it impossible for them to form new
memories so a doctor will go in they
will have a pin on their hand they will
shake hands with a person it pokes them
person jerks their hand back now
remember they cannot form new memories
so that doctor Jabs them and they're in
pain they pull their hand away the
doctor comes back five minutes later the
person does not remember meeting them at
all but they still won't shake their
hand now when you ask them oh why won't
you shake my hand they will make up
and they'll be like well I've just
always had this problem with shaking
people's hands that are wearing white
lab coats which is total five minutes
ago they were more than happy to shake
that person's hand so that is the
conscious mind needing to make sense of
what's going on in the subconscious mind
because the way that memories are stored
are very different so you have the
implicit the explicit memory so you've
got something that's happening
consciously and subconsciously so the
short-term memory is not turned into
long-term memory and so they don't
remember why they're doing this thing
but the part of the memory that's
working based around the pain and
knowing what causes pain stimulus
realizes that this person generates pain
but the subconscious speaks an emotion
it doesn't speak in language and so the
rational logical mind tries to then make
sense of what is going on so we're gonna
hijack that to work for us here in this
example where we want to get hyped up
about something but we want it to be
real so we know that the my is doing
this and yes we're totally hacking the
mind yes we're playing a bit of a game
with ourselves but it ends up having
this incredible impact so what I do is I
embody the passion that I want to feel
so like I'm doing now you can imagine if
you're sitting in a room with me I would
probably be speaking much more subdued
but because I understand that the
passion that I'm feeling is infectious
to other people that if I can embody it
then I can get other people to feel it
as well now the crazy thing is is it
works in the loop and I actually begin
to feel that the response that I'm
having is the right amplitude so even if
I'm merely consciously turning the dial
of excitement up or whatever about the
goal that we have because I know that I
want to Spring out of bed in the morning
I'm going to dial that up and say this
thing that I'm working towards it isn't
a want this is a need I've got to have
this and this is why I have to have it
and I'm going to create some logic that
really means something to me and I'll
give you an example at quest to show up
every day and to fight that hard to
learn manufacturing to spend my time
repairing equipment it was crazy and
there were times it was so frustrating
and I knew for me to do something I
didn't want to do that I was going to
have to leverage that notion so I said
going into it how do I attach to
building a nutrition company to
something that I care intrinsically
about deeply about and that thing became
my mom and my sister and so I said okay
this is really powerful because I can
show up every day and fight for my mom
and my sister so how do I associate my
mom and my sister to a nutrition company
and the answer was very simple my mom
and my sister were morbidly obese and I
wanted to help make food that they could
choose based on taste and it happened to
be good for them and if I could do that
that they would be in my life longer
they would live longer healthier lives
they would feel better so when a piece
of equipment broke down or I was dealing
with something incredibly frustrating
where I was working insane hours it was
just hey I'm doing this for my mom and
my sister and I would embody that and I
would tell people that I would feel it I
would get amped up the way that I'm
doing right now I would literally say
things like this like a crazed man and
it began to infuse so that over time six
months 12 months it was like I really
felt like this was a crusade for my mom
and my sister and that is so powerful
the ability to take something that you
care deeply about marry it to a goal
that you care about so that you have
this emotional resonance with that thing
is very very powerful so that's the
brain hack that you're going to use to
get yourself super excited looking at
and understanding who that person is
what your relationship is with them how
much they can take what
what the nature of your relationship is
with them in terms of feedback so for
instance there's a person on our team
his name is Will voo now will came to me
one day and said he's been working with
me for a couple years and he said Tom I
want to be honest with what my goal is
here at impact Theory and I said amazing
tell me all about it and he said I want
to be co-ceo and I said all right but if
you're really gunning for that like we
can play a game and all just sort of
giggle and laugh and say how cute that
will at the time he was probably 19 or
20 that he said that you know how cute
that will is calling his shot like Babe
Ruth and saying that he wants the the
top job or I can take that really
seriously and now we can talk about what
would it really take to get to that
point and if you're giving me permission
which is something that I'll do a lot
with people is you tell me you know how
hard basically you want to be pushed
because I'm happy to like if you want to
know what it takes to to get to your
goal right everything is an echo of your
goal he gave me his goal and I said cool
if that's really how you want me to
treat you like I'm grooming you to be
the co-ceo it's going to be hard and we
just had a call like yesterday or the
day before where
um he brought something up he said
something that I would have let slide
and virtually anybody else and I stopped
him in the middle of that I told him why
it didn't make sense he pushed back I
started escalating it got to the point
where I was like look if you really want
to be the CEO you've got to think in a
way that is always solution oriented you
cannot be pushing off something making
it somebody else's problem or saying
that that's too big and that you're not
going to be able to overcome that and so
you just sort of move on without
thinking about it I'm like you are
literally poisoning the rest of this
team because subliminally you've told
them that this can't be done and so
going through that I would not have done
that with other people I wouldn't have
gone that hard I might have suggested
hey there's a better way to frame this
or whatever but with will because he has
specifically asked me to actually help
him develop the skill set that he will
need to be the CEO that I treat him
differently than I might treat somebody
else now everybody in the organization
we have a total transparency culture but
you have to earn your way into that so
one you're only as good as what you
write down so we have published what our
culture is so we have a culture document
it tells you exactly what a principal's
culture is it tells you what we mean by
transparency it tells you that we expect
people to own it meaning your opinion
speak up or get out and so we hold
everybody to that standard and so there
is a lot of open discussion now we can
do that because everybody who's here
knew that before they came on and
they've bought into that culture and
they see the benefits of that culture
and so by communicating what that is
laying the ground rules having you know
Rules of Engagement which I'm sure as a
military person you're intimately
familiar with once you have those Rules
of Engagement then it's like hey this is
how we agreed we were going to deal with
each other you agreed you wanted to be
pushed this way and that to me is very
important now one thing that I will
throw in there is be careful who you
hire some people just are not going to
have the
um the makeup for that I won't even say
it's good or bad I'm just saying they're
they approach the world in a very
different way they want their feedback
in a very different way they may not
want to be pushed like you want to push
them and so you have to know going in
whether somebody is going to be a
cultural fit I think it's as important
to judge a cultural fit as it is to
judge a skill set fit so if you get all
of those Rules of Engagement a good
cultural fit you've written down the
culture you've discussed it you have
buy-in and permission from the person
now you can be very open and back and
forth and then if you really want to
bring it home you're going to make sure
that you're as receptive to that kind of
feedback as you would expect them to be
so if you lead by example and you're
showing people what it means to take
criticism to be pushed to want to know
where you're weak and then to work to
get better at that when people see that
man and then you come to them and say
hey of course in a compassionate way but
never sacrificing Clarity for kindness
but you tell them hey here's you know
where I think you are lacking here's
what I think that you should do to
improve that
um people know the sincerity of it
because they've been on the other side
and told you where they think you're
weak and how they think you can improve
and if you took that on well and
actually did something about it and
actually got better and that we're all
reaping results because of that
Improvement now people are really going
to be open to it because you've set the
tone and that is certainly how I do it
respect
comes from competence whether it's your
own self respecting yourself doing
something you think is worthy getting
good at something that is valuable
that's how you get somebody else's
respect
you don't get respect by saying you
should treat me this way
and
respect cannot be given it must be
earned and I remember hearing that at
the beginning of my career and thinking
man like I can't just go to somebody and
say hey don't be a like you need to
treat me better and that got me nowhere
it makes you look weak like you said I
mean you literally put in the question
where uh my facade kind of Fades and I
slip back into my normal self and
eventually I completely lose the respect
instead of getting it okay this is a
game of confidence
to be confident you must actually be
good at something I'm sure you've heard
the phrase that confidence comes from
competence okay the same with respect if
you want to get that respect you
actually have to get good at something
if you want to get that respect you
actually have to respect yourself you
want oh God there's a great story so I
interviewed
um
Matthew McConaughey watch the episode
first of all it's fire that dude's
amazing but he in his book green lights
he talks about how he came to Hollywood
and first he was discovered in Texas now
why was he discovered in Texas because
he had Swagger he had that it Factor he
didn't give a sh he didn't want people's
approval he wasn't asking for anything
he wasn't coming to the world with his
hand out this is so critical this was a
turning point in my life don't come to
the world with your hand out don't act
like the world owes you anything the
people that are disrespecting you don't
owe you and you shouldn't want anything
from them you shouldn't be thinking
about them you should be thinking about
becoming a beast that cannot be stopped
because you have a set of skills
that lets you do something other people
can't do
my favorite
one of my favorite quotes all time
certainly my favorite Kobe Bryant quote
booze don't block dunks
if you get so good at something that
people can't stop you they can't stop
you think about being on a basketball
court the other team they are paying
their players millions of dollars to
stop somebody from putting a ball into
the hoop but you can actually get so
good that they cannot stop you from
doing it no matter how hard they try
life
is like that
you actually okay remember skills have
utility
so you can actually get so good at
something your skill set is so Superior
to other people your competitors the
other people in your work environment
whoever
that even though they want to stop you
they can't
because you've just gotten that much
better than they are
now
back to Matthew McConaughey Goes to
Hollywood
they picked him out of obscurity because
he had Swagger he goes there and all of
a sudden he loses that Swagger and
before his
agent I guess would let him go to his
first audition he said no no I can I can
see that you've got your hand out now
that you want something from this town
so we sent him on like a two-month
motorcycle journey across Europe or some
crazy like that and he said when
you're ready and you no longer want
anything from this town and you can just
walk in be you totally unapologetically
then we'll start sending you out on
auditions he did it he comes back he's
got a Swagger he sends him in and
obviously the rest is history
man that that's just hard and I know
that people want an easier path forward
but the reality is you have to get so
good you can dunk on even the people
trying to stop you that's just the truth
and when you do that and you're no
longer wanting other people's respect
you don't care about that all you're
doing is investing in skill set then it
will pay off all sudden people will
respect you and by the way be kind to
people
extend that respect to those that have
earned it of course but don't be cold or
cruel even when people are being that
way to you I just I can't tell you how
much that will pay off in the end
because most people hit a gazillion
emotional snags as they go through this
they derail themselves they don't listen
to the truth of their failure they don't
want to own it because it sucks every
time Omar that I realize that I have
screwed up that I am wrong it sucks I
don't enjoy it but the thing that keeps
me going is recognizing that that is the
nature of progress itself and that if I
fail to look at what I can control that
I could do differently next time I'm
either going to repeat the mistake or
I'm gonna quit now the bad news about
success is it's a game of attrition and
the really bad news is that to move
forward you must be willing to fail a
lot because failure is the most
information Rich data stream that exists
because it alerts and you actually tried
something so you tried something there's
real world results those results hurt
that pain triggers the areas of the
brain that have to do with memory and
focus so you really look at that thing
right this again this is nature saying
hey because there's so much information
in this failure I want to make sure that
we do the things that get you to learn
from that so that the next time it is in
a close call with a tiger right that
either you can really keep distance
you're not putting yourself in that kind
of dangerous situation again and then
obviously the people that really got
themselves in trouble just got eaten and
so they're all wiped out and so that
becomes this Loop but every time you
fail you get this aversion response
where you don't want to do this again
you don't want to look at it you don't
want to face your inadequacies right and
it's really rough and then it's
magnified a thousand fold by social
media because now a thousand people are
telling you that you're a so it's
it is this really team and money and
time and energy and yeah you you magnify
that a million full because now there's
a lot at stake for a lot of different
people and so most people they just
can't keep iterating and so it's um
it is the game and there's as far as I
can tell and look I'm constantly
updating my mental models but as far as
I can tell that's the ground floor that
that really is the physics of progress
and if you can't figure out that when I
just failed I'm gonna fail publicly and
people are making fun of me in that
moment can I just stay centered or get
centered again because of course you're
going to get knocked off can I re-center
myself very quickly and focus on what I
need to do and once the do is back to
hypothesis back to execution and if you
can stay in that Loop what do I need to
do what's the next thing to try then on
a long enough timeline you can win but
most people they just stop man it's just
too much it's not fun and by the way
there is a a ready-made off-ramp because
I don't know how many people should
listen to me I don't know how many
people should live the kind of life that
I'm trying to live where I'm trying to
have outside success I'm trying to build
something massive
um
for the right person I think that I
actually have the right tools like these
have served me incredibly well in my
life I have the receipts to show that it
works but I also have the receipts to
show emotionally it's brutal and if you
don't know how to rebalance yourself
it's not a winning proposition so
focusing on that the mental game of like
fulfillment matters fulfillment it's
important Joy is a metric optimize your
life for joy and then you've got to play
the game on a really long timeline so
you have to Discount anybody that says
you know you're a for this failure
it's like that isn't that doesn't ring
true to me for the following reason
making a mistake and even doing
something that is objectively stupid
let's say that the vast majority of
humanity would would have seen clearly
that which I missed okay so let's say
that that was true and I'll qualify that
and say that's what we're defining as
stupid so let's say that I actually do
make a stupid mistake that most people
would not have made
if in that moment I give up I'm out of
the game if in that moment I can
re-center learn my lesson and keep going
then I just I put myself in a in an
Elite Class not because I you know can
prognosticate everything accurately but
because I don't quit and that's really
been my secret is I just don't give up
and if you have a neurochemical
imbalance that really sucks like I can
just tell you looking at my mom I'm
prone to anxiety so there is
um I'm sure if when this all gets mapped
out it will become clear that I have
markers for anxiety whether they were
epigenetic or genetic but that I came
out just primed to become anxious
so that sucks for me because I've really
had to contend with anxiety like this is
one of the biggest issues in my life I
think about anxiety almost every day so
it is really a thing that I've had to
manage especially for somebody striving
in the way that I have so I'm constantly
putting myself in the position of being
anxious I remember in high school I
promised myself I would never again do
anything that made me nervous that was
the word I used back then that I would
never again do it and yet my adult life
has been a betrayal of that promise that
I made to myself in high school because
all I do is put myself in situations
that make me anxious
so but the striving and getting better
has been a reward of Untold proportions
so
when I think about
we all in some way we all have it worse
than somebody else right so somebody
with Tourette's that sucks I would not
want to have Tourette's somebody that
gets multiple scleros sclerosis that
sucks would not want that Alzheimer's
cancer heart disease whatever the thing
is that makes your life worse it really
does make it worse
but the only thing that compounds that
problem is to lean into that that it
sucks to be me whereas take Stephen
Hawking right
what are you gonna say what what
advantage did he have right like he
literally couldn't move so in his early
20s he starts losing every function that
he has other than his brain and he
realizes at one point this sucks but if
I in fact he has a quote Oh God people
are really going to hate this
Stephen Hawking okay quadriplegic
in a wheelchair basically can blow in a
straw and move
his eyes I think towards the end like he
could only move one eye I mean it was
crazy so this guy there's just not a lot
he can do he's been spoon fed since he
was like 30 years old like crazy crazy
imagine not being able to like go to the
bathroom by yourself forever like every
time and crazy so this guy says what I
have found is that no one will help you
if you don't help yourself
and it just is man we look at somebody
who who despite all of that is like
trying to make contributions to physics
or that you know ended up being his
stick and he just realized that I can
actually get help from people but not if
I'm not helping myself first it's just
something that we respond to
are you optimistic you talked about this
cultural movement I'm freakishly
optimistic but because I need a belief
system that is both true and optimistic
I don't want to fall for traps and if I
paint myself a falsely optimistic view
of what's real I'll get tripped up and
optimistic about that personal
responsibility movement everything are
you optimistic that oh the that will
gain momentum that that it will um
lose momentum it has lost so much
momentum just in my lifetime that the
pendulum is swinging so hard in that
direction so I don't know if it swings
back in the next five years the next 50
years it will swing back but if now
we're gonna really derail but I remember
as a 16 year old boy reading about Roman
orgies and I was so angry because I was
like
how is it possible that they were having
orgies 2000 years ago and me now in like
the mid 90s like my mom would have a
seizure I wasn't allowed to go see the
movie Basic Instinct
so it's like I was like how did we go in
my 16 year old brain how did we go
backwards I was like I feel betrayed by
all the generations between Roman orgies
and now I was like how did we end up
here
it's cyclical everything is cyclical and
so once you understand the Cycles one it
can be a little daunting so if you read
Ray dalio's book principles for dealing
with a changing World Order
no oh it's gonna fill up your sleep so
you're welcome thank you but he uh he
outlines he goes back he goes back I
think to like 500 BCE but he really
focuses on the last 500 years and he
shows you this is all the loop and that
there are only so many personality types
and you can just watch culture Loop and
loop and loop and loop and cultures
build up and then they crash down the
next one builds up and then it crashes
down he's like it's freakishly
predictable it goes in six steps the
cycle does and there is not yet a
society in the last 2500 years that has
avoided this cycle that lasts about 100
to 150 years so
the reality is that I'm like
I don't think we get out of this
cultural momentum quickly I think that
the phrase tough men make good times
good times make weak men weak men make
Hard Times Hard Times make strong men
and you Loop and loop and loop and loop
and we have been in good times for a
long time and so I think we've
I'm just gonna keep doing myself damage
here I think we've gotten soft and I
think because of that we are headed for
hard times and I think the hard times
will
take care of any of the
values and belief systems that aren't
useful in the acquisition of skills I'm
not joking when I look at my important
time that I put on the schedule at a
minimum from eight to ten and I try to
make it like from six to ten like that
time is aggressively and only about
execution doing things so my list is
literally prioritized by Lee Domino's
what's the highest impact thing but I
also try to keep it to really painful
stuff all the things that need to be
done that I don't like doing like
contracts by contracts right so it is an
absurd amount of hours that in my
important time is just contracts right
because a they're important because
things will stop in the contract phase
because it's like there's always
something better to do so like just
making sure that every day I've got the
time carved out to do that and the the
Myriad other things that I don't enjoy
doing
to make sure that I'm not pacifying
myself because I get a chance to come on
here and talk so passionately about what
we're trying to accomplish that dude it
would be so easy to like five years from
now just still be talking about it and
like hey coming soon and never actually
moving it forward that's I have forced
that to become the most terrifying thing
in my life so yeah don't do that that is
a very real thing about The Human
Condition your mind will be pacified
simply by thinking about it so you've
got to hold yourself to a standard of
execution you've got to like keep a list
and say like hey like date it if you
have to so I put this on my list back in
July oh my God July like it's June and
I'm still not done that's Madness and so
that you have that level of
accountability to make sure that you're
checking things off and moving on and
that it really was a lead Domino like
audit yourself did I choose the right
things to put on my important list or
not or did like I go nowhere from these
things so yeah the human mind is
pacified by thought alone uh you're
gonna have to put things into practice
to make sure that you're you're actually
getting things done and then audio
yourself to make sure they actually
moved you forward the reason most people
fail to achieve their goals is twofold
number one they don't have a sufficient
level of clarity and number two they
don't want it badly enough the statistic
is that 92 of all people that set a New
Year's resolution failed to stick with
it the way that you go from being in the
92 percent to being in the eight percent
is by having a freakish level of clarity
and building so much desire in your life
that nothing could stop you even if it
tried this is what you need to do
the clarity piece is really the most
important thing that you can have in
your life and most people have a really
vague sense of clarity but because they
can say in a sense something like I'm
gonna win a gold medal they think they
have the clarity that they need but the
question I would ask somebody that told
me that they wanted to win a gold medal
is a gold medal in what the Olympics yes
Tom I want to win a gold medal in the
Olympics amazing which events swimming
or tennis swimming fantastic the
breaststroke the freestyle medley what's
it going to be you have to get so
specific with your goal that you know
what to do with the next 15 minutes of
your life ultimately success
accomplishing a goal seeing things
through all come down to what you're
doing with your time and what part of
your potential you're turning into
actual usable skill set the only way to
know how to spend your time transferring
your potential into skill set that is to
have a truly granular level of clarity
you cannot stop at the high level and
you can't do what a lot of people do
which is they as the Brits say they
waffle so when they're describing their
goal they either say something like I
want to win a gold medal which we just
covered is hopelessly vague or they say
something that's even worse which is you
know I really want to do something great
with my life I know that I'm capable you
know I was really athletic when I was a
kid and I know that if I applied myself
I could probably really you know
recapture what I was doing that's how
most people describe what they want to
do in life it is terrifying you need to
be able to State what your goal is in a
single sentence with no commas
parentheticals run-ons it needs to be a
very simple and direct goal something
like I'm going to win a gold medal in
the Summer Olympics freestyle medley
swimming event by 2028 whatever once you
have a go goal that is that specific
that contains the what you're going to
do the by when and the how much then you
know that you actually have a real goal
and not a hope not a vague idea but you
have something very concrete and
specific that you can execute against
now remember the goal is to translate
that into what you're going to do with
the next 15 minutes of your life always
and forever on and on and on when you
have something so specific that you know
how to break it down into those
incremental steps you can really begin
to make progress if you've ever heard
the idea of the 10 000 hour principle
it's talking about how we go about
actually achieving Mastery in something
and the punch line is that you spend ten
thousand hours applying yourself in a
disciplined fashion towards your goal
the discipline fashion is born out of
the clarity it's born out of the clarity
of knowing precisely what you're trying
to achieve and by when and knowing how
how to take advantage of I've tried
something it didn't quite work I need to
get a little bit better or this part of
my game is weak I need to focus on
getting better at that thing but again
all of that is born from clarity
and being able to break down that
Clarity into action items which is
absolutely critical because action items
are how we're going to turn our
potential into skill set and that is the
critical chain that you have to walk I'm
afraid of getting to the end of my life
and realizing that I did not
become the best version of myself
knowing that I got to the very end of my
life and I did not accomplish every
single thing I know I believe in my
heart that I deserve to have
I know the only thing that's stopping me
itself
I love that I think that's the right
fear and I think all of us should have
some form of that fear which if you
didn't hear is to have a vision of the
person you could become
and to reach the Pearly Gates as it were
see who you could have been contrasted
with who you actually are and be
disappointed by the gap between them
and I love chasing that I think it's a
beautiful Chase
but what I hope you guys will do if you
ever find yourself at the Pearly Gates
disappointed in how much farther you
could have gone
to Simply ask one question of yourself
every day
did I give it my all today
doesn't mean you're always going to win
yeah
if your life is a series of
yes I did
You've Won
You've Won guys the struggle is
guaranteed the struggle is guaranteed
the struggle is guaranteed the success
is not
and like the thing that I beg you guys
is to have the guts to fail at something
that you love
and when you were on the mud on your
face and people are laughing the I told
you souls are coming out
that you remember one simple fact
you loved what you were doing
and you left it out on the field what
the else is there
legitimately like I'm getting emotional
what the else is there what more
can you ask of yourself than to really
try to really say I give a about
this
that's the life to live that's the life
like to say I care about this it matters
it gives me purpose I'm gonna fight for
this this is a group of people I want to
serve
and I'm gonna go all the way out every
day and look you're not gonna hit it
every day there's going to be days where
you're off there's going to be days
where you're weak weak but if that day
instead of booking yourself instead of
saying I wasn't weak today what are you
talking about if that day you
own it and you say yeah I was weak today
and I'm not going to be weak tomorrow
but I'm not afraid to face that I'm not
afraid to accept that I'm not perfect
I'm not afraid to look in the mirror and
say today was a bad day that I didn't
make myself proud today but that
shouldn't diminish who you are it
shouldn't diminish your view of yourself
why because I wouldn't serve you
because if you beat yourself up today
you make it harder for you to be rad
tomorrow
it's a game that has to be seen in total
it's not a game where you can take a
snapshot and this is like what I
want you guys to understand in any one
moment I've looked like a fool so many
times I can't count
but when I look at my life in 10-year
chunks I'm freaked out by what I've
accomplished I was diagnosed with ADH
sorry I was diagnosed with hyperactivity
disorder when I was a kid that would
almost certainly translate today into a
diagnosis of ADHD so
I really struggle to stay on task so
this is something I've had to put a lot
of rules around in my life
so
because I distrust myself when I have
the impulse to do something I ask myself
is this actually going to move me
towards my goal yes or no if it moves me
towards my goal then I'm going to do it
but I also know that I'm prone to lie to
myself so oh wood looking at Tick Tock
right now move me towards my goal of
course I would I need to master the
algorithm 100 I should look okay wait
you're prone to lie to yourself so did
you make a list of the important things
you should be doing yes do you have a
calendar that tells you what you should
be doing right now yes so like in my
calendar I have a time that says
important things it's a free-form thing
so it's the moment where I'm most likely
to get myself in trouble because I'm not
doing the things that I should be so I
keep a list of important things that are
listed in order of what I need to
execute against so I'm goal obsessed and
to get goal obsessed I built desire to
build desire you do the following you
need to say internally this is my goal
and I'm obsessed
now hopefully that hits everyone
listening to this is stupid so basic
that it cannot be true but it
really is true you become what you
repeat so I tell myself this is my goal
and I'm obsessed
then I tell other people this is my goal
I'm obsessed I'm building the next
Disney for me say that a couple times so
and I'm obsessed with Disney okay that's
the first part but it's not going to get
you very far but if I do this
yo I'm gonna build the next Disney and
let me tell you why I'm gonna build the
next Disney because I used to Big
Brother for this little kid and I
watched his zip code Edom did you guys
know for real this is actually true
right now in the entire Western World
your ZIP code is the number one
predictor of your future success now
what I'm doing is embodying the way that
I want to feel at the beginning people
need to understand in the beginning it
felt fake to me because I was walking
myself through the process of building
desire I was saying it internally I was
saying it externally and I was embodying
the thing I wanted to feel
when I said it
the way that the brain works it will
justify whatever you do
it's one of the worst things about the
brain it's amazing because of the
psychological immune system but the
psychological immune system's job is to
keep you from committing suicide it is
not to help you get ahead in life
unfortunately
so your psychological immune system is
going to come up with a justification
for why you do whatever you do you can
actually there's a study done on this
with patients that have an inability to
term short-term memory into long-term
memory so you can re-meet them every
three minutes and they will not remember
meeting you so a doctor will walk in
they will put a pin in his hand he
shakes your hand it pokes you it hurts
you come back three minutes later you
don't remember meeting the doctor he
extends his hand to shake your hand and
the person with the selective or the
memory damage won't shake his hand
so you ask why won't you shake my hand
oh I don't like to shake the hand of
people in white lab coats oh I don't
shake the hands of doctors oh my
shoulder's hurting today I just don't
feel like shaking hands they're all lies
but the person doesn't realize that
they're lying now once you understand
it's easy you want to be with that
person and just be like oh well they
have brain damage of course they do that
no no we all do that so once you
understand that you have all these weird
things happening in your brain and one
of them is that it's going to make up an
excuse a justification for whatever you
do you can now leverage that so as I
tell people yo I'm really hyped about
the saying and it's because of your zip
code and like I really think that I can
help people get an empowering mindset
through story at scale they're going to
escape their zip code it's going to be
amazing makes me feel the way that I
want to feel I'm going to be able to
contribute this is amazing
now all of a sudden six months into that
repetition cycle I actually started
feeling it and it wasn't fake anymore
and I actually felt that like high level
of energy every time I would go to
explain it to people change the dynamic
of the way that you're thinking so that
you don't get trapped in your own
neurochemistry because when you have an
emotion
the chances are you believe that emotion
but the brain has this crazy weird
mechanism where however big you react it
goes oh it was that big of a deal so if
you freak the out and you're
yelling and screaming then your brain's
like yeah man it really it matters that
much like I said no cheese on this
hamburger
cheese on this burger
that is crazy you you can't do that
you can't put
get the flavor it says no cheese and
when you wind yourself up like that then
literally it just gets hardwired that
yeah this really is that catastrophic
but the reverse is true something
horrifying happens something terrible
goes wrong and if you can in your mind
just flip it and be like yeah we're
gonna figure this out how do you stay
focused in this world full of
distractions I often find myself
procrastinating and watching YouTube
videos forever alright so this really
does come down to habits and routines
this is one of those things I cannot
stress enough if you haven't built in
mechanisms to deal with your lesser
nature you're forever gonna fall prey to
them some of it is identity some of it
is I'm the kind of person who makes use
of my time some of it is I'm the kind of
person that has goals and I do that
which moves me towards my goals but then
some of it is reinforcing that belief
with very strict rules what I'll call
Bright lines so some of my bright lines
are I go to bed at 9pm period second
bright line I only have 10 minutes to
get out of bed so I wake up when I wake
up I don't use an alarm but once I
realize I'm awake then I only have 10
minutes to get out of bed as long as
I've had at least five hours so look at
the clock see what time it is I have 10
minutes boom I'm up and I emotionally
reward myself when I meet the deadline
and I emotionally punish myself if I
miss it and when I miss it by the way
it's usually by seconds it's not like
ever I'm just like it and I stay in
bed for 20 minutes that would not be a
bright line uh so but hard and fast 10
minutes emotionally reward yourself or
emotionally punish yourself whether you
do it or not and then just having a
compelling future it is so critical that
you have a compelling future that
there's actually something that you're
excited about and this makes me think of
Weekend Warriors for most people no one
has to tell you what to do on the
weekend you're very excited to do it you
get out of bed with some enthusiasm
there's something that you want to do
that day even if it's play video games
read watch a movie hang out with your
significant other whatever it is there
is something that you're excited and
there is a way and I won't answer it in
this question but there is a way to put
at the center of your life and all the
things you're doing to work and to build
something to put that thing that you
enjoy at the center of that so that
you're generating income off of
something that you love doing that is
very very possible here's the thing
about how happiness happiness is by
nature transient happiness is also a
neurochemical state
and for me to get out from under my
brain I finally had to understand that
neurochemistry
[Music]
is fickle and it changes from one minute
to the next in fact who's ever had a day
in the same day where you thought
I'm so amazing like this is crazy for
real are other people this good at
anything like I'm just and then I'm not
joking 40 minutes later you're like oh
and I am I can't believe I'm
never gonna succeed like this is a joke
I'm a total piece of who's ever been
there
all right that's essentially Universal
hands in the air so just know the next
time that you have one of those down
moments remember everybody else is
feeling that the joke is on all of us
we're all feeling it but we think we're
the only ones so we hide it so we get in
these Loops about happiness look
happiness comes and goes it's super
transient you're gonna feel it one
minute you're not gonna feel it the next
that is the nature of things
burn that notion into your head that is
the nature of things all right well if I
know that it's there if I know that it's
predictable then I'm not going to Let It
Whip me into a frenzy I know that as I'm
sure Mr J Shetty would say this too
shall pass
yeah
learn that phrase and learn it well this
too shall pass
the highs will pass the lows will pass
so don't focus on happiness it's too
transient
focus on fulfillment
fulfillment is defined very simply you
work very hard for a set of skills that
have meaning to you you care about them
in and of themselves and those skills
that you have worked so hard to obtain
they allow you to serve not only
yourself but others that's the key to
making this highly Social Animal
fulfilled and to have something that
sustains over time fulfillment is born
of suffering it's born of doing the hard
things so even in those dark moments you
can see beauty you can experience the
joy of being alive you can experience
the joy of having loved ones because it
endures
fulfillment endures my question is what
is the quickest way to learn about
crypto for anyone you so YouTube YouTube
unto itself is one of the greatest
inventions in modern history the fact
that any of us could go on right now and
take an MIT course for free on YouTube
if you type in cryptocurrency Bitcoin
ethereum whatever defy anything that you
want into YouTube You're Going to get a
slew of results in the beginning you
want to look for crowd validation so
what's got a lot of views that's going
to be a great place to start now may
have a lot of views and still be
worthless but it's a very good place to
start when you're learning anything new
first you need to understand the
language so every new area industry
topic all of that is going to have its
own vernacular its own jargon
and to really begin to understand it you
have to know what people are actually
talking about so first it's just hey
we're going to watch a bunch of content
and we're going to begin to learn the
words that people use now part of the
reason that I suggest doing this on
YouTube versus say books is that the
publication cycle is very long and
things in this space are changing so
rapidly that personally I probably only
watch about five percent of the content
that I consume on the topic of
cryptocurrency is more than a week old
now when it comes to voices that I
resonate with and everybody needs to
figure out whose thesis makes more sense
to them figuring out how people view the
world is very important uh Michael
Saylor for me is somebody that has
really been influential Rao Paul is
somebody that's been really influential
I've interviewed both of them as you go
deeper down the rabbit hole there's
Robert Breedlove as you start to like
learn about sovereignty and you start
asking questions like what is money
which is one of the more interesting
questions that you will need to begin
asking for cryptocurrency to make a lot
of sense then it gets incredibly
interesting and you'll be able to start
to create your own thesis about where
you think the world is going because you
understand humans which is ultimately
all this is about
markets are driven by people we want to
understand those people and then we can
make predictions on what they're going
to do with their behavior which is
essentially what a market is you have to
bet against the consensus bet against
the consensus and be right and that's
how you end up making money in any sort
of public market and you'll find
different people you'll find people that
talk about Buy and Hold Michael Saylor
you'll talk to people about what's
called macro investing understanding big
trends Rao Paul you'll find other people
that are more day tradery uh bitboy
crypto is a guy that like that's what he
talks about and in the beginning that
was like really fun for me and I watched
a lot of that content but then as I
realized uh that doesn't really fit my
personality I gravitated more towards
people that are looking at this as a
psychological transformation even more
than a transformation of markets eating
late is one of the biggest offenders
people end up eating a heavy meal
oftentimes an hour or two before they go
to bed I think that that is a huge
mistake a big part of what's going to
allow you to sleep in a relaxed state is
to not be digesting food so you want the
food to be able to work its way not just
through your stomach but through your
digestive tract because when you go to
sleep all of that shuts down what ends
up happening is if you've eaten this
large meal and that's sitting in your
stomach or your gut when you go to bed
then your body is going to stop working
on it and that can actually irritate
people which is why oftentimes people
will get stomach aches if they go to bed
too close to when they ate it isn't that
the food is in and of itself problematic
though I'm sure we'll get to the next
one many people are actually making
mistakes there as well the most common
mistake is just eating too close to
bedtime so you want to give yourself a
lot of hours before you end up going to
bed I'll get specific as I walk you
through how to fix these but just eating
too late that's a huge mistake that
people make so you don't want to do that
you want to give your body plenty of
time to be finished with that so it
isn't a distraction while you sleep it
isn't something that ends up upsetting
your stomach and that pain which
certainly I have experienced in my own
life ends up keeping you awake or just
disrupting the stages of your sleep
which is what happens to a lot of people
who don't even realize because their
whole life they've eaten so close to
bedtime they don't even realize that
it's diminishing their ability to get
quality deep sleep another thing that
people do is just their diet itself is
problematic so the most obvious symptom
that people get from eating a poor diet
is they have acid reflux now acid reflux
because it's literally acid building up
in your esophagus you can feel it
gurgling up from your stomach it is so
horrible it is one of the worst feelings
and trying to sleep like that no way are
you going to get quality sleep this is
where people start popping Tums which
that kind of thing is just suppressing
the symptom it's not getting to the root
cause it's going to be devastating to
your sleep a lot of times people will
try try to sleep sitting up it's really
a disaster so you want to be very
thoughtful about the kind of things that
you eat and there's a lot of literature
out there about how what you eat does
have an impact on how you sleep
carbohydrates for instance in your last
meal can have an impact on sleep and
deep sleep and so being very thoughtful
to do self-experimentation there's never
going to be a one-size-fits all but
making sure that you do
self-experimentation to know what kind
of diet you can eat to feel perfect when
you go to bed there is nothing that says
that you shouldn't feel perfect when you
go to bed if you don't feel perfect it's
either a timing or a diet issue and
you're going to want to figure out what
it is that's causing that unease when
you lay down to go to sleep AI isn't
going to be a little smarter than
Einstein it's going to be a lot smarter
not five times smarter or 10 times
smarter or even 10 000 times smarter
we're talking Millions of time smarter
and in case you think I'm exaggerating
futurist Ian Pearson told the world
government Summit that AI could become
billions of times smarter than humans
how because AI isn't limited by the
messy chemical-laden realities of being
a meat bag like we humans are we have to
wait roughly 20 years for the Next
Generation to be born rotosexual
maturity and have more kids AI on the
other hand is a non-biological system
that is only limited by the laws of
physics AI will be able to think at the
speed of light and will only be limited
by the ever increasing rate at which it
can learn to configure electrons in
novel ways the evolution of AI won't
play out over Millennia it will play out
first over decades than over years then
over months and finally over minutes or
even seconds until we reach the
technological singularity where AI will
be capable of making twenty thousand
years of human progress overnight
and if you want a mile marker for where
we're at in the march to the singularity
I'd say we're at the month stage at this
point how much longer it's going to take
to reach the actual Singularity where
the rate of change is so fast we can no
longer predict the future is anybody's
guess but futurist Ray Kurzweil predicts
it will happen by
2045. now why should you believe him
because approximately 87 of the
technological predictions he's made over
the last three decades have come true
and in just one month open ai's chat GPT
has gone from not existing to being used
by 100 million users AI works and it's
getting better every day
take a cold shower
we're doing all of this to accomplish
two goals
toughen up buttercup
and cognitively optimize so working out
as much as it's good for the brain it's
also to show you that you can do hard
things because in your life you need to
be doing hard things the other hard
thing you're going to do that's also
good for your brain and good for a whole
host of other things including
anti-inflammatory
um getting uh all the effects of
longevity that come from cold exposure
you're going to get in the cold shower
now the amount of time you need to stay
in the cold shower is going to depend on
the time of year and where you live
because let me tell you Minnesota in
February is very different than La in
August the cold temperature in La in
August not that cold so and compared to
and I've actually done this was it in
Minnesota no Chicago I did Chicago in
the winter I can't remember exactly what
month and the water hitting my forehead
gave me a headache I was like damn this
is a whole nother level of cold so doing
that versus in La was a world of
difference but in La I would keep myself
in the shower I think my record was like
oh God it was somewhere between 12 and
17 minutes I can't remember but for uh
what was it 13 months I did this every
single shower weekend no weekend
actually that might be a lie every
shower Monday through Friday that's
correct I think on the weekends I
allowed myself a warm shower don't hold
me to that I can't remember but for 13
months I took so many cold showers it
was horrifying in fact I stopped I
promised myself I'd do it for 30 days I
did it for 13 months I began to resent
my shower
but it is extremely powerful for doing
things that are difficult so we're going
to do the cold challenge expose yourself
for the cold as long as you can possibly
bear extend that period of time you
should be shivering before you get out
of the shower like uncontrollably
shivering that is a good way of knowing
if you've been in long enough I think
rules are one of the most underestimated
things people don't deploy that nearly
enough and so in my life I give myself
72 hours if I'm just not sure and I'm
really lamenting making a decision I
don't know like it's unclear I give
myself 72 hours to make a decision and
then I make it now I always protect my
downside and I never do anything that
could be a mortality event for the
company I want to make that abundantly
clear but assuming that I've hedged my
downside and assuming that even if it
fails catastrophically and even my
downside hedge doesn't stop this from
being an abject failure that I'm not
going out of business okay that's
critically important but within that I
give my so 72 hours and then I need to
take action now that doesn't mean that I
don't find small incremental ways to try
something to learn which is a huge part
of part of hedging my downside is how do
I stair step into this how do I put a
toe in and then a foot and then up to my
knee and then waist and then all the way
right and there is usually a way to walk
into that where you're not you know
biting off something that's going to
take you years and cost millions of
dollars before you'll even know if it's
going to work so finding that
incremental way to figure something out
and having that rule in your life that
you take action plain and simple here's
the trick to managing both love and
business step one you must choose well
selection is eighty percent of the
battle in Romance if you can't find
someone amazing masturbate and keep
looking because a bad relationship is
worse than no relationship at all that
goes for business and love unless you
want to split your company up in the
divorce don't mess up this step it will
be ruinous a business will not bring you
together any more than kids will it will
expose your flaws most of that is going
to be intensely personal you would
probably hate being married to me but my
wife swears that she loves it now maybe
there's just no accounting for taste or
maybe we selected well I'll let you guys
be the judge but here's a criteria that
we've refined over the years whenever
people ask this question all right
number one selection criteria It's gotta
be love it's a bit like pornography hard
describe but you'll know it when you see
it two you have to be committed to
maintaining a thriving sex life three
you gotta be committed to the
relationship as a whole four you both
need a growth mindset five you have to
share most of your values you're not
going to show them all but the vast
majority you should share six on balance
they need to be your equal you're going
to be good at different things but they
need to be your equal seven on balance
they need to be emotionally stable we
all fluctuate but on balance eight they
need to play a different role than you
it needs to be a complimentary role but
they need to play a different role nine
they need to legitimately want you to be
happy ten they need to take full
responsibility for their actions and
their emotional state all all of those
are important but Lisa and I's secret
weapon is that we both have a growth
mindset we focus on the relationship and
we are constantly trying to improve
we've always been receptive to critical
feedback because our goals are clear
that's incredibly important and we
understand that to achieve our goals we
have to constantly be getting better
constant never-ending Improvement is
required if you want to make meaningful
progress in your life now if you or your
partner doesn't already have that
mentality stop the video now and go
address that you simply will not succeed
working with your spouse if you don't
both have a growth mindset I'm telling
you right now you're not good enough to
pull this off yet every year around the
holidays I find it super challenging to
be with friends and family at all the
various parties and Gatherings with all
the cookies and cakes and alcoholic
beverages and not let everything go last
year I lost a whole bunch of weight this
year I want to try way to keep some of
it off do you have any strategies for
maintaining some discipline during the
holiday season thanks
I do all right so I have exactly one
strategy for
um maintaining the rules in my life and
that is bright lines now full disclosure
because I am so disciplined in my life
during the Christmas period I completely
let myself go ham and the only thing
that I steer by is uh physical suffering
so there's only so much junk food that I
can eat before I begin to feel sick or
get stomach cramps or my joints hurt so
that keeps me in check uh to some degree
but I don't want to give advice like I'm
moralizing I just want it because all
bets are off for me at Christmas but I
do want to give you the strategies that
I was would use or I should say I'm
going to give you the strategies that I
use year round that you can deploy at
Christmas that will work guaranteed it's
just a question of whether you want the
outcome badly enough to stick with it so
it is very easy not to have any alcohol
it is harder to have one alcoholic drink
because first of all once you have one
alcoholic drink it lowers your
inhibitions which makes you more likely
to have another one so you are literally
chemically more likely to make a
decision to have another drink when you
have one so not having any alcohol easy
having only one hard not having any
cookies easy having only one hard so I
go in with bright lines now for me and
this is where you have to translate for
you I'm so like
fetishistic
if I'm honest about bright lines and
being able to when I say I'm going to do
something I do it that I could go in and
say it cool my bright line is that I can
have 25 of one small cookie or whatever
so that I don't go looking for the
biggest cookie I can find and have 25 of
that I could do that now I probably
wouldn't if I'm honest I'm either going
to have fun let loose and have as much
as I want
or I'm gonna go in with bright lines but
bright lines will work no matter what it
is as long as you want the outcome
enough to essentially torment yourself
now
this is advanced class so I'm saying
what I would do is just abstain and so I
would set let's say if the Christmas
period is two weeks what I would do is
pick a number of times and let's just
make it a number of uh meals to keep it
easy we're going to pick a number of
meals that we're going to let ourselves
have fun and then the rest of the time
we're going to have just a binary we're
not going to do it so we walk in and
let's say over the two week period I'm
going to let myself go crazy four times
okay amazing so twice a week
for each of the weeks now pick the days
maybe it's going to be New Year's Eve
maybe it's Christmas day maybe it's
Christmas Day and Christmas Eve maybe
it's the first day of the holiday so
you've got the first day of the holiday
Christmas Eve Christmas Day and New
Year's Eve that's almost certainly what
I would do so but you're gonna pick some
number of days and then you're gonna go
cool on those days I'm gonna have one
meal where I get to go as crazy as I
want so to celebrate the beginning of
the holiday season I'm gonna go bananas
on my dinner or your lunch whatever is
more fun for you and you're gonna go Hog
Wild on that meal and
eat until your little heart is content
now when you do that you're going to get
to the point where you're full it's not
fun to eat anymore and then cool the
rest of your meals you're going to eat
normal food no cheap Foods whatever
you're going to need to get very clear
about what is and is not a cheat food uh
but you line that out now we've got
bright lines now the next day man that
was fun we really enjoyed yesterday
can we have more this day
there are two options either no you
cannot or cool if I want to move one of
my four days forward I can do that but
personally I would see that as a bad
sign I would see that as more addictive
behavior and you're not following your
map so were it me I would establish my
four days ahead of time and I would
stick to them no matter what your diet
is one of the most important things you
can do to boost your energy your focus
and your productivity what you should be
eating varies wildly and I will just
tell you right now that while I'm gonna
give you a very simple thing that you
can follow and it's going to take care
of 80 of all of your desires and
problems know that there is massive
variability at the individual level and
that you should be testing a lot of
different things to find out what is
right for you so what I'm about to lay
out is the sort of generic strategy that
I think everybody should try but getting
into the nitty-gritty is going to
require you to do a lot of testing there
is is no way around this I wish that
dieting was more simplistic but based on
your lifestyle based on your heredity
based on your microbiome all of this
stuff is going to dramatic to
dramatically vary so be very thoughtful
make sure you run experimentation having
said that what are the things that I
think are Universal number one you want
to be eating Whole Food whenever humanly
possible so you want to eat food that is
recognizable from what it was in nature
so a piece of meat should look like a
piece of meat it shouldn't be highly
processed your vegetables should look
like vegetables I mean you should be
brushing dirt off of them that kind of
recognizable from nature nuts should be
I mean ideally raw I'll be really honest
I do sometimes eat roasted nuts but if
I'm honest that's worse than if you're
just eating them raw so you want things
that are as close to
their natural state assumingly possible
the less that they have been messed with
manufactured altered in any way the
better off you're going to be I will say
that heat is something that I apply
apply to virtually all of my food there
are some really interesting theories
about from an evolutionary standpoint
that cooking is one of the things that
allowed us to grow the big brain because
by cooking it you not only soften the
food make it easier to chew but you also
release some of the nutrients beyond the
scope of this to get into that but when
I say raw I don't mean that everything
needs to be uncooked I just mean the
less processed the better things that I
eat every day I eat a lot of eggs red
meat I eat some chicken a bit of pork
but I'm eating a fair amount of meat so
I get a good portion of my calories from
that again individual variability if
you're doing a vegan thing word I'm
totally about it test for the individual
response that you get I find that the
more plant forward I go there's like a
breaking point where I start feeling
worse could be me it could be me doing
it poorly but as long as you're doing
whole food I think you're on the money
so eating whole food and making sure
that you're avoiding sugar that is like
the big thing so I don't think you can
eat fruit with impunity I think you have
to be very thoughtful about that if
you're on sure of what fruit is going to
impact you and how I highly recommend
getting a continuous glucose monitor
that will allow you to eat fruit if you
want and see what kind of glycemic
response you have for instance I find
that I can make certain fruit smoothies
and if I eat it slowly enough my
glycemic response will go up to about
120. I prefer to keep it in the 80s but
hey if it goes up to 120 and it's sort
of even and it comes back down I don't
consider that too problematic but if I
eat it really quickly and it spikes up
to say 140 150 that to me is problematic
and I don't want to be that high so you
can play with things also what you put
in the Smoothie Etc if you're going to
eat fruit and vegetables make sure that
you separate fruit and vegetables keep
those two things distinct I think you
will find by wearing a continuous
glucose monitor that you're going to
have a dramatically different response
to most fruit than you will to
vegetables again there's a lot of
variability here so the more that you
test on yourself the better but that's
really the the sort of generic response
if your or generic setup that I think
everybody should try Whole Food whenever
humanly possible avoid sugar keeping
your blood glucose below 100 I highly
recommend it for me I try to keep my
glucose in this the 80-ish range that's
sort of my default I also do
intermittent fasting I think that that
is very effective getting into things
like autophagy is beyond the scope of
what we're talking about right now but
even that I think it's going to be huge
body composition is greatly affected by
intermittent fasting again individual
variability make sure that you
experiment with this stuff for yourself
I do when you average it out I think I
went about 18 months where I was
tracking every day my average over that
extended period of time was 17 and a
half hours so on the weekends it's it's
shorter but on the weekdays sometimes
it's longer sometimes it's 19 20 21 22
hours that I'll go uh between meals but
again over a very extended period of
time it averages out to 17 and a half
hours of not eating now the way that I
do that I have my last meal around 1 15
definitely done chewing by 2PM and then
I don't eat again until the next day at
around 9 9 30 somewhere around in there
shorter on the weekends longer during
the week and it it balances out I'm
having everything from green leafy
vegetables like bok choy uh collard
greens kale broccoli
to carrot jicama I do occasionally have
some sweet potato it'll be a little
thoughtful about that one watch your
glycemic load that definitely spikes me
more than green leafy vegetables but
those are the mix that I use again I'm
eating Whole Foods virtually all of my
calories come from Whole Food during the
week in fact I'd say 95 percent of my
calories come from Whole Foods very rare
that I deviate from that but doing that
allows me to have tremendous focus a lot
of energy get the most out of my
workouts maintain my body composition
keep my fat low keep my glycemic spikes
low so I'm not getting you know blood
sugar spikes which helps me maintain my
energy through the day and also just
from a longevity standpoint I think
that's a great idea I will say go look
at David Sinclair he's got some pretty
compelling information around the fact
that Meats may not be great for
longevity so while it makes me feel
awesome that's something called mtor so
be thoughtful as you get into the
complex weeds of this stuff nutrition is
a very big complex topic again the only
things that I consider universals are
whole food and reducing sugar universals
close to a universe will be intermittent
fasting though some people can have
differing responses to that so be
thoughtful as you experiment with this
stuff but if you do that like I said 80
plus percent of your problems are going
to go away that's a nice low
inflammation diet and keeping your
inflammation low is incredibly important
that's an incredible question this is
something that I have lived through so
when Quest was small it was very easy
for me to do what I was saying at the
top lead by example I was there on the
production line I would take the hardest
job and we would would literally agree
what is the hardest job this is the
hardest job cool if this is the hardest
job I'm going to be the one that that's
going to do it and I would get in there
and I would do it with all my might and
Not only would I do it but I would
uplift other people I would bring energy
and enthusiasm and I'm an introvert by
Nature let me tell you right now now In
fairness I have a pretty easy time going
to extroverted so my default though is
introverted Now by going on the line by
encouraging other people by taking the
hard job all of a sudden it was very
easy for me to get people to Rally
behind me but as we scaled the company
now all of a sudden there were a ton of
people that had never seen me
working like that so to them I was
almost a mythological figure by that
point I was creating YouTube content so
you know we had 3 000 employees many of
them had never met me
and so to them you know it was like oh
my God that's the guy that runs a
company or the guy that's on YouTube
whatever and it had a really problematic
effect on the way that they approached
me and so what I began to realize is you
have to have a culture you have to show
people up close what gets results
intoxicate them with certainty okay
that's a huge part if you really want to
take your leadership game to the next
level you want to make sure you know
exactly what needs to be done so within
the world of influence you're trying to
have you know where you're trying to go
so you have a goal very clear goal you
can articulate that goal this is where
we're going and then you never
and I mean never
let somebody outwork you and when you
have certainty on where you're going you
tell other people what that is we're
going to go after this most people live
their entire lives doubting themselves
doubting the path that they're going on
and even when you know and some element
of what I'm saying isn't going to work
out but you believe to the core of your
being I'll adjust I'll figure it out now
you can intoxicate people with certainty
and just go like a bat out of hell
towards that thing working in a way that
nobody else is going to match and if
when you do that you elevate those
around you rather than say hey why are
you losers not working as hard as me you
say hey we're a team I want to lift you
up I want to help you I want to help you
get there okay so now you establish that
with those around you in that near group
you make that the culture this is how we
move here this is what we're about so
you're as good as what you can write
down so you write down what that culture
is you let people know what it means to
be a part of this team
then when they get in you're encouraging
them you're elevating them
you start with the people closest to you
because you're you've been able to write
the culture down you know which way they
have to act you hold them accountable
you ask them to hold you accountable
right you're not trying to be above this
you're trying to be in it trying to show
people what it means so now you've got
your core group then they're going to
have their Core group and then that Core
group is going to have their Core group
and now that influence goes down so you
definitely have to set the example but
when you scale you have got
you have got
to get people to understand what the
culture is
get them to lead by example get them to
intoxicate people with certainty get
them to
show people what it means to have a goal
and to go after it and to live up to the
standards of that culture and now when
you elevate people and you're lifting
them up and you're not trying to beat
them down
then you get something really really
incredible then people will follow you
because it's a game of elevation it's a
game of skill acquisition it's a game of
goal accomplishment it's not
you're not wasting people's time you're
really making progress and progress is
one of the most foundational pillars of
human happiness I really want people to
understand that
that there's a reason that this ends up
becoming a result that you can achieve
and if I could get people to understand
that as you change your mindset it isn't
a woo-woo thing right it's like this is
really gonna
um you will to use your example you will
end up spending your time on things that
are actually going to yield the results
you want and so you talk about this in
the book it's like you need to have
Clarity you need to know what you're
going for now if you know what you're
going for and you're making decisions
that don't move you towards that then
the question becomes why and so if
you're trying to people please now you
have a bifurcated path of goals this was
the biggest breakthrough in my life
there are a few things in my life where
it's like this is a demarcation point
and my life looks fundamentally
different after this moment than before
and it was when I realized I was
worshiping two different Masters what
were those Masters so one was what I
really believed was my driving goal
which is to be successful and then the
unknown goal that I had but was actually
driving a significant amount of my
behavior was I wanted other people to
think I was smart and so I'm I'm arguing
with the guys that end up becoming my
partners but at the time they're just my
employers and I am like I need to to
have them agree that my idea is the
right idea so that they'll realize that
I'm smart and so why did you need that
though
why why did I need them to think I'm
smart yeah oh insecurity so I was
unfortunately doing what so many of us
do and I was Outsourcing my
um my esteem to other people now this
gets it's very nested and I'll try to
make sure that we come back up to the
core idea but we are both the shout and
the Echo and one of the reasons that I
have a hard time speaking in bumper
stickers is that there really is Nuance
so you can tell people don't worry about
what other people think but it won't
work right because we're a social
creature and you are both the things you
do and how you feel about yourself but
what you do and how it echoes in the
world will influence you just it is the
way the human mind is wired so there are
all these real consequences to the
things you do so going back to I'm I'm
fighting myself yes not even realizing
I'm fighting myself I have a known goal
be successful an unknown goal make sure
other people think you're smart and so
I'm in this moment where I'm arguing for
this idea uh subconsciously because it's
going to make me feel good if I can win
because I'll think well if I convince
them then they'll realize that I'm
really smart so anyway but inside my
mind I've got this voice screaming this
is the wrong idea and this will move you
backwards your idea yeah oh 100 so in
what you're fighting yes and so when
they finally acquiesce and they're like
okay we'll do it that way and and see
what happens they leave the room and I'm
like what have I done like do I want to
be successful or not and so then I
finally okay pull these both into my
conscious mind figure out what I was
really doing realize that I had these
two competing goals and so to your point
heal the thinking first because if you
have a wound or whatever that's making
you think less of yourself or think you
need other people to think that you're
smart that's it it has an impact in your
ability to achieve your goals I haven't
set an alarm in in now jeez how many
years has it been like 15 years 16 years
something like that maybe 17 years at
this point so it has been a very long
time since I set an alarm and I do that
for the two reasons that I mentioned
before I do not want the stress of the
alarm that I know it's going to be going
off at some point and then I also want
to make sure that I let my body get as
much sleep as it needs so many people
live in a chronically sleep deprived
state so make sure that you're really
careful about that and then like I said
before I work out really hard so that I
fall asleep really fast and then while I
don't do anything to diminish the
electrical outputs of devices like I
sleep with my phone next to me obviously
I'm listening to a book so of course I
am
um I don't turn my Wi-Fi off at night or
anything like that I have not noticed
that that's had a big impact but I will
say that there are things out there that
indicate that that may be an issue I
think that getting your thoughts in the
right place is hugely important and if I
were diagnosed with cancer let me tell
you
go do or don't do you would do chemo I
would do all of it everything 100 so
would I so would I
um and it's not about not using modern
medicine it's about being wise and smart
and doing what you need to do again
I try to find every tool possible
to to heal myself or to overcome pain I
would use every tool imaginable I would
eat perfectly I would think the right
way I would do the modern medicine I
would do all of it I have a feeling and
this is a guess and I fully recognize
there are things I just don't understand
but I have a guess that
your thoughts really matter they have a
huge impact on your biology but at the
end of the day this is just a cellular
game and that your thoughts are
affecting your biology and thusly one
needs to be thoughtful about that
yes my take could you make do you think
you can make yourself sick with your
thoughts that is clear so do you think
you could heal yourself with your
thoughts but I think you can undo the
things you can think your way into I you
can probably stop
creating you almost certainly can stop
creating more problems through the
thoughts but the reality is you could
have reverse the things you probably
could reverse some of it but the reality
of the way the
um like take a cancer cell for instance
so in fact maybe an even easier one if
you think about the microbiome the
microbiome is very treatable through
diet and things like that until you
start getting biofilms and the
microbiome can actually protect itself
with by creating like this slime that
will stop things from being able to
penetrate it so there really is a sort
of point of no return where it's like
hey maybe like your stress because
levels of stress are going as far as I
know the literature backs up that stress
levels will impact cancer
and so that is you getting into a state
that's Korea creating a problem with
your biology but the biology then can
get and I'm guessing here I don't know
the data well enough but my gut instinct
is that
given what I know about how mechanisms
can become runaway mechanisms
that's hard to reverse yeah that there
there comes a point where you're just
not going to think your way out of it I
agree with that so after a certain point
for sure that might be too hard to the
body might have gone too far
and it might be harder to get back and
that even if you are sort of thinking
your way to uh root of it that's still
solvable that you're doing it through
biology and so yes if one was it's it's
a bit like
um
if you said hey you have to put on 35
pounds of muscle because you're going to
start filming a movie in six weeks I
would like steroids please yeah so even
though I can really work out and no
matter what if I take the drugs or not
I'm gonna have to work my ass off but
the odds of me getting there without the
intervention are basically zero we're in
a three-dimensional World biology game
yeah we're in a three-dimensional world
but I feel like our thoughts can
influence this world in a big way that
you and I can agree on violently we need
to co-evolve with AI remember AI is a
tool instead of stepping back and just
saying well whatever happens happens
let's use AI to keep up with AI it's
obvious to me that the path board is
completely unpredictable in the
specifics but directionally I think it's
safe to say that we're not going to
outperform AI by ourselves we're going
to need the help of AI itself to
paraphrase Sam Altman the founder of
openai I have no idea how open AI is
going to become a big business I'm going
to build a super intelligence and then
ask it how to do it now we set a
tongue-in-cheek but it's actually pretty
true now putting my doe eyed optimistic
atom for a second there's another
critical thing to focus on in the near
future AI is going to make your life
much much better it's going to extend
your capabilities in ways that will make
you feel like a superhero it's already
happening AI is being used to help
doctors researchers drivers Pilots
writers artists therapists musicians
soldiers entrepreneurs investors and
many many more I don't think people
fully understand how integrated narrow
AI already is doctors are going to be
able to detect and treat cancer earlier
and less invasively drugs will be tested
virtually massively speeding up
Effectiveness and time to market energy
costs are going to plummet and that will
create a Cambrian explosion in
life-saving and life improving
Technologies and not the least of which
will be the proliferation of access to
clean water I assume you already know
about self-driving cars flying cars
reduced deaths from dangerous jobs and
better emergency response options it
really will be an endless Cavalcade of
Miracles and that's why this fight is
worth fighting it's worth facing things
head on and doing this well it is going
to be amazing and terrifying but whether
it turns into a Utopia or a demon
summoning circle is going to be up to us
even though we will lose control of our
child far too soon as every parent knows
if we give AI a good foundation if we're
thoughtful about it and don't give in to
fatalism I think we can have just enough
influence to make this turning point in
history the moment when the rate of
progress tilts even stronger towards the
good just as a long Arc of History bends
towards Justice I believe the long Arc
of progress bends towards the good
especially if the bending is intentional
as a kid I dreamed I'll be the provider
which made me feel very powerful and
then I I don't I don't advise anyone to
take for granted how powerful that is
now typically for a guy but not always
um but for a guy as a you know looking
at the bell curve sort of right in the
middle I would say most guys that gives
them this sense of like pride and
purpose and meaning which do not
Overlook that you you have to process
through it at a minimum you don't have
to accept it but you have to understand
it and
so that's always what I wanted I wanted
more than anything to be able to work so
that you could stay at home not
realizing that that would not be
fulfilling for you but I didn't even
understand fulfillment at the time so I
get that you're taking care of me you're
really allowing me to build the business
and I suddenly had this real like
heartbreak for people who the husband
and wife choose the husband goes and
works the wife doesn't they end up
getting divorced and the wife's like
what the we had always agreed that
I was going to help you build your
career and now I'm having to start over
and I had this real sense of like yo I
could not do what I'm doing I couldn't
work as hard or be as focused if you
weren't facilitating my life which is
why I always said you were the CEO of
billu Enterprises it's like you were
making sure that I was able to go do all
of the things I wanted to do kept the
house in order it was like you would
tell me where to be when are we doing
what and all that and that was
incredibly incredibly valuable so to me
it was like hey this is working this is
amazing
um not yet understanding you're not
being fulfilled I see you start to take
off all the things you were doing before
they stopped getting done there's a
little sense of like oh whoa like that
meaning and purpose that I had before
it's it's not making sense anymore and
so now I'm losing connection to what I
thought was my role and I'm losing you
know some very amazing perks of being in
this relationship and I need a red hot
minute to to get through that and so I
thought that I was like
you know I'm not being as like yeah yeah
like do what you want do your thing and
so I needed that second to reorient what
did that process look like in your mind
it was entirely the phrase there would
be nothing more
um
nothing would shatter my own values
faster than not wanting you to be
exactly what you want to be and
supporting you every step of the way so
it was like yes you feel some kind of
way about losing something that you had
both the vision and just like you said
it's rad to have somebody who's looking
after you 24 7. it's amazing and so yes
you're losing that and yes it doesn't
feel good anybody that would ask you to
be like this is awesome
um it's just not being realistic but at
the same time like at the absolute core
of my being is I want you to be happy
but like fulfilled happy at like the
deepest core part of your soul and
whatever room we have to make in the
relationship for that to happen then we
need to do it we need to do it
immediately and and that to me man
that's just like if you want your
relationship to succeed in the long run
you really do have to put the the bond
the pair as the the primary importance
right you can't pretend you don't have
your wants and needs but you also can't
pretend that the other person doesn't
have theirs and they are of equal
importance like no matter because at the
time I was the breadwinner for sure and
so there was no like well you're the
breadwinner she should take the back
seat it's like no like whatever you're
doing half that just hers she has earned
it so whatever you guys have
um
you need to make that space and I really
really really really believe and view us
as equals we all have 24 hours in our
day we have 365 days a year
plus leap year when it comes around and
most people just aren't making the most
of it most people don't have rules in
place most people don't know what
they're trying to accomplish most people
don't drag their ass out of bed and get
to work but if what you love to do is
the thing that you do when you get up it
really is pretty extraordinary here's
the thing that we're all up against
you've got all this potential
you can turn it into skill set but the
thing that's required is time and energy
so you need to get sleep to have the
energy and you need to get out of bed to
get the time now there's something about
getting up when it's dark when the world
just feels slow people aren't texting
you they're not emailing you it's just
you and the things you're trying to
accomplish when you take advantage of
that time and by the way you're going to
be sharp you're going to be fresh maybe
not in the first 30 minutes when you
wake up but man once you get that engine
turning which is why I recommend that
you work out first thing in the morning
once you get that engine going
and you're up to speed those are going
to be the most high performative hours
of the day and so you want to make sure
that you're taking advantage of that
time so that you can really get things
moving so get up get going take
advantage of that set goals know what
skills you have to acquire use that
additional time that you get from
getting up and getting right to it to
stack those skills and accomplish the
things that you want and once you
understand that stacking skills is how
you do something great but stacking
skills takes time then you'll start
putting the right rules in place in your
life to make sure that you do the things
that you need to do to be energized get
out of bed and get after it so stop
making excuses structure your life in a
way that is set up
to give you the space that you need to
get this all done don't make excuses
just get after it if you want to make
the most out of your time you really
have to be very thoughtful about the
things you do the first couple of hours
after waking up I have a very strict
routine that I've been adhering to in
one form or another it does very
slightly depending on what I'm doing in
my life but I have a very narrow range
of things that I do immediately after
waking up in the beginning of my
business career first of all I knew
nothing so people were right to question
me why I was there what the value I was
offering and I remember in the beginning
this was back at a technology company
when I first started I was hired as a
copywriter with by the guys who would
later become my partners but at the time
I was just an employee and people were
asking who's the kid in the server room
I was the youngest person in the company
nobody took me seriously I was working
in an office where everybody had
floor-to-ceiling windows with a view of
the Pacific Ocean it was absolutely
stunning except for me and I was put in
the server room which is the sort of
business equivalent of Harry Potter
living under the stairs I didn't have
any windows I remember being so
embarrassed bringing my wife to the
office because there were no windows I
didn't even have like a proper desk I
just sat in a room full of the servers
that were running the technology that we
were building
and I thought okay nobody takes me
seriously I remember one guy we ended up
letting him go and he was so pissed that
I was in the room uh during his
termination and so
there was a lot of sort of pressure
against me people thought that um
rightly so by the way in the beginning
that I didn't know what I was doing and
it took so much time and energy to grow
and get to the point where I was adding
enough value that I couldn't be denied
and that took me years
but I put in that work I picked the
things that I wanted to get good at I
put an inhuman amount of effort I'm
talking working to the point where my
wife finally had to pull me aside and
say you're now damaging the marriage you
were working so much so I recognized
that what this was was a game of skill
set and if a normal person was going to
be convinced of my skills
um you know say at Point C these guys
weren't going to be impressed by my
skills until Point Q fine I'm aiming for
Point Z and I'm gonna go that hard I'm
not gonna ask permission I'm going to
really try to add value I'm not going to
see this is antagonistic I'm not going
to take anything on I'm not going to see
like you know them and I'm just trying
to beat and crush them what I wanted to
do was get so good that I could deliver
so much results tangible results for the
company that people would want me on
their team and that more and more people
would covet to have me help them that I
would reach out to people and try to add
value to them even if it wasn't my job
and just see what are the things that I
can do to help and by a adopting that
attitude knowing that as I was helping
people I was getting better I was
becoming more valuable I was taking
things on myself I was trying to look
beyond my job description I was just
trying to get so freakishly good that
one I could go anywhere if I wanted to I
didn't have to stay in that company two
if I'm honest at that point what I was
trying to do was earn equity in the
company so for five years I didn't ask
for a raise I just put my head down and
all I wanted to do was become a partner
and I was just learning and learning and
learning and learning and if somebody
made fun of me dunked on me
um yelled at me whatever I just
self-soothed that was the big thing was
I realized one of my superpowers was I
could self-soothe faster than anybody
else I could focus on skill acquisition
and I tied my identity entirely my
entire ego all of my pride was around
getting better
and by focusing relentlessly on skills
not worrying about other people in fact
trying to help them take on way more
than my job description put time in
nights weekends to learn a skill set
that I knew would be valuable to the
company and I wasn't even asking for
anything in exchange I just wanted to
prove
that I could get so good that they were
better off offering me a piece of the
company than losing me to somebody else
and that like that's that thing it's
become so frowned on in this culture to
work more than you're being compensated
for and I'm telling you right now if you
really want an extraordinary life
trying to optimize for your dollars in
the short term is a losing proposition
you want to over deliver consistently at
a freakish level and then when you've
done that
then you can make real demands demands
that will change your net worth forever
that's commanding respect I have a
question for you I would love your
thoughts your suggestions around the
holidays and loneliness and anxiety and
depression and sadness everything that's
that's just ick that goes along with
that I am a single mom I'm an empty
nester and
I don't have a lot of family most of my
family is
most my family is deceased
so
this year feels harder and it feels
heavier that being said anything that
you can suggest that would help me avoid
ending up in the fetal position the
entire holiday season so I could truly
focus on what matters most in life
thanks Tom
[Music]
man I wish we were together because I
really want to know what matters most in
life to you
um so here's here's what I would do
without knowing what that answer is
because certainly if what matters most
is family then we want to map out how
and when are we going to be able to
spend time with the family that we do
have so whether that's your kids and
traveling to them or having them travel
to you and figuring out how many days
there are going to be of that
but really mapping this stuff out now
let's take a really hard approach to
this let's make it like the just
absolute dire straits issue let's say
that every single friend that you have
and every single family member that you
have is unavailable and you're not going
to be able to see them all right we're
going to want to do a couple of things
with our time to make sure that we're
getting more energy than we're losing
that we're doing things that are fun
we're doing things that fill us up so
some of that is going to be just what
are the things that excite you right so
for me for instance I have no problem
watching movies by myself so putting out
a slate this is this is what I would do
I so one thing my wife has taught me is
you can take an average Tuesday and make
it special by doing certain things so
for instance when covid first kicked off
and we thought it was just going to be a
couple weeks uh we completely changed up
our routine and so normally Monday
through Friday if I'm awake I'm either
working or working out to make covid
special we invited my sister over to my
house we played video games starting at
five o'clock we were watching anime it
was really really fun and just by
breaking out of our routine and doing
something that was more enjoyable it
completely changed the dynamic so if
you're not able to hang out with people
but there are things that you like doing
and you can break yourself out of your
normal routine for instance I would if I
were going to be alone I would schedule
out different Christmas movies that I
wanted to watch and I would schedule
them out in a way where I couldn't
change them because then what ends up
happening is you're like oh man I can't
wait till Tuesday or whatever when I get
to watch this movie that I'm saving for
myself for that day so there's something
about how and and I would leave some
wiggle room so I would let's say I had
two things planned that I was going to
watch one is scheduled one is not then I
would also you have to find the things
that make you happy you have a lot
a lot of really dumb beliefs that you
have mistaken for objective truth
everybody gets trapped inside their own
minds nobody more so than me and because
we all get trapped inside of our own
minds if you really want to make change
in your life the first thing you're
going to have to do is recognize what
those beliefs are unwind them and then
you can begin to layer the new beliefs
in and that's the second thing is you
need to build up a set of beliefs that's
going to take you where you want to go
now we live in what many people refer to
as a post truth World well I'm here to
tell you boys and girls that the truth
is going to slap you about the head neck
and chest as much as you would like to
avoid it or hope pray pretend that it
isn't real we are all beholden to the
way the world works and the world Works
in some some kind of way and we all
filter everything through our brain and
that is the third thing that you are
having a biological experience there is
a reality to be faced so let me thread
the needle between these two things so
you're going to be building up this set
of beliefs and you're going to be doing
it
in a way that recognizes the truth of
the way that the world is including your
own biology so what do I mean by you
have to layer on beliefs so you have all
these false beliefs that you're
mistaking as reality
you're going to recognize those you're
going to begin unwinding them now you're
going to figure out what the truth is
the truth very simply is that which most
efficiently moves you towards your goals
now what do I mean by that
so if you think in the beginning there
was Newtonian physics and that helped
everybody understand how the planets
were revolving around the Sun it helped
describe the motion of large bodies as
they say but then Einstein came around
and even though Newtonian physics opened
up the world and answered a lot of
questions and moved us a step closer to
the truth and at that time you could
have said hey Newtonian physics are the
truth and you would have been
effectively right it was the most
effective thing that we had to move us
forward now instead of it being a
post-truth world when we realize oh
actually Einstein has a version that
allows us to even more efficiently move
towards our goals so for instance we
could not have had GPS with Newtonian
physics it wasn't until we had
relativity and special relativity that
we were able to get so precise that we
could nail down someone's position add
speed to within a couple of feet so it
required us to get even better better at
predicting the outcome of our actions
and so when people ask me what the truth
is what I tell them is whatever belief
allows you to most accurately predict
the outcome of your actions now that
doesn't mean that you're making it up it
means your ability to predict the
outcome of your actions is tied to what
is real so the reason that you're more
able to predict the outcome of your
actions when you understand in the case
of physics Einstein's general relativity
and special relativity is because it
gives you a higher degree of accuracy so
it isn't that Newtonian physics were
wrong they were directionally correct
it's just that we're always refining now
as most physicists will tell you there's
actually something Beyond
einsteinian physics I think that's how
you would say that and that is what they
call the theory of everything so there's
a gap between
relativity and special relativity and
quantum physics and nobody quite knows
what that thing is it's going to bridge
all of that together so even though
we're not all the way the
progress that we've made from Newton
from like uh the Bible tells us
everything that is true to Newtonian
physics and then to relativity and
special relativity and now there's going
to be something even beyond that and
each time that we get closer to the
truth we're able to predict more and
more things that's how you need to think
about unwinding the poor beliefs that
you have which are moving you away from
your goals because they do not give you
a frame of reference with which you can
most accurately predict the outcome of
your behaviors and your actions and so
you're trying to then strip those away
get to the ones that more efficiently
move you towards your goals and again
the only reason that you're going to be
moving more efficiently towards your
goals is because that belief is more
accurately aligned
to the way the world actually works
including your own biology and your
brain and the way that you distort and
interpret the world your brain
unfortunately is not designed to give
you an accurate representation of the
world your brain is designed to keep you
alive long enough to have kids that have
kids
and the difference between
what evolution thought would be most
useful to keep you alive long enough to
have kids that have kids and what
actually is most useful in a modern
context there is a gap and that Gap
leads to things like obesity
diabetes Alzheimer's all that kinds of
stuff because all of our impulses lead
us to behave in a way that made sense
when food for instance was hyper scarce
but now that that food is not hyper
scarce we find ourselves in a position
where we're just constantly overeating
and people get themselves in trouble so
once you begin to realize oh wait a
second just following the impulse to eat
is not a useful way to determine whether
I should consume something or not so I'm
going to refine my beliefs around that
that sometimes I'm actually going to
ignore hunger or I'm going to get a
better understanding of macronutrients
and how they act as signaling molecules
and so in the case of diet this is a bit
like going from not knowing anything to
Newtonian physics right then to getting
all the way to like the really fancy
stuff where uh we're able to use food
science to do things like a fasting
mimicking diet so on and so forth so
just to re-anchor us you start with all
of these beliefs that are cobbled
together through run-ins with your
family and what they believe to be true
run-ins with uh failure in life
embarrassment your friends pop culture
all of that stuff and that steers you to
want things to think of the world in a
certain way to love certain things about
yourself to hate certain things about
yourself all of that which is creating
this jumbled mess in your mind of how
things should be
which is further Complicated by the
biology of having a brain that was
created slowly and blindly over millions
of years of evolution and
as you begin to understand things like
and this is not this again is a partial
truth but it will get you directionally
in the right direction that the brain is
comprised of three layers again only
directionally accurate and you have what
they call the lizard brain at the center
all Instinct all the time then you've
got the mammalian brain all emotion all
the time and then the outer layer you
have the
um human brain we'll call it which is
the
um the part that is able to
process higher level cognition and so
when you understand that you have a
brain directionally that's made of those
three layers
then you can begin to realize oh so I
don't just need to just like I'm not
going to use hunger as the determining
Factor as to whether or not I eat I'm
going to have a more nuanced
understanding of my biology and why I
might feel hungry even when I don't need
calories I'm not just going to listen to
my emotions I'm going to realize that my
brain works in some kind of way and I
need to layer in a belief system about
how the brain works that allows me to
more accurately predict the outcome of
my actions so instead of just being
emotional which is going to lead me to a
sub-optimal
pattern of behavior where people get
angry at times we're building a bridge
would be a more appropriate response or
even just calming yourself down or they
are fearful in the face of an
opportunity take speaking in public for
example much of My
Success at impact theory has been built
to my ability to speak in front of a
camera or in front of a live audience
but nonetheless I had all kinds of fear
especially in the beginning of doing
that and so recognizing oh that fear was
meant to keep me alive when I was a part
of a hunter-gatherer band of people and
I had to be very careful about pissing
off uh anybody that was in charge and I
could find myself isolated and so I had
to fight through that emotional layer to
get to a cognitive logical layer that
allowed me to come up with a belief that
it was okay if I failed it was okay if I
risked things and embarrass myself it's
even okay if I get pushed out of one
group I can always find another right in
a modern context all of that makes a lot
more sense and so as we refine our
thinking and build this new set of
beliefs we can actually get closer again
to predicting more accurately the
outcome of our behaviors because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
some something but they don't ever do
the work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one interview with Tom check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I was worth two
million dollars on paper and I've never
been more unhappy in my life somebody is
gonna get started in crypto and nfts has
a similar mentality I don't understand
this stuff I'm not a money guy the rich
keep getting richer